GOOD MORNING I'D LIKE TO
CALL -- THE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER. TWO TO
ORDER A DECISION REMINDER ON THE
PUBLIC COMMENT WHAT'S BEEN MY
MODEL IS THAT FOR ISSUES THAT
ARE HELD OPEN I'M GOING TO HAVE
THE PUBLIC HEARING AT THE END OF
THE DEPARTMENTS.
IN A BATCH OF ISSUES IF WE'RE
GOING TO DO A VOTE ON IT I'LL DO
IT.
AS WE MAKE THE PRESENTATION I'M
SO WITH THAT WE HAVE EIGHT
MATTERS THERE ON VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR THIS IS ITEMS ONE
THROUGH EIGHT IS THERE A MOTION
TO APPROVE -- BUT CORPSMAN CALL
THE ROLL SORRY [inaudible]
I CASCADE [inaudible]
SOUNDS.
A QUIET.
MORNING HERE THANK.
AND HAVING BEEN ESTABLISHED THIS
IS ISSUES ONE THROUGH. EIGHT FOR
VOTE ONLY ANY MEMBERS THAT WANT
TO REMOVE SOMETHING FROM THE BUT
ON THE COUNTER.
THERE'S A MOTION BY CENTER
MONNING PLEASE CALL THE ROLL I
CASKEY.
HI [inaudible]
REQUIRE [inaudible]
MONEY [inaudible]
STERN.
OUR MEMBERS THE SERVICE TURNED
TO ISSUE NUMBER NINE WE HAVE THE
LA OWES OFFICE IS HERE TO GIVE
US A PRESENTATION ON COASTAL
ADAPTATION.
MISS TAYLOR.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
COMING.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
THE TIME MAKE US OF THE SURGEON
IS GOING TO PASS AROUND A HAND
OUT FROM WHICH I WILL SPEAK.
I ENTITLED COASTAL ADAPTATION
IT'S ALSO ON OUR WEBSITE FOR
THOSE.
NOT ON THE DíAS -- SO STAFF IS
ASKED ME TO GIVE AN OVERVIEW OF
A BRIEF REPORT WE PUT OUT IN OUR
BUDGET PUBLICATION IN FEBRUARY --
IT PROVIDES CONTEXT FOR THE
RELATIVELY MODEST BUDGET
PROPOSALS THAT ARE BEFORE YOU
TODAY BUT REALLY OUR INTENTION
WAS THAT IT ALSO CREATE A
FRAMING FOR A MUCH LARGER
CONVERSATION THAT.
LIKELY WILL BE FACING YOU IN THE
MONTHS AND YEARS TO COME AROUND
COASTAL ADAPTATION -- SO TURNING
TO PAGE ONE OF THE HAND OUT
CALIFORNIA'S COAST FACES THE
THREAT OF RISING SEEDS AND TAXIS
AND TIDES WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY.
HOW HIGH THE THE SEAS WILL RISE
AND WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHEN
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT IT'S
INEVITABLE THAT WE WILL AND
ALREADY ARE SEEING SOME CHANGES --
THERE SOME RANGES HERE IN THE
HAND OUT FOR THE COAST BELOW
MENDOCINO FROM THE RECENT STATE
GUIDANCE OF SOME ESTIMATES OF
WHAT THOSE PROJECTIONS ARE OVER
THE COMING DECADES -- I THINK
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT.
HOWEVER MUCH THE ACTUAL SEE RISE
THE IT RISES THE IMPLICATIONS
FOR THE COAST ARE MUCH HIGHER
FROM SOME OF THE EPISODE
EPISODIC EVENTS THAT HAPPENED
WHEN KING TIDES AND LARGE STORM
SURGES COMBINED WITH THOSE.
LARGER TIED SO THAT SOMETHING
ELSE TO BE PREPARED FOR
OBVIOUSLY THIS WILL AFFECT
PROPERTY INFRASTRUCTURE BUT ALSO
OUR NATURAL RESOURCES OUR
BEACHES AND OUR HABITATS.
BOB SO THERE ARE NO NUMEROUS
STATE AGENCIES THAT ARE ALREADY
WORKING ON TRYING TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THESE ISSUES SOME OF
THEM ARE HERE TO TESTIFY BEFORE
YOU TODAY -- THE GOOD NEWS IS
THEY ARE WORKING TOGETHER BUT
THEY ALSO EACH HAVE SOMEWHAT
UNIQUE ROLES THE COASTAL
COMMISSION -- REGULATES THE USE
OF LAND AND WATER IN THE COASTAL
ZONE WHICH GENERALLY EXTENDS
INTO ABOUT A THOUSAND YARDS
INLAND FROM THE MEAN HIGH TIDE.
I'M A LOT OF THAT IS THROUGH
THEIR LOCAL COASTAL PROGRAM
REGULATORY PROCESS THE LCP WHICH
I KNOW YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT FROM
THEM HERE TODAY -- BUT THEY ARE
NOT IN CHARGE OF REGULATING IN
THE SIMS IS THE BAY AREA THAT IS
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
CONSERVATION AND DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION OR BC DC ALSO HERE
TODAY -- THEY ARE IN CHARGE OF
REGULATORY ISSUES AROUND THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY -- STATE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY TYPICALLY DOES MORE
OF A HANDS ON PROJECTS WHERE
BECAUSE THE COMMISSION A. B. C.
DC KIND OF WORK ON PLANNING
GENERALLY ALTHOUGH THEY DO SOME
PROJECTS TO COASTAL CONSERVANCY
IS REALLY FOCUSED ON GIVING OUT
GRANTS AND IN SOME CASES ALSO
UNDERTAKING DIRECTLY SOME OF
THOSE PROJECTS -- ALONG THE
COAST AND IN THE BAY THEY'VE GOT
BOTH JURISDICTIONS OPC THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL PLAYS A MOAT
MOST IF COORDINATING ROLE ACROSS
ALL OF THESE AGENCIES AT THE
STATE AND ALSO FUNDS SOME STATE
LEVEL ACTIVITIES LIKE RESEARCH.
GUIDANCE -- AND THEN ALSO SOME
LOCAL PROJECTS.
AND THEN FINALLY THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION IS OUR LANDLORD FOR
THE STATE OWNED SOVEREIGN
PROPERTY AND THE PROPERTY IN
THAT I'M.
THAILAND'S AND SUBMERGED LANDS
AND SO THEY OBVIOUSLY HAVE A
ROLE TO PLAY TO PROTECT STATE
INTERESTS THEY'RE NOT LISTED
HERE BUT ALSO WORTH NOTING IN
HERE TODAY ARE THE STATE PARK
SINCE THEY OWN ABOUT A THIRD OF
THE COASTLINE IN OUR STATE PARKS
ON ON OUR BEHALF AS AS
CALIFORNIANS.
THE TURNING TO PAGE TWO JUST TO
TOUCH FOR A MINUTE ON FUNDING
FOR COASTAL ADAPTATION THE STATE
HAS PROVIDED SOME FUNDS OVER
RECENT YEARS -- FOR BOTH
PLANNING IN FOR PROJECTS -- FROM
VARIOUS SOURCES GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND WHICH IS THE
PROPOSAL THAT'S BEFORE YOU TODAY
ALSO SOME FUNDING FROM BONDS.
RECENTLY APPROVED RESOURCES BOND
AND SOME GENERAL FUND I WOULD
SAY THAT THE CATEGORIES THIS IS
RELATIVELY MODEST IT'S KIND OF
BEEN IN THE LOW MILLIONS OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL.
YEARS MAYBE.
MAYBE IN THE KIND OF TEN MILLION
RANGE BUT CERTAINLY NOT TENS OF
MILLIONS.
SO THE CHART HERE SHOW SOME OF
THE RECENT G. G. R. F.
APPROPRIATIONS FOR THESE TYPES
OF ACTIVITIES AS WELL AS THE
PROPOSAL THAT.
IS BEFORE YOU TODAY YOU CAN SEE
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION PROPOSED
FOR BC DC WHICH IS AN INCREASE
OVER THE RECENT YEARS -- ONE
POINT FIVE FOR THE COASTAL
COMMISSION WHICH IS A
CONTINUATION I WILL KNOW THAT IN
RECENT YEARS THE FUNDING FOR
THESE. THREE AGENCIES THAT SHOWN
IN THE TABLE HAS BEEN PROVIDED
ON A ONE YEAR AT A TIME BASIS SO
THIS WOULD BE AT PROPOSAL IS TO
MAKE IT ON GOING -- AND IT'S
ALSO BEEN A LEGISLATIVE ADD EACH
YEAR FOR THE PAST FEW YEARS AND
THIS IS THIS TIME IT'S SHOWING
UP AS A GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL SO
THAT'S A DISTINCTION AS WELL --
I'LL LEAVE IT TO THOSE TWO
AGENCIES TO DESCRIBE THEIR
PROPOSALS IN MORE DETAIL ON YOUR
NEXT ITEM.
SO TURNING TO PAGE THREE SOME
CONSIDERATIONS WE WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU IN THE FIRST
IS REALLY MOST OF THIS WORK IS
GOING TO HAPPEN TO HAPPEN AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
MOST OF FOR THAT PROPERTY IS
OWNED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL EITHER
BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OR PRIVATE
ENTITIES.
MOST OF THEM DECISION MAKING AND
LAND USE DECISIONS HAPPEN AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND SO THERE FOR
MOST OF THE PRIMARY.
LIABILITY AND FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY IS ALSO GOING TO
HAPPEN AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT
OBVIOUSLY THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
THE STATE JUST WASHES ITS HANDS
AND WALKS AWAY THERE'S A VERY
LARGE STATE INTEREST IN ENSURING
THAT THERE'S PREPARATION -- AN
ADAPTATION HAPPENING AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL BOTH FOR HEALTH AND
SAFETY CONCERNS.
AND POTENTIAL ECONOMIC IMPACTS
BUT ALSO BECAUSE WE AS THE STATE
ALSO OWN PROPERTY ALONG THE
COAST INCLUDING HIGHWAYS AND
BEACHES THAT WILL NEED
PROTECTION AND WE ARE THE PUBLIC.
TRUST ENTITY AS THE STATE FOR
NATURAL RESOURCES.
SO WE THINK THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL CERTAINLY REASONABLE
AND AND MEET SOME IMPORTANT
NEEDS -- BUT I THINK ONE OF THE
MAIN MESSAGES WE WANTED TO LEAVE
YOU WITH TODAY IS THAT THIS.
LIKELY JUST A STARTING PLACE --
OVER THE COMING YEARS AND THAT --
THERE'S STILL.
A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE FOR
PREPARATION AND THAT LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ARE GONNA NEED STATE
ASSISTANCE BOTH PROBABLY
FINANCIAL BUT ALSO -- POLICY
GUIDANCE AND ADDITIONAL TOOLS.
SO ON THAT NOTE TURNING TO THE
FINAL PAGE OF THE HANDOUT AND
THIS IS ALSO A PAGE THIRTEEN AND
FOURTEEN OF YOUR AGENDA -- SOME
OF THE KEY LEGISLATIVE QUESTIONS
WE WOULD RECOMMEND YOU START
GRAPPLING WITH.
I'M NOT JUST TODAY OF COURSE BUT
IN THE MONTHS AND YEARS TO COME
AND THE FIRST ONE WE THINK IS
REALLY KEY WHICH IS TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT IS THE WAY THAT
THE STATE CAN AND SHOULD BE MOST
HELPFUL AND WHAT IS.
THE LOCAL ROLL KIND OF FIGURING
OUT THOSE ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES AND MAKING SURE
THAT THE STATE IS ENGAGING IN
LEVERAGING -- ITS RESOURCES AND
ASSISTANCE IN THE MOST HELPFUL
WAY POSSIBLE -- SECOND WHAT KIND
OF PROGRESS IS BEING MADE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IS IT SUFFICIENT --
IT ARE THERE OTHER THINGS THE
STATE CAN DO EITHER THROUGH
CARROTS OR THROUGH STICKS TO
HELP AT THE LOCAL LEVEL MAKE
SURE THAT THE PROGRESS IS BEING
MADE.
FUNDING WITH THE LIMITED
RESOURCES WE HAVE BOTH AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND THE LOCAL LEVEL
HOW CAN WE TARGET IT MOST
EFFECTIVELY -- AND ARE THERE
OTHER FUNDING SOURCES THAT MIGHT
BE AVAILABLE OR BE MADE
AVAILABLE THROUGH -- TOOLS THAT
AREN'T BEING UTILIZED YET THAT
THAT MAYBE REQUIRES LEGISLATIVE
ACTION.
TO ENABLE. ONE OF THE ROLES WAYS
THE STATE HAS BEEN MOST HELPFUL
I THINK SO FAR AND CAN CONTINUE
TO BE HELPFUL IS PROVIDING DATA
AND DOING RESEARCH ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS.
THROUGH KIND OF MEANS OF SCALE
TO PROVIDE TO LOCAL LEVEL SO
CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
ENGAGED IN THAT ROLE AND ALSO
CONTINUING TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
REFLECTING UPDATED SCIENTIFIC
UNDERSTANDINGS AS THINGS CHANGE
AND PROVIDING THAT GUIDANCE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AS WELL -- FOR
STATE ASSETS SOME OF THESE
PROPERTY INFRASTRUCTURE ASSETS
ARE THE STATE'S RESPONSIBILITY
AND ARE WE ENGAGING AND TAKING
ACTION THAT WE NEED TO PUT TO DO
TO PROTECT OUR ASSETS INCLUDING
HIGHWAYS BUILDINGS AND BEACHES
AND HOW IS THAT BEING COR NEEDED.
WHAT ARE THE COST ESTIMATES AND
HAVE THE FUNDING BEEN PROVIDED
FOR FOR THOSE STATE
RESPONSIBILITIES?
AND THEN FINALLY ON THE L. C. P.
OUR LOCAL COASTAL PROGRAMS THAT
ARE ADMINISTERED BY THE COASTAL
COMMISSION THAT IS HAS BEEN
TRADITIONALLY ONE OF THE PRIMARY
WAYS THAT THE STATE HAS BEEN
ENGAGED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
IN A LOT OF THESE COASTAL
DEVELOPMENT AN ADAPTATION
DECISIONS AND ACTIONS SO
CONTINUING TO MONITOR HOW THAT
PROCESS IS WORKING -- IS
EFFECTIVE IS IT THE BEST
CONTINUE TO BE THE BEST WAY AND
HOW CAN WE MAKE IT MORE
EFFECTIVE -- IT IN TERMS OF THAT
STATE AND LOCAL NEXUS.
AND THEN I JUST WANTED TO CLOSE
BY SAYING THIS IS ACTUALLY AN
AREA THAT OUR OFFICE WOULD LIKE
TO BE INCREASINGLY ENGAGING IN
THIS THINKING ABOUT A LOT AND IS
PLANNING TO DO SOME ADDITIONAL
WORK ON SO WE WANT TO BE A
RESOURCE TO YOU IS YOU'RE
ENGAGING ON THESE.
ISSUES SO IF THERE ARE WAYS THAT
YOU THINK WE CAN BE HELPFUL AND
THINGS YOU'D LIKE US TO SPEND
SOME TIME ON THIS IS AN AREA WE
THINK IS GOING TO BE A BIG
PRIORITY FOR YOU ALL AND FOR THE
STATE.
I IN THE COMING YEAR SO PLEASE
THINK OF US AS A RESOURCE --
LAST YEAR I GAVE A LECTURE TO
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT CROWD
ABOUT COMING IN FOR A HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR AND
NOT.
HAVING A CLEAN NEXUS BETWEEN
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GASES --
WITH AB.
AKTION MONIES FROM THIS YEAR I
GET IT TWENTY TWENTY ONE VERY
CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
ADAPTATION HAS SOME OF THE SAME
CHALLENGES WITH WITH MONEY THIS
THIS YEAR.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT AND THEN --
HOW MIGHT THAT BE PACKAGED UP
BECAUSE WE'RE LOOKING AT A
REQUEST HERE?
OF THREE MILLION DOLLARS VERSUS
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND A HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS IS ALLEGEDLY
JUST TAKE TRAIN THE PEOPLE TO DO
THE WORK THAT WE WOULD WANT HIM
TO DO.
SO WE GOT A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION IN TRAINING AND THREE
MILLION A LEASE.
ON GOING SO.
HELP ME OUT ON THAT.
THE FIRST PART ON THERE.
ON THE YEAH I I THINK I'LL DEFER
TO THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
JUSTIFICATION I WILL JUST
HIGHLIGHT THAT THIS IS.
SOMETHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS USED TO TERRA FOR IN RECENT
YEARS THESE ADAPTATION ACTIVITY
SO IT'S NOT A NEW USE OF THESE
FUNDS FOR THESE TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES.
I THINK HE LEGISLATURE'S BEEN
VERY -- FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE
THAT WE DRAW THOSE LINES JUST
TRYING TO SET AN EXAMPLE THAT WE
WOULD CONTINUE AT LEAST.
IN THE COMING YEARS [inaudible]
M..
TALK ABOUT THE OVERLAP --
BECAUSE YOU HAVE SEA LEVEL RISE
YOU DO YOU DO YOU FOCUSED ON THE
STATE RESPONSIBILITY IN A LOCAL
RESPONSIBLE IN TRYING TO SORT
THAT OUT IN WHETHER WE MAKE
GRANTS AVAILABLE OR WE HAVE.
THE ASSISTANCE THAT WE'RE DOING
NOW IF ON THE RESEARCH AND DATA
DATA -- I THINK SOME OF THE
LINES ARE FUZZY AND I THINK SOME
OF THAT IS THE ACTIVITY THAT
COMES BECAUSE WE HAVE STORM
SURGES THAT MAY HAVE A FLOODING.
IMPACT THAT DOESN'T FIT INTO THE
LITTLE ADAPTATION OR CLIMATE SEA
LEVEL RISE BOX BUT STILL.
PART OF THE PHENOMENA.
I THINK THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
TO TO MAKE THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MOST SUCCESSFUL IS
TO ANTICIPATE THAT THOSE THOSE
TYPES OF FLOODING FROM SOURCE
STORM SURGES ARE NOT -- CAN'T BE
THOUGHT OF AS SURPRISE
UNPREDICTABLE ANYMORE WE HAVE WE
HAVE TO PROTECT THEM WE HAVE TO
KNOW THAT THEY'RE COMING THERE'S
SOME REALLY GOOD RESEARCH
HAPPENING OUT OF SCRIPTS -- BE
IT YEAH YOU SEE SAN DIEGO IN THE
IMPERIAL BEACH AREA OF SAN DIEGO
THEY'VE GOT.
IN THERE USING BOOTIES AND
DROWNS TO TRY AND PREDICT --
SOME OF THE WIND THIS STORM
SURGE WILL COME AND WEAR IT LIKE
A FEW DAYS OUT SO THAT THEY CAN
BE PREPARED AND KNOW EXACTLY
WHERE THAT'S COMING.
SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT --
COULD COULD BE A PILOT PROJECT
THAT PERHAPS COULD BE EMPLOYED
ELSEWHERE -- MY UNDERSTANDING IS
NOT VERY COSTLY BECAUSE WE'VE
GOT A LOT OF THE MOVIES OUT
THERE SO IT'S JUST AT AND
PLAYING SOME ADDITIONAL DATA
COLLECTION TO LOOK AT AT WHEN
THERE'S A STORM PREDICTED WE
KNOW WHERE THE SEAS ARE WE KNOW
WHAT THE TIDES ARE WHERE IS THAT
WATER.
IN A CALM SO THAT COMMUNITIES
CAN GET SAND BAGS IN PLACE OR IF
THEY'RE DOING LONGER TERM
PROJECTS PRIORITIZE THIS IS
WHERE THE FLOODING IS GONNA
CONTINUALLY HAPPEN MAYBE
EPISODICALLY.
BUT IT WILL CONTINUE TO HAPPEN
THERE SO THAT'S WHERE WE SHOULD
FOCUS OUR PRIORITIES FIRST NOW
AS FAR AS TIMING IS CONCERNED
IT'S AS IF WE HAVE THESE PILOTS
OR DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS.
THAT THAT ARE READY TO BUY THE
CALL SHOVEL READY TO READY TO GO
OUT.
PRESUMABLY THE KNOWLEDGE THAT WE
LEARNED FRM THOSE SOME WHETHER
IT WORKS OR NOT IN THEORY IT
WORKS IF IT WORKS OR NOT THAT
WOULD BE TRANSFERABLE TO
DIFFERENT.
OUR WATER WAYS OR RIVERS THAT
METER THE OCEAN OR JUST --
WETLANDS THAT CAN BE HAD CAN BE
INUNDATED RIGHT AND I WOULD SAY
THAT'S PROBABLY A PERFECT NEXUS
TO YOUR QUESTION OF WHAT'S THE
STATE ROLE LOCAL ROLE EEN IF
IT'S A PROJECT THAT.
REALLY BENEFITS THE LOCALS THE
STATE COULD PUT THE FUNDING AND
FOR SOME OF THESE PILOT PROJECTS
THAT COULD THEN.
SHOW A STATEWIDE BENEFIT BECAUSE
THEY COULD BE -- LEARN FROM AND
THEN UTILIZED EMPLOYED IN OTHER
AREAS FOR SOME I'M INTERESTED IN
THE IN THE BUDGET REQUEST FROM
BC DC THERE'S NO REQUEST FOR
GRANT FUNDS TO SORT OF HELP WITH
THESE.
PILOT OR DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY THEY'RE
HELPING WITH THE ASSISTING THE
LOCALS THAT COMPETENT PLANS AND
AND DO IT WHERE THE DAYS --
COASTAL COMMISSION HAS ABOUT
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND IN
IN GRANTS THAT THERE COULD BE
GIVING OUT IS THERE SOME REASON
THE THE THINK THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING IS GOING ON IN THE
OCEAN -- WETLAND -- AREAS IT'S
NOT HAPPEN IN THE BAY I MEAN I
WOULD SAY THAT I WOULD I WILL
ACTUALLY CHARACTERIZE THE
COASTAL COMMISSION MANY AS
PLANNING MANY AS WELL BOTH OF
THESE POTS I THINK ARE REALLY
PLANNING MONEY BECAUSE EVEN THE
GRANTS THAT THE COASTAL
COMMISSION WOULD GIVE THE SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IS FOR PLANNING VULNERABILITY
ASSESSMENTS CHANGES TO THEIR
LOCAL COASTAL PROGRAM SO IT'S
NOT ACTUALLY FOR PROJECTS IT'S
TO PLAN FOR THE PROJECTS AND I
THINK THAT'S THE CASE. FOR BE
CDC AS WELL -- AS A MAN AS I
NOTED MOST OF THE MONEY
TYPICALLY THAT IS GIVEN FOR
PROJECTS COMES OUT OF THE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY -- AND PC
SOME TO BAY AREA AND AGAIN
THAT'S MY LAST QUESTION IS THAT
IS THAT THAT.
THAT DANCE BETWEEN LOCAL AGENCY
SAYING WE HAVE A PROJECT WE
THINK IT'S GOING TO REDUCE THE
LEVEL [inaudible]
RIGHT.
OR RISING IN OUR IMPACTS IMPACT
RIGHT AND THEN YOU HAVE THE BC
DC THAT'S HELPING THEM WITH THE
OR HAS SOME INFORMATION WITH
THEM THE STATE.
ALSO COMMISSION WOULD BE THE
VEHICLE THAT WE WOULD USE IF
WE'RE INTERESTED IN.
GRANT FUNDING GRANTS IS THAT HI.
AND TYPICALLY IT'S THE
CONSERVANCY THE SERVICE THURMOND
GRANT YES THAT'S RIGHT.
RIGHT THESE TWO AGENCIES
TYPICALLY ARE MORE ENGAGED IN.
PLANNING THEY DO.
AND AND HAVE HISTORY OF GIVING
GRANTS FOR PROJECTS AS WELL AND
THEY ALL DO WORK TOGETHER BUT
I'M KIND OF IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR BROAD STROKES I
WOULD SAY THAT'S THAT'S KIND OF
THE BROAD STROKES OF ALL THOSE
HYDROLOGISTS HANG OUT TOGETHER.
CENTER MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR --
JUST CAN BE QUICK AND THEN BE
INTERESTED FROM EXACTLY FOSTER
OFFICER THE COST QUESTION.
HE IS PRESENTING TODAY.
LOOK.
AT THE COAST MACHINE HAS A
WONDERFUL PROGRAM THAT WERE
THERE THEY'RE OFFERING GRANTS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO BE ABLE TO
HELP PROVIDE. FOR PLANNING AND
TO DROP IN THE BUCKET.
ABOUT WHERE WE NEED TO GO SEVEN
MILLION MR EXACT OF OFFICER AT
APPROXIMATELY.
AT THE END.
WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE NEED IN
THE HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF INFRASTRUCTURE JUST
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE THERE ON
OUR COASTLINES -- WHAT IS THAT
LONG TERM PLAN -- AND TO BE ABLE.
TO SAY IF WE'RE GONNA SAY TO
LOCALS THAT THEY HAVE TO BECOME
MORE RESILIENT.
IT'S GONNA BE IMPOSSIBLE FOR
LOCALS BE ABLE GENERATE THE
REVENUE TO BE ABLE.
TO FORTIFY THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE
OR TO BE ABLE TO CANDIDLY MOVE
BACK IS WELL.
SO.
BOTTOM LINE IS I THINK.
A GRAND VISION OF WHAT THIS IS
GOING TO LOOK LIKE BOTH.
WHAT OUR GOALS ARE AND HOW WE'RE
GONNA FUND NAME?
IN ALSO REALIZE IN AND AGAIN
THIS IS NOT THROWING STONES THE
CALLS WHICH IS A OF THE ONES
THAT ARE OUT THERE DOING IT --
IN TRYING TO FIND BUT IT IS SO
MINOR IN THE BIG SCHEME OF THE
ISSUE THAT'S CAN IMPACT IS OVER
THE NEXT TWO DECADES.
ALL THIS USE MARIN COUNTY IS
EXAMPLE WE HAVE AREAS IN -- NO
VALLEY THAT ENDED IN TIMBER ON
THE CURRENTLY FLIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE AREAS ARE DOWN IN SAN
DIEGO -- THE PARK AND RIDE LOT --
ALONG WITH A ONE ALL INUNDATED
DURING KING TIDES HIGHWAY ONE A
ONE IT MARIN CTY.
INUNDATED DURING KING TIDES WERE
SHUT DOWN THE MAJOR THOROUGHFARE
THAT CONNECTS TOWARD THE SOUTH A
SALE THAT IS -- HOPEFULLY IN MAY
IN THIS WOULD BE THROUGH CHAIR
MAYBE IN THE IN THE FALL OF
DOING SOME TYPE OF SPECIAL
HEARING ON SOMETHING LIKE THIS
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT.
IS GOING.
TO BE ON OUR PLATE FOR MANY MANY
DECADES TO COME BEFORE THE RAINS
HEY THERE YOU GO THAT'S EXACTLY.
I'M NO I MEAN I THINK YOUR TO
MAKE A POINT IT'S IT'S BEEN
RATHER -- CHALLENGING TO GET THE
RESEARCH MONEY AND TO GET THE
LITTLE PITTANCE OF MONEY THAT
HAVE GONE TO THESE AGENCIES HAVE
BEFORE US.
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS SO -- WE
SHE THE UNDER SCORING AND IN THE
ALLEY OWES -- OFFER TO BE A
PARTNER FOR US CENTER STERN.
THANK YOU LET ME.
DOUBLE UNDERSCORE THEN I MEAN I
JUST TO SET THE CONTEXT.
FOR IN THE QUANTITY OF DOLLARS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE U.
S. G. S. REPORT THAT.
AND THEN JUST CAME OUT.
THE TIME IS 6%OF CALIFORNIA'S
ENTIRE GDP ON THE LINE.
IN ON THE TRAJECTORY WERE ON IN
OVER THIS THIS CENTURY IT'S TWO
SCALES ROUTE REALLY IMPORTANT
UNDERSTAND AND SO I MEAN GETTING
PLANNING DOLLARS COMING YES.
BUT CAPITALIST PLAN I MEAN I I I
KEEP WHEN WE BROUGHT THE SEVEN
IF YOU HEARINGS WITH LA -- SORT
OF QUANTIFY THE SCOPE OF THE
TOTAL RISK.
COMPREHENSIVELY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN A FISCALLY
ORIENTED WAY LOOKING AT THAT
FIFTH CLIMATE ASSESSMENT TO
REALLY.
GO BEYOND SCIENCE INSERTED
IMPACTS WRIT LARGE DOWN TO LIKE
DOLLARS.
WE START TO RIGHT SIZE THE THE
SCOPE OF NEED THAT RIGHT AND SO
WHAT I WONDER IF YOU ALL AS YOU
CONTINUE FALL THIS ALSO IS.
IS THERE SOME METRIC WE CAN BE
USING. TO TO TALK ABOUT HOW MUCH
RISK WE WERE BUYING DOWN WHEN WE
AND MAKE THESE INVESTMENTS.
THAT IT'S IT'S A IT MIGHT SET
MORE CONTEXT IN THIS FEELING
LIKE -- THIS ISN'T AN
ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRAMME YOU'RE
JUST SPENDING ON LIKE FEEL GOOD
PROJECTS ON THE COAST LINE AND
YEA THE BEACH.
LIKE NO ACTUALLY WE'RE TRYING TO
SAVE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS HERE
YEAH AND AND SO.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT.
IT'S GOING TO BE ROUGH.
THE MATH I I WOULD IMAGINE
THERE'S SOMEWHAT SOME
SENSITIVITY IN IT BUT WE DO THIS
IN ACTUAR REALLY ANALYSES ARE.
IN THIS WHAT REINSURANCE
COMPANIES DO CONSTANTLY RIGHT SO
IS THAT SOMETHING YOU GUYS WANT
TO CONSIDER YES AND WE ARE AND
WHAT YOU VESTED GOOD QUESTIONS
THAT WE PROBABLY HAVEN'T HAD
SATISFACTORY ANSWERS TO IN
SEVERAL HEARINGS AND SO WE ARE
GRAPPLING WITH ITS IT IS AND AND
AND TAKING.
IT SERIOUSLY AND HOPING TO SPEND
SOMETIME OVR THE SUMMER AND
FALL I MEAN I THINK I WILL ONE
CONTEXT I WILL ADD IS.
IN ORDER TO BE EFFECTIVE AND
MAKE SURE THAT OUR DOLLARS ARE.
ACTUALLY BUYING DOWN RISK THERE
IS A PROCESS THAT NEEDS TO BE
GONE THROUGH FIRST OF WHAT ARE
THE VULNERABILITIES IN DOING THE
AVAILABILITY ASSESSMENT AND THEN
THE PLANNING FOR HOW DO YOU
ADDRESS THAT AND THEN UNDERTAKEN
THE PROJECT SO IN SOME WAYS IT'S
GOOD THAT WE HAVEN'T SPENT
BILLIONS.
IN PROJECTS YET WHEN WE ARE
STILL IN THE PROCESS OF DOING
THE PHONE ABILITY ASSESSMENTS
AND PLANNING I THINK. ONE OF OUR
MESSAGES AND I'M SURE YOU'LL
HEAR THIS FROM FROM THE AGENCIES
AS WELL AS WE'VE GOTTEN A LOT OF
THAT PLANNING DONE THAT'S GREAT
WE NEED TO MOVE INTO THE NEXT
PHASE AND FOR THOSE THAT HAVEN'T
ENGAGE MEANINGFULLY IN THE
VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENTS AND
PLANNING.
WHAT CAN WE DO TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE HELPING THEM DO THAT AND
AND TO TO SHOUT OUT THE CHAIRS
LEGISLATION HERE I MEAN THE THE
EFFICACY OF ADDING MORE FIRE
POWER IN?
TWO NOT JUST THE CONSERVANCY BUT
ALSO IT -- PR IN THOSE DOING THE
FIFTH CLIMATE ASSESSMENT AND
FIND A WAY TO GET SOME OF THIS
STUFF COORDINATED IN A WAY THAT --
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE CAPACITY FOR
THIS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THEY THEY
CAN'T DO IT ON THEIR OWN RIGHT
SO LIKE HOW TO BUILD THAT INDEED
THE SEQUEL -- GENERAL PLAN
UPDATES AGAIN A REALLY.
EASY TURN KEY WAY YOU GOT OFF
THE SHELF GOOD SOLID PEER
REVIEWED STUDIES COMING OUT.
SO ANY OUT THAT SOUNDS LIKE A
LINING WITH WHERE YOUR GUYS HAS
A YEAH AND I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS WE'D REALLY LIKE TO LOOK
AT MORE CLOSELY AS IF THERE ARE
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
KIND OF FOR THEIR HAD WHAT IS
ENABLING THEM TO GET FURTHER
AHEAD.
WHAT ARE THE CONDITIONS AND THEN
IF THERE ARE THOSE THAT ARE
STRONGLY MORE WHAT ARE THE
BARRIERS AND AND WHAT CAN WE
LEARN FROM THAT KIND OF
STATEWIDE LEVEL?
I GUESS THE QUESTION COMES ON
THESE HOW DO YOU BALANCE THAT IS
A I THINK YOU COULD MAKE A CASE.
AND THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
SAN FRANCISCO I WAS BORN THERE
SO I CAN SAY THAT THEY THEY HAVE.
A BIG VOICE ABOUT WHAT THEY
WANTED TO TAKE.
TO AS ADDRESS SEALEVEL RISE AND
THAT'S TO BUILD BARRIERS AROUND
THE FINANCIAL DISTRICT THAT DOES
NOT HELP OUT MARIN.
ALAMEDA COUNTY SANTA CLARA
COUNTY SAN MATEO COUNTY SO THERE
THEY WERE WELL DEVELOPED BUT
THAT'S I WOULD ARGUE THAT'S A
LOCAL ISSUE THAT IS.
HORRIBLE SELF INTEREST HORRIBLE.
STEPPED VERSUS THE WORK ON
ALAMEDA CREEK TO CREATE -- RE
HAVE RE HYDRATES OR RECONSTITUTE
TO REVERSES THAT THAT YOU
INCREASE THE WETLAND --
THROUGHOUT THE BAY IT'S COST THE
SAME AMOUNT OF MONEY AND YOU
REDUCE SEA LEVEL RISING IN.
MARIN.
INFRA HEY WORD IN A SAN MATTEO
BY A FOOT.
BRUCE IS JUST HELPING OUT
DOWNTOWN SAN FRANCISCO AND AND I
CAN GUARANTEE THERE WILL BE MORE
PEOPLE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
YELLING AT US ABOUT WE NEED THIS
TO PROTECT OUR FINANCIAL
INTEREST.
VERSUS SOMEBODY FROM SAN LEANDRO
COMING IN HERE AND SAYING BUT
THE HYDROLOGY WILL WORK OUT SO
THAT WE ALL BENEFITS SO THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED THE HELP
FROM THE ALEJO.
AND ALSO FOR MáS IS TO IS TO
LOOK AT THESE.
THESE ARE.
POTENTIALLY POOR QUIET.
YES THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO DO IT
THAT WOULD BENEFIT EVERYBODY IN
THAT GOES REGION REGION WHETHER
YOU'RE IN SAN DIEGO OR YOU'RE IN
THE CENTRAL COAST YOU SAY WE GOT
A LOT OF BIG MOUTHS OF HAVE AN
IDEA.
BUT IT'S NOT THE BEST IDEA TO
GETS THE BEST POP BEST BEING
BEST GOOD FOR THE REGION.
IN THIS ADAPTATION.
I THINK YOU'LL HEAR QUITE A BIT
FROM THE CDC ABOUT THAT ISSUE IN
PARTICULAR BECAUSE THEY ARE I'M
REALLY TRYING TO HELP LEAD IN
THE IN THE BAY.
SPECIFICALLY OF REGIONAL
APPROACH SO I'LL DEFER TO THEM
BUT I I THERE THERE IS PROGRESS
BEING MADE ON THAT POINT AND
THAT APPROACH IN THE BAY I THINK
YOU'LL HEAR FROM.
OKAY THIS IS A ISSUE NUMBER NINE
THERE'S NO ACTION WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE.
THEY OPEN UP.
YEAH ALL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARINGS IS THE GENERAL COMMENTS
ON COASTAL ADAPTATION.
WE WILL GO.
DRILL DOWN ON THE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I THINK
I'M THE ONLY ONE SO I MIGHT.
OKAY TO TAKE MORE TIME.
NO JUST OKAY I'LL BE BRIEF.
I JUST REALLY WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THINGS --
ONE OF THEM AND AND REALLY WANT
TO THINK THE LA -- FOR FRAMING
THIS AS NOT JUST WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE A FEW MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WERE PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET
BUT REALLY THE HIGHLIGHT BEATEN
THE DRASTIC NEED MOVING FORWARD --
WHAT ONE THING I WOULD ALSO
MENTION IS THAT THERE HASN'T
BEEN A WHOLE LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE THE ROLE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION PLACE IN ALL THIS --
I THINK AS LAND OWNERS OF ONE
THIRD THE COASTLINE INC IN
CALIFORNIA THEY WILL BE A PART
OF THE SO IT AS DISCUSSIONS
AROUND FUNDING IN A ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES BEING MADE AVAILABLE
FOR THESE ISSUES -- THEY SHOULD
DEFINITELY BE THE TABLE -- ALSO
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT -- THERE WAS
MENTION OF PROPOSED LEGISLATION.
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE OF SOMEONE
STONE HAS ACTUALLY BEEN WORKING
WITH AUTUMN ON CALIFORNIA ON
OZELL TO LOOK AT EXISTING
REVENUES FROM THE TIDE LINES.
ACCOUNT -- WHICH HAS A DIRECT
NEXUS AS AS YOU CAN IMAGINE TO
TO SEA LEVEL RISE IN COST LETTER
TATIAN GIVEN THAT WE ARE PUMPING
ALL THIS OIL FROM OUR OFFSHORE.
OIL WELLS IN STATE WATERS -- AND
WE GET SOME REVENUE BUT THERE
REALLY HASN'T BEEN AN
ASSOCIATION BETWEEN THAT REVENUE
AND DIRECT ENVIRONMENTAL
PROJECTS -- AT LEAST NOT IN THE
LAST DECADE OR SO.
ALSO BEING ABLE TO GO BACK TO
AND TO RE LINK AND CREATE THAT
NEXUS I THINK IT'S AN
APPROPRIATE AND VERY IMPORTANT
STEP IN OR TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S ADDITIONAL FUNDING
MOVING FORWARD.
THE LAST THING I WOULD MENTION
IS IS AROUND -- NEEDING TO
REALLY EMPHASIZE NATURAL
INFRASTRUCTURE SOLUTIONS --
MOVING FORWARD -- FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF EVEN COASTAL
ACCESS IT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
PIECE.
AND THEN THE PUZZLE BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT RELYING HEAVILY ON
RIPRAP IN ANOTHER -- HARD AGREE
INFRASTRUCTURES A SEQUELS DOES
HAVE -- DIRECT IMPACTS TO
ADJACENT BEACHES DOWN THE LINE --
WHICH FURTHER REDUCES THAN THE
AMOUNT OF BEACH SANDY BEACHES
THAT WE'D HAVE ACCESSIBLE TO US
AS CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS -- SO ON
BEHALF OF US WOULD WANT TO MAKE
THOSE COMMENTS AS WELL AGAIN AND
THANKS OFFER THE DISCUSSION AND
LOOKING FOR TO CONTINUE ENGAGE.
PART WILL CLOSE AT MATTER AND
LET'S CALL UP.
ISSUE NUMBER.
TEN THIS IS GOING TO BE A JOINT
CALIFORNIA COLTS THE COMMISSION
AND THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
CONSERVATION DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION.
CONTINUATION ON OUR COASTAL
ADAPTATION -- THE MORNING THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MY NAME'S
JACK GAINES WORTH -- EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION.
AND I SO MUCH APPRECIATE THE LA
OWES -- PRESENTATION ON COASTAL --
ADAPTATION AND THIS COMMITTEES
INTEREST IN THIS BECAUSE IT IS A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S COASTLINE.
AS YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA'S COAST
LINE.
IS FORTY FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
COAST IN OCEAN ECONOMY IS AT
RISK FROM CLIMATE DRIVEN STILL
ARISE WHICH INVOLVES FLOODING
INUNDATION EROSION.
AND ULTIMATELY THE LOSS OF OUR
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC PROPERTIES
ALONG THE COAST. ONE RECENT
STUDY FOUND THAT -- WE DON'T
TAKE ACTION NOW TWO THIRDS OF
OUR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BEACHES
ARE GOING TO BE -- GONE BY THE
END OF THE CENTURY.
AND THAT'S REALLY THE ECONOMIC
HEART AND SOUL OF A LOT OF OUR
COASTAL COMMUNITIES.
AND WITH EACH NEW STUDY THE GETS
PUBLISHED WE LEARNED THAT THE
SEAS ARE RISING FASTER.
AND THAT THERE WILL BE HOT THE
IT WE RISING HIGHER THAN
PREVIOUSLY THOUGHT.
RECENT USGS STUDY AS YOU JUST
MENTIONED FOUND THAT.
WITH THAT JUST WITH A MODEST
INCREASE IN SEAL RISE IN
COMBINATION WITH THESE CLIMATE
DRIVEN CLIMATE CHANGE DRIVEN
AMPED UP STORMS COULD RESULT IN
A REALLY DEVASTATING -- FIXED
WERE -- COASTAL COMMUNITIES.
AND IT'S HAPPENING NOW IT'S NOT
LIKE SOMETHING OUT OF THE FUTURE
WE'RE SEEING WITH KING TIDES
WITH JUST EIGHTEEN INCHES OF
RISE AND AND AND SEAL WITH THOSE
REFLECTING THOSE KING TIDE YOU
SEE FLOODING UP AND DOWN THE
COAST LINE WE'VE DOCUMENTED THAT
REALLY WELL THROUGH OUR KING
TIDES.
PROJECT -- TAKING PHOTOGRAPHS OF
BEEN ON THE COAST.
IT REALLY OF INCREDIBLE IMAGERY
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE
GROUND.
SO WHAT DO WE DO ABOUT IT THE
COASTAL COMMISSION -- TO GET OUT
AHEAD OF IT.
THROUGH THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES ONE POINT FIVE MILLION --%
PER YEAR FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUNDS TO OUR BASELINE
BUDGET AND THESE FUNDS WILL
CONTINUE SUPPORT PLANNING GRANTS
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND SUPPORT
THE COMMISSION STAFF'S EFFORTS
TO SUPPORT THOSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN THIS PLANNING.
EFFORT.
SO OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS WE
HAVE AWARDED SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN GRANTS THAT THIRTY
SEVEN LOCAL JURISDICTIONS -- TO
UPDATE THEIR LOCAL COASTAL
PROGRAMS OR L. CP'S FOCUSING ON
CLIMATE CHANGE AND SEAL RISE
ADAPTATION.
PLANNING AND THIS PLAN INCLUDES --
REDUCING EMISSIONS THROUGH SMART
GROWTH CONCEPTS BY REDUCING
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED AND
DEVELOPING POLICIES TO PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES ALSO FROM
WILDFIRES -- BECAUSE THERE ARE
CALLS TO COMMUNITIES -- THEIR
THREAT BY LIGHT WILD FIRES THAT
WE SEE IN LAST YEAR.
AND THESE GRANTS OF FUNDED
THIRTY THREE A DRAFTER FINAL
SEAL RISING CLIMATE CHANGE
VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENTS TWELVE
DRAFTER FINAL ANATASE REPORTS
THIRTY FIVE DRAFTER FINAL LCP
DOCUMENTS.
AND WE'VE ACTUALLY HAVE -- FINAL
L. C. P. CERTIFICATIONS FOR THE
COASTAL SIDE OF SAN FRANCISCO --
THE CITY OF SAN CLEMENTE.
SELANNE BEACH AND THE THE CITY --
COUNTY SAN DIEGO.
AND WE HAVE ADDITIONAL WORK IS
CURRENTLY UNDER WAY INCLUDING
OUR MOST RECENT GRANT ROUND
WARDS OF SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS -- FROM THE G.
HERE OF APPROPRIATIONS FROM LAST
YEAR.
NOW.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE PLANNING FOR
THESE ISSUES CAN BE REALLY
DIFFICULT IN CONTROVERSY ALL THE
LOCAL LEVEL SO WE ARE HELPING
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NAVIGATE
THE LCP UPDATE PROCESS BY
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND POLICY GUIDANCE. TO HELP
DEMYSTIFY THE COMPETING
SCIENTIFIC MODELS THE COMMISSION
IS STOPPED ADOPTED -- ITS ITS
FIRST YOU SEE OVER AS GUIDANCE
DOCUMENT BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN AND WE RECENTLY UPDATED.
THE TO INCLUDE CURRENT US SEAL
RICE PROJECTIONS IN -- TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FROM THE OPC.
THE SCIENCE.
STAFF IS ALSO DEVELOPING
ADAPTATION PLANNING GUIDANCE
DOCUMENTS FOCUSED ON RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT AND CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THESE DOCUMENTS
PROVIDE PRACTICAL SAMPLE POLICY
LANGUAGE AND ADAPTATION.
PLANNING TOOLS TO HELP OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO BUILD BEGIN THIS
PROCESS OF PLANNING AND TO HELP
THEM THROUGH THAT PROCESS.
IN ADDITION WE'RE ASKING OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PARTNERS TO
CONSIDER ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
IN THEIR LOCAL COASTAL PLAN
UPDATES.
AND PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
DIVERSE COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT --
IN THROUGHOUT ALL WE ARE
CONTINUALLY TO COLLABORATING
WITH OUR STATE AGENCY PARTNERS
THE CDC.
THE COASTAL CONSERVANCY THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL STATE
PARKS CALTRANS OPR AND STATE
LANDS COMMISSION -- ADAPTATION
IS GONNA BE COSTLY THIS COULD BE
PALE IN COMPARISON TO THE
ANALYST'S EMERGENCIES PROPER
RESPONSES BY A MARGIN OF FOUR TO
ONE GRANT REQUEST CONTINUE TO
OUTSTRIP -- ARE AVAILABLE FUNDS
WE RECEIVED OVER TWELVE MILLION%
DOLLARS IN GRANT REQUESTS AND
WE'VE ONLY BEEN ABLE THE AWARDS
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
SO IF YOU WANT TO CONTINUE TO
SEE PROGRESS -- THAT WERE MAKING --
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE THESE
THESE THESE PROGRAMS INCREASE
THESE PROGRAM FUNDING. TO CREATE
A SAFE AND RESILIENT CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COASTLINE FOR OUR FUTURE
GENERATIONS TO COME.
SO I'M AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS -- AN ALTERNATE OVER --
TO WE HAVE MISTER.
OR DEPUTY DOUBLE BACK PRESENT
AND THEN WE'LL GO BACK AND FORTH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MANY MEMBERS I AM TO GO BACK
WITH BCC I AM THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OUR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
IS ON A LONG PLANNED TRIP.
IN SENDS HIS REGRETS -- BUT BC
DC IS.
AS THEY'LL THEY'LL TALK ABOUT A
OF REGIONAL AGENCY THAT
REGULATES AND PLANS FOR SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AND THEN I'M HERE
IT COUNTIES -- SHORELINE AS ONE
INTEGRATED UNIT AND WE ARE VERY
FOCUSED ON RISING SEA LEVEL IN
THE IMPACTS ON THE SHORELINE I
HAVE A BRIEFING PAPER THAT WAS
THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE.
IN FRONT OF YOU AND THE FIRST
COUPLE OF PAGES SHOW -- THROUGH
PICTURES WELL OF YOU'VE JUST
HEARD THAT RISING FEEL IMPACTS
ALREADY HERE IN FACT THIS
PICTURE IS C<c.cyan> JUNCTION IN.</c>
MARIN SHOWING US ANY DAY
FLOODING.
FROM HIGH TIDES SO THIS ISN'T A
THEORY THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE ALREADY SEEING -- AND I
WANT TO MOVE QUICKLY THROUGH
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE POINTS HAVE
BEEN MADE BUT ON THIS PAGE HERE
YOU SEE A MAP THAT SHOWS -- THE
VULNERABLE AREAS ALONG THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY SHORELINE AS A
PART OF OUR PLANNING PROJECT
WE'VE TRIED TO IDENTIFY THE
AREAS.
THAT ARE HIGHLY VULNERABLE WHICH
INCLUDE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES -- IN -- COMMUNITIES
WHERE PEOPLE SPEAK ENGLISH AS A
SECOND LANGUAGE AND THESE FOLKS
ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE.
HAVE THE LEAST ABILITY TO
RESPOND TO FLOODING AND OTHER
EMERGENCIES AND SO WE BELIEVE
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE A HEAVY
FOCUS IS A ALREADY BEEN
MENTIONED.
ON ADDRESSING THESE COMMUNITIES.
THE NEXT PAGE SHOWS THE SOUTH
BAY AND THIS GOES TO TALK TO THE
COST.
THERE IS AROUND YES -- I CAN'T
REMEMBER HOW MANY OF THE HIGH
TECH COMMUNITIES BUT MOST ALL
THE MEN THERE SHOWN ON THE MAP
HERE ARE ALONG THE BAY SHORE
LINE INCLUDING FACEBOOK.
AND THE GOOGLE PLAQUES WELL WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF YOU GOOGLE
SOMETHING THEY SAID SORRY WE'RE
FLOODING RIGHT NOW WE'LL GET
BACK TO YOU ON THAT -- ONE THE
PACIFIC INSTITUTE DID A STUDY A
FEW YEARS BACK THAT ESTIMATED
THE COST JUST TO REPLACE -- THE
BUILDINGS AND INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SUCH THAT WOULD BE -- FLOODED AT
A FIVE FOOT OF SEA LEVEL RISE IS
OVER SIXTY BILLION DOLLARS THAT
DOESN'T COST.
OUT THE LOST WAGES AND
PRODUCTIVITY SO THERE ARE VERY
LARGE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
ADDRESSING RISING SEA LEVEL.
AND NEXT PAGE SHOWS -- WHAT
WE'RE DOING ABOUT IT WE ARE A
PLANNING IN A REGULATORY AGENCY
THIS IS A PICTURE FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO SHORELINE?
ON THE LEFT HERE IS THE AG
BUILDING -- RIGHT BY THE FERRY
BUILDING WHICH WAS BUILT MANY
YEARS AGO.
AND YOU CAN SEE THE HIGH TIDE
LINE IS VERY GETTING VERY CLOSE
TO THE THE PIER -- BOTTOM ON THE
RIGHT IS A NEW FERRY TERMINAL
THAT IS JUST BEEN CONSTRUCTED.
AND THE PERMITS THAT WE GRANTED
THEM REQUIRED THEM TO BE
RESILIENT TO MID CENTURY.
AND TO HAVE AN ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT STRATEGY TO END OF
CENTURY WHICH IS WHAT WE REQUIRE
OF ALL OUR MAJOR PROJECTS AND SO
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE SO MUCH
HIGHER.
THAT'S SO YOU CAN SEE THE STARK
DIFFERENCE THAN WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IN TRYING TO ADAPT.
IN SAM CISCO BAY AND THIS IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THIS IS THE EMERGENCY WATER
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK AND SO
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE FLOODING
WHEN YOU NEED -- WHEN YOU HAVE
AN EARTHQUAKE IN YOU NEED TO GET
PEOPLE -- MOVED AROUND SAN
FRANCISCO BAY.
AB BUT WE UNDERSTAND THAT.
YOU CAN'T GET TO A RESILIENT
REGION JUST THROUGH THE PERMIT
PROCESS SO WE ARE DOING A
REGIONAL PLANNING -- THE NEXT
PAGE US IS -- ATHENA STUDY AND
I'LL -- UP.
MY PARTNER HERE AND THIS STUDY
SHOW THAT THE BENEFITS FROM
DOING ADVANCE MITIGATION
PLANNING ARE -- WE'RE SHOWN TO
BE MORE THAN FOUR ONE SIX TWO
ONE BENEFITS FROM DOING ADVANCE
MITIGATION PLANNING.
AND SO THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING
RIGHT NOW IN THE BAY -- RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE IN ADAPTING TO
RISING TIDES PROGRAM -- OR ART
AS WE CALL IT THAT IS DOING
REGIONAL PLANNING ON WORKING
WITH LOCAL COMMUNITIES -- TO DO
VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENTS AND
ADAPTATION PLANNING AND OUR
CURRENT STUDY IS ART BAY AREA
WHERE WE'RE WORKING TO ADDRESS
THE BAIT TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
INCLUDING A LOT OF STATE HIGHWAY
ASSETS AND LOOKING AT THEIR
VULNERABILITY.
AND LOOKING AT ADAPTATION
MEASURES FOR THEM AS WELL AS
ASSOCIATED -- PRIORITY
DEVELOPMENT AREAS AND
CONSERVATION AREAS IN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES.
AND WE'RE DOING THIS WITH THE
GRANT FROM CALTRANS AND THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION.
WE'RE ALSO WORKING WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES -- ONE WE'RE DOING
RIGHT NOW IS WITH EASTERN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY -- TO DO A
VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENT AND
ADAPTATION PLANNING -- WITH THEM
AND THE INTERESTING THING IS
THEY ARE OUTSIDE OUR PERMIT
JURISDICTION -- BUT THEY LIKE SO
MUCH THE WORK WE DID WESTERN --
RICHMOND THAT.
THEY ASKED US TO COME AND WORK
WITH THEM AND WE HAVE A GRANT
FROM -- THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL TO DO THAT WORK.
SO WE ARE WORKING WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
AND WE HAVE ALSO GENERATED
THAT'S SOMETHING I RECOMMEND YOU
ALL GO LOOK AT THE ADAPTING TO
RISING TIDES BAY SHORELINE FOOT
EXPLORER.
IT'S AN ONLINE TOOL THAT ALLOWS
YOU TO LOOK AT VARIOUS AREAS
ALONG THE BAY SHORE LINE AND
LOOK AT VARIOUS COMBINATIONS OF
RISING SEA LEVEL IN EXTREME
STORMS TO SEE WHAT GETS
INUNDATED WHEN AND WHERE THAT
FLOODING COMES FROM.
BASED UPON THE MAPPING AND THE
OTHER VULNERABILITY WORK THAT
THAT WE HAVE DONE TO DATE -- AND
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO WELL
WITH THE FUNDS THAT WE WOULD GET --
WE ARE -- IN IN OUR PROPOSAL IS
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION IN
GREENHOUSE GAS FUNDS.
AND WHAT THIS WOULD DO WOULD BE
TO ALLOW US TO FULLY PLAN.
AS HE'S ME FULLY FUND OUR
PLANNING DEPARTMENT WHICH RIGHT
NOW IS DONE MOST ALL OF THIS
WORK ON GRANTS AND ONE TIME
GREENHOUSE GAS.
PRODUCTION FUND -- ALLOCATIONS --
IN THIS WILL ALLOW US TO FOCUS
ON WHAT WE NEED TO DO WHICH IS
RESILIENCE PLANNING FOR THE
ENTIRE REGION.
THAT LOOKS AT IT AT LOOKS AT IT
AS WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE DOING
AS ONE CONNECTED NETWORK AND THE
IMPACTS OF WHAT A LOCAL
COMMUNITY DO EVEN IF WE WORK
WITH THEM TO MAKE THEMSELVES
RESILIENT NOT ONLY CAN.
IMPACT THEIR NEIGHBORS BUT
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN IT CAN --
IMPACT PEOPLE ACROSS.
THE BAY FROM THE SOUTH BAY TO
THE NORTH BAY SO WE NEED TO THE
PLAN -- TO BECOME RESILIENT AS A
REGION THESE FUNDS WILL ALLOW US
TO START -- PREPARATION OF A
REGIONAL SHORELINE ADAPTATION
FRAMEWORK TO START WORKING WITH
THE VARIOUS LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO
DO THIS -- INTEGRATE THE LOOK AT
REGIONAL PLANNING -- WE WILL
SPECIFICALLY HAVE TO PLANNERS --
THAT WILL BE ADDED ONE WILL BE
WORKING WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CONSTANTLY TO TRY TO DO THIS
COORDINATION WORK THE OTHER ONE
WILL FOCUS ON ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES.
AND LASTLY WE A AREN'T --
NEGLECTING THE REGULATORY SIDE
WE WILL HAVE TWO NEW ANALYSTS
ONE WILL BE -- WORKING ON
SHORELINE DESIGN WITH PREVENT IT --
APPLICANTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE ARE DESIGNS ARE RESILIENT
AND THE OTHER ONE WILL BE
WORKING WITH -- OTHER --
REGULATORY AGENCIES THE BAY TO
DO COOPERATIVE PLANNING FOR
THESE -- WELL IN RESTORATION
PROJECT IN NONSTRUCTURAL A MULTI
BENEFIT FLOOD CONTROL PROJECTS
TO TRY TO EXPEDITE THEM
VERTICALLY TO USE THE FUNDS THAT
THE REGION -- HAS GOTTEN FROM
MEASURE A A WHICH IS A PARTIAL
TAX ON EVERY -- PARCEL --
INCLUDING MINE IN THE BAY AREA.
IS FUNDING RESTORATION PROJECTS
COULD THAT CAN ALSO HELP THE
SHORELINE BECOME MORE RESILIENT.
SO -- THAT'S THE WORK THAT WE
ARE PLANNING TO DO -- HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE -- UP TO GO BACK AYE.
INTIMATED THAT THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE ARE SPECIFIC GRANTS
AVAILABLE TO YOU TO HELP OUT
THESE LOCAL COMMUNITIES ARE
THESE OTHER AGENCIES THAT ARE
MAYBE NOT FULLY.
COOKED ON THEIR PILOT PROGRAM
BUT THERE ALONG THE WAY THAT
SINCE YOU'RE HELPING THEM IN THE
ART PROGRAM MIGHT BE APPROPRIATE --
TO TO EFFECTUATE THAT ADAPTATION
PLANNING AM I OFF BASE IS WOULD
THAT BE HELPFUL OR HARMFUL.
A TEAR ACOSTA YOU'RE EXACTLY
CORRECT THE CDC DOESN'T HAVE
GRANTING AUTHORITY -- SO THAT WE
HAVEN'T BEEN DOING -- AND DO NOT
PLAN WITH THESE FUNDS TO DO UP --
PLANNING GRANTS BUT WHAT WE ARE
DOING IS USING THESE FUNDS TO
WORK DIRECTLY WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES SO WE'RE NOT JUST
GOING OUT AND DOING AND I STUDY
AND PUTTING IT UP ON THE SHELF --
WE'RE GOING OUT THERE AND
WORKING WITH THEM AND PART OF
WHAT WE SEE.
US AND OUR OUR PARTNER AGENCIES
WERE KIND OF AT THE SWEET SPOT
IN THIS BECAUSE THE LOCAL FOLKS
ARE ON THE GROUND THEY NEED TO
BE DOING A LOT OF THIS WORK.
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES AND THEY CAN'T.
HIRE SOMEBODY TO BECOME AN
EXPERT ON REGIONAL PLANNING AN
ADAPTATION PLANNING -- BUT WE'RE
AT THE LEVEL WHERE WE CAN BE
WORKING WITH THEM DIRECTLY BUT
WE ALSO ARE WORKING WITH THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL -- AND
THE NATIONAL FOLKS TO BRING THAT
EXPERTISE DOWN TO THE LOCAL
LEVEL SO -- SO THAT THAT'S KIND
OF THE APPROACH THAT WE SEE
OURSELVES TAKING AND SPECIFIC TO
YOUR POINT.
THERE WAS THE RESILIENT BY
DESIGN COMPETITION IN THE AREA
THAT LOOKED AT VARIOUS PROJECTS
TO BECOME A RESILIENT AND TO
RISING SEA LEVEL.
AND WE'RE LOOKING TO WORK WITH
THEM AND WITH THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
ASSOCIATION OF BAY AREA
GOVERNMENTS AND TAKE SOME OF
THOSE SITES.
AND WERE THEY IDENTIFY
PARTICULAR PROJECTS ON THE
GROUND IN WORKING WITH FOLKS TO
TRY TO REALLY DO THOSE PROJECTS.
AS A DEMONSTRATION OF HOW YOU
ACTUALLY ADAPT -- THAT COULD BE
THEN BE -- USED OTHER PLACES AS
WELL SO I GUESS THE QUESTION IS
HOW MIGHT THE STATE ASSIST AND
EFFECTUATE AND THAT IS THIS.
IS THIS [inaudible]
THE COASTAL COMMISSION OR THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION OR BC DC
OR THE LOCAL AIR LOCAL COUNTIES
FLOOD CONTROL AREAS HOW MIGHT WE
MAKE FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR THE
NEXT STEP WHATEVER THAT MAY BE
ON THESE.
RESILIENCE BY DESIGN.
WELL I WE BELIEVE THAT THE THE
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION WITH
THAT WE WOULD GET THROUGH THIS --
BUDGET CHANGE POSE A WOULD --
HELP DO THAT BECAUSE WE WOULD BE
WORKING WITH THEM ON THESE
PROJECTS THAT COASTAL
CONSERVANCY -- DOES DO GRANT
FUNDS IN THE BAY AREA AS WELL AS
THE REST OF THE CALIFORNIA COAST --
THAT CAN HELP THE LOCALS WITH
THESE PROJECTS WE ALSO HAVE.
AND I'M GOING COMMISSIONER WORK
GROUP CALLED FINANCING THE
FUTURE WHERE WERE WE ARE LOOKING
AT THE WAYS OF HOW WE'RE GONNA
FINANCE THESE PROJECTS BECAUSE I
AGREE WITH THE SENTIMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN EXPRESSED TODAY THAT.
PROBABLY THE HARDEST PART ABOUT
THIS IS GOING TO BE FINDING THE
FUNDING TO DO THE ADAPTATION
MEASURES IT'S GOING TO BE
REQUIRED.
SO WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT VARIOUS
PUBLIC FINANCE EXPERTS AND SUCH
TO LOOK AT VARIOUS MECHANISMS TO
FINANCE THESE PROJECTS FROM
SPECIAL FINANCING DISTRICTS TO
GREEN BONDS -- THE AND SO WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO SHARE WITH YOU
SOME OF THE INFORMATION WE'VE
BEEN GETTING OUT OF OUR STUDIES
BUT IT CERTAINLY IS GOING TO BE
THE BIG CHALLENGE THAT WE
QUIBBLE OVER THE R. O. I. B. AND
FOUR TO ONE OR SIX TO ONE NO
THAT'S OKAY.
FINANCE -- ENDED UP THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
JUST PUT A NOTE THAT THERE IS
FUNDING.
WITHIN THE COURSE PROTECTION
COUNCIL -- FOR SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT -- ECOSYSTEM RESILIENCE.
TO CLIMATE CHANGE -- WHICH WOULD
ASSIST THE THE COMMUNITIES AND
AND THE COASTAL.
AREAS SUCH AS ON DIRECTOR -- INS
WITH FORGET TO MY COLLEAGUES ON
THE LOCAL COASTAL PROGRAM.
LOVE THE COLLABORATION LOVE TO
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE LOVE THE
POLICY GUIDANCE YEAH THE DADA
DADA. ONE DO YOU PULL THE PLUG
WHEN DO YOU GET THIS DIVERSE
GROUP OF LOCAL COMMUNITIES THAT
SOME OF THEM HAVE AN DONE
ANYTHING FOR FORTY YEARS.
I MEAN I KNOW IT'S IT'S WHEN
WHEN DO WE GET TO THE POINT
WHERE WE SAID WE'VE GOT.
TO WE'VE GOT TO A PLAN OR WILL.
ADAPT -- IN YOUR COMMUNITY JUST
BECAUSE WHERE YOU'RE LOCATED.
THAT'S RIGHT IN THE SOME OF
THESE SOME ORIGIN WE HAVE
THIRTEEN JURISDICTIONS THAT
DON'T HAVE LOCAL COASTAL
PROGRAMS AND WE'VE TARGETED
THOSE FOR GRANTS.
THE BIG KAHUNA BEING THE CITY OF
LA.
DOESN'T HAVE A A LOCAL COASTAL
PROGRAM.
AND SO ALL OF THESE FRONTS WERE
MAKING YOU KNOW WE'RE ON THE
CUSP OF MAKING GREAT PROJECT --
PROGRESS AND MOVING FORWARD TO
ACTUALLY REALIZE THESE LCP
CERTIFYING THESE LC PEAS.
THE HERE'S THE RUB.
AS WE GO THROUGH THIS THIS
PROCESS AND WE WE THEY DO THE
VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENTS ONCE
YOU PUT THE YOU KNOW A PEN TO
PAPER ON A MAP.
A THAT'S WHERE EVERYONE GETS
CONCERNED BECAUSE THEY'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LOSS OF
THEIR PROPERTY VALUES THERE HE
THERE FEARFUL OF WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN A FUTURE THAT THE STATE'S
GOING TO COME IN AND SEES OUR
PROPERTY THROUGH EMINENT DOMAIN
AND THE SORTS OF THINGS -- AND
THAT'S WHERE THE THE PLANNING
SIDE AND DEVELOPING THE POLICY
STARTS GETTING REALLY DIFFICULT
WE HAD A GREAT -- A LOT OF PUSH
BACK ON OUR RESIDENTIAL
ADAPTATION GUIDANCE DOCUMENT
THAT WE HAVE AT THE HEAD OUT FOR
A FOR ALMOST A YEAR NOW.
GETTING A PUBLIC INPUT ON IT.
ON THE NOTION OF PLANNED RETREAT
AND HOW -- YOU KNOW THE THE THE
LOSS OF PROPERTY VALUES A LOSS
OF THE TAX BASE AND THINGS LIKE
AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES WERE
CONCERNED PARTICULAR THE
REALTORS COMMUNITIES.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO WORK THROUGH
THESE I THINK THIS IS AN
EVOLUTION OF POLICY OVER TIME
IT'S AT INCREMENTAL STEPS GOING
FORWARD WE DON'T HAVE TO SOLVE
IT ALL IN ONE SHOT I THINK.
YOU KNOW WE GET.
MAKE SOME PROGRESS ARE LCP WORK --
WITH REGARD TODAY MAKING SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE AWARE THAT
THEY'RE INVULNERABLE AREAS WE
DISCLOSE THAT -- THE THOSE
VULNERABILITIES WE FOCUS ON THE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
THE GLUE THAT HOLDS OUR
COMMUNITIES TOGETHER THAT'S
WHERE WE SHOULD START THAT'S
WHERE THE THE THE BANDS.
BUT PLANNING AND DESIGN FOR
THOSE THINGS NOT JUST THE NOT
JUST THE ACTUAL PROJECT
CONSTRUCTION COSTS.
ARE OW AT MY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PARTNERS TELL US THAT THEY NEED
MONEY FOR PLANNING AND DESIGN OF
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE OF PROJECTS GOING FORWARD
PARTICULARLY -- WASTE WATER
TREATMENT FACILITIES UP AND DOWN
THE COAST THESE ARE REALLY
VULNERABLE MOST OF THEM ARE --
AT SEAL RISE ARE AT SEA LEVEL
AND THEY'RE REAL IN THAT'S OF
HUGE BIG TICKET ITEM -- TO MOVE
THOSE BACK OFF THE COAST AND
SMALLER DISTRICTS ARE REALLY
STRUGGLING WE HAVE ONCE IN THE
NUMBER IN THE BAY AREA THINK
EIGHTEEN OF THE NINETEEN
TREATMENT PLANTS ARE RIGHT THERE
BY THE BAY THERE'S ONE IN EAST
CONTRA COSTA.
CENTER MONEY YET QUESTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR COM.
I WANT TO THANK BOTH OF YOU FOR
YOUR UPDATES AND THE LA -- FOR
THE POSITIONING HERE.
ON THE CHAIR.
ZEROED IN ON ONE OF MY QUESTIONS
WHICH RELATED TO THE LOCAL
COASTAL PLANS YOU SAID THERE
WERE THIRTEEN COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVEN'T YET COME INTO COMPLIANCE --
BUT YOU SAID IT'S A GRADUAL
PROCESS HOW DO YOU INCENTIVIZE
THEM TO GET THESE DONE.
AT THE GRANT PROGRAM HAS IS HAS
BEEN A REALLY INCREDIBLE
INCENTIVE TO BRING THOSE
COMMUNITIES THOSE THOSE
JURISDICTIONS IN WHO DON'T HAVE
THE WE DON'T HAVE AN A LOCAL
COASTAL PROGRAM.
AND SO I THERE'S BEEN GREAT
PROGRESS MADE I AM REALLY
CONFIDENT OVER THE NEXT FEW
YEARS THAT WE'RE GOING TO SEE
THE YOU KNOW.
MOST OF THOSE JURISDICTIONS --
COME FORWARD AND GET A SORT OF
GET OUT OF THE LCP CERTIFIED AND
PRESUMABLY THOSE THAT ARE STILL
IN THE PROCESS ARE LOOKING AT
SEA LEVEL RISE IN ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCY.
HI BUT YOU'RE DOING GRANTS ALSO
TO UPDATE PLANS -- IS THAT ALSO
PRIORITY FOR COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE UPDATING THEIR PLANS THE
GRANT PROGRAM IS TO IT IS TO
UPDATE THE LOOK IS FOCUSED ON
UPDATING LOCAL COASTAL PLANS FOR
CERTIFYING UNCERTIFIED AREAS AND
SPECIFICALLY THE GRANTS
REQUIREMENTS ARE TO ADDRESSED.
SEAL RISE -- ADAPTATION CLIMATE
CHANGE ADAPTATION PLANNING.
IT'S SO YOU MENTIONED IN YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS. TWO THIRDS OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BEACHES ARE
AT RISK QUOTE.
I THINK YOU SUGGEST TO THE TIME
FRAME BUT I DIDN'T CATCH IT IS
BY THE END OF THE OF THE CENTURY
BY THE END OF THE CENTURY -- BUT
IT COULD BE A MORE QUICKLY BASED
ON SOME OF THE SITES WERE SEEING
COMING OUT OF THE AYE XCELERATED
AYE SHEET MELT AND THOSE SORTS
OF THINGS SO.
AND AND AND IN COMBINATION WITH
THE STAMPED UP STORMS WILL SEE
MUCH MORE RUSSIAN OF OUR SANDY
BEACHES AND OUR BLUFFS ALONG THE
COASTLINE NICER PRESENTATION
RECENTLY FROM THE M..
BLUE OCEAN ECONOMY PROJECT INTO
MIDDLEBURY INSTITUTE AND THEY
HAD DONE SOME MAPPING OF CENTRAL
COAST AREAS SHOWING.
A SEA LEVEL RISE.
COMING OVER HIGHWAY ONE BUTTON
COACHING IN IN KEY TOURISM AREAS
HAVE YOU DONE ANY MAPPING THAT
LOOKS TO THE ECONOMIC.
IMPACT OR LA -- WE DID HAVE A
PRESENTATION AND RESOURCES A
WEEK OR SO AGO THAT.
THAT HAD SOME BROAD FIGURES BUT
DO YOU HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DIAL
IN AND IT WOULD SEEM LIKE THAT
WOULD BE AN IMPORTANT WAKE UP
CALL FOR THESE COMMUNITIES IF
THEY SEE HOW THEIR LOCAL
ECONOMIES.
ARE TO BE IMPACTED.
AND THE FIRST STEP OF OF THIS
PLANNING PROCESS IS THE
VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENT PIECE
AND THAT'S WHERE THE THE WERE AT
THE DO THE DEEPDIVE OF DENTAL
FIND THE AREAS THAT ARE GONNA BE
VULNERABLE AND YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT VULNERABILITIES IN
DIFFERENT SCENARIOS.
BUT ALSO THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF
THAT OF THAT SO IT'S IT'S BEING
DONE.
ON THE LOCAL BASIS.
IF OKAY AND THAT'LL IT BY CITY
OR BY JURIST AND THEN THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT LOOKING AT
IMPACTS TO BROAD CATEGORIES OF
BUSINESS INDUSTRY TOURISM.
YOU BREAK IT DOWN INTO POTENTIAL
JOB LOSS IN LAW LOST REVENUES TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES IN SOME THAT
HAVE DONE THAT.
IT SEEMS LIKE THAT'S ANOTHER
IMPORTANT PART OF THE WAKE UP
CALL TO TRANSLATE INTO.
MICRO A CONNIE'S OF JOBS LOSS
LOSS OF PROPERTY REVENUES --
PROPERTY TAX REVENUES
[inaudible]
SO.
THE THE THE ASSUMPTION HERE IS
THAT SEA LEVEL RISE IS A
FUNCTION OF CLIMATE CHANGE IS
THAT YOUR PERCEPTION
[inaudible]
SLOWLY.
AND IN YOUR VIEW IT'S REAL.
UPSET.
IT IS REAL AND IT'S HAPPENING AS
WE SPEAK.
AND HAVE YOU RESPOND TO THOSE
WHO SAY.
I AM IT CHANGES THE HOAX.
WELL THE SCIENCE SPEAKS FOR
ITSELF AND IN A WAR HI BUT WE
BASE OUR DECISIONS ON THE FAX
GOOD SCIENCE RULE OF LAW AND A
GOOD DOSE OF COMMON SENSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GERMAN VERY GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE
HERE IN AT FOR YOUR WORK IN THE
END IT WILL ALSO INCLUDE -- THIS
FOR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE CHALLENGE THAT I FEEL THAT
WE HAVE IS WERE WORKING IN SILOS.
GOOD PROGRAMS NOT WELL FUNDED
CANDIDLY GOOD WORK IT'S HAPPENED
WITH THE FUNDING THAT'S
AVAILABLE.
BUT THERE IS NO ONE OVERSEER IF
YOU WILL OF ALL OF THE DASH
PROGRAMS.
SO THEIR INDIVIDUAL PROGRAMS
WITH ITS TO THE CONSERVANCY.
COMMISSION THE CDC IN A SLEW OF
OTHERS.
CONTENT I HAVE AND WHY I THINK
THAT WE NEED TO GET OUR ARMS
AROUND THIS IS IT'S GOING TO BE
ALL HANDS ON DECK.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF THAT IS RUN
THROUGH RESOURCES.
YES AS AN OVERSEER IN BEING ABLE
TO MOVE THROUGH.
WOULD LOOK AT WOULD HELP THE LA --
IS GOING TO BE CONSIDERING THIS
AS A LOOK AT THIS ISSUE.
BECAUSE WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
IS THAT WE HAVE MULTIPLE
AGENCIES.
MOVING FORWARD ON NOT IDENTICAL
BUT SIMILAR ISSUES AND HOW WE
CAN COMBINE OUR EFFORTS -- IN
THE IN ALSO FIGURE OUT WHO'S
DOING WHAT AND HOW THEY'RE GOING
TO BE FUNDED.
IT WOULD LIKE TO BE TO GET YOUR
TAKE ON THAT.
AND SO WE'VE OF WITH ALL THEY
ARE AGENCY PARTNERS WE FOUGHT WE
WE DEVELOP THE SINGLE RISE
LEADERSHIP TEAM WHERE WE MEET
REGULARLY AND TALK ABOUT JUST
THOSE ISSUES TO TALK ABOUT --
WHO'S ARE PARTNERING WITH THE
OPC FOR EXAMPLE TO GO OUT AND DO
LOCAL OF GOVERNMENT WORKSHOPS UP
AND DOWN THE COAST -- TO
CONTINUE OUR PUBLIC OUTRAGE ON
SEAL RICE -- EDUCATION AND ALSO
STILL RISE ADAPTATION EDUCATION
ACROSS THE STATE SO WE ARE
WORKING WE'RE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY TOGETHER -- AND TRY IN
COORDINATING TOGETHER SO WE WE
WE REALIZE THOSE EFFICIENCIES
AND THAT THAT WE HAVE OUR OWN.
RESPONSIBILITIES BUT HOW CAN WE
WORK TOGETHER -- TO IT'S TO
REALIZE EFFICIENCIES AND REALLY
GOOD OUTCOMES SO I I IT WORK
WE'RE WE'RE MAKING GREAT
PROGRESS -- THERE AND WE
CONTINUE.
TO IF I COULD JUST AMPLIFY THOSE
REMARKS I'VE BEEN IN COASTAL
MANAGEMENT FOR GOING ON THIRTY
YEARS NOW.
AND WE'VE ALWAYS WORKED -- AS
SISTER AGENCIES TOGETHER -- BUT
I'VE NEVER SEEN THIS LEVEL OF
INTEGRATION AND COORDINATION --
AS I'VE SEEN WITH THE RISING SEA
LEVEL ISSUE BOTH THROUGH -- THE
THE VARIOUS MEANS WE HAD BUT
JUST ON A DAY TO DAY BASIS GOING
BACK AND FORTH -- AND TALKING
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING -- AND
HOW WE CAN WORK BETTER TOGETHER
AND SO I I THINK ON THIS TOPIC.
THAT IS A BIG PROBLEM BUT I
THINK WE ARE AT LEAST IN THE
COST OF COMMUNITY I THINK WE ARE
REALLY WORKING HARD TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE WORKING TOGETHER.
AND AS I MENTIONED FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY THAT'S KIND OF WE
SEE OUR ROLE AS TRYING TO BRING
TOGETHER THE VARIOUS FOLKS THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES DOING THEIR
ADAPTATION PLANNING.
THE VARIOUS -- REGIONAL ENTITIES
LIKE THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION.
COMMISSION -- IN THE WORK
THEY'RE DOING AND THEN THE THE
STATE AGENCIES TO TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE ALL COR DATING
AND HAVE ONE REGIONAL FRAMEWORK
THAT WE ARE DOING.
ADAPTATION PLANNING ON SO WE'RE
WE'RE FOCUSED ON ON THE ISSUE
THAT YOU RAISE IT IS ABOUT.
YEAH IT LOOK IN AT WHAT I WOULD
SAY -- TWO CHAIRS AT WHEN WE GET
THAT LARGE SCALE PLAN RIGHT.
AND ACTUALLY START MOVING
FORWARD ON TRYING TO SECURE
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS WHATEVER THAT
SOURCE MAY BE.
I THINK IT'S GONNA BE MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER I SPECIAL
AND DOLLARS ARE FLOWING TO BE
1100% COR NEEDED AND WHO'S DOING
WHAT AND I APPRECIATE THE EVEN
DOING THAT -- INDICTED ALTERNATE
THROW STONES AGAIN ON THE AD HOC
BASIS OF SAYING THAT WE CAN
START GETTING -- BUTTONED UP
TOGETHER.
BUT I WOULD THINK YOU'D BE
NEEDING SOME TYPE OF FORMAL
PROCESS IT ALSO TALK ABOUT WHAT
THOSE PRIORITIES ARE GONNA BE.
UP TO THE CHAIR RESEARCH.
EXACT DIRECTOR THAN WITH
ACTIVITY HERE FROM FINANCE IN LA --
WITH THAT SO.
YEAH I I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT ON
SETTING PRIORITIES IS REALLY
GOING THE IMPORT PARTICULAR
RELATES TO CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
DOING A SURVEY AN INVENTORY OF
THOSE THOSE OF IT ACROSS THE
EVERY JURISDICTION A WHAT WHAT'S
OUR PRIORITY AS FAR AS A
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND IT
ADAPTATION PROJECTS TO MOVE THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE OUT OF HARM'S WAY
THAT'S REALLY GOING TO BE.
PROBABLY THE FIRST STEP I THINK
IT IN THE IN THIS PLANNING
PROCESS AND ALSO A WITH
ADAPTATION -- PROJECTS.
THE OTHER THING THAT WE'RE DOING
IS -- WORKING WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES AND SEE SACKING WE'RE
GONNA HAVE COME EGGMAN COMING UP
IN -- JULY A WORKSHOP FOCUSED ON
SEAL RISE AT TATIAN PLANNING
BECAUSE WE ARE RUNNING INTO SOME.
YOU KNOW STICKY ISSUES AT LOW
WHIMS BECOMES A POLITICAL ISSUE --
WHEN YOU START TALKING ABOUT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF REAL
ESTATE AND DEVELOPMENT SO -- TO
HELP US ADD TO HELP UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEIR CONSTRAINTS ARE THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CONSTRAINTS ARE
AND HOW WE CAN WORK TOGETHER TO
ADVANCE -- THIS WILL RISE AT
PATIENT PLANNING GOING FORWARD
BECAUSE THE POLITICS AROUND IT
IS GOING TO BE DIFFICULT.
AND WE WE'VE ALSO FOUND IN OUR
VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENT
SOMETIMES ON THE SHOW AND THERE
IS NO.
FLOOD CONTROL AGENCY THAT IS
DOING AT THAT THE LANDOWNER IS
THE DEFAULT AND IT MAY BE A
SCHOOL DISTRICT OR LOCAL FOLKS
WHO DON'T REALIZE THAT THERE ARE
THE ONES THAT ARE PROTECTING A
BUNCH OF FOLKS.
BEHIND THEM.
AND OFTEN IN THE BAY AREA IT
IT'S STATE INFRASTRUCTURE --
LIKE HIGHWAY ONE OH ONE THAT IS
THE DEFAULT PROTECTION FOR THE
AREAS BEHIND THEM BUT IS
CALTRANS DOING PLANNING THAT'S
LOOKING AT THE WHOLE REGION FOR
AN INTEGRATED PLAN.
THEY'RE LOOKING AT THEIR
FACILITIES THAT'S THEIR MANDATES
SO WE ARE TRYING TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH THESE -- VERY
SENSE THESE AND AGENCIES TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE LOOKING AT AN
INTEGRATED LOCK.
AND I WOULD BE SAYING WOULD LIKE
TO IF IT'S THROUGH THE CHAIR
WITH DEPARTMENT HAS IT ALL OUT.
SOMETIMES WHEN THERE IS A
MANDATE ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE GOING
TO BE DOING RIGHT.
IT PUTS THE BEING THE MONEY. TO
GET IT MOVED QUICKER -- AND SO.
I UNDERSTAND THAT BECAUSE I
THINK ON THE ISSUE OF CALTRANS
AT LEAST IN DISTRICT.
FOUR WHICH IS AT YOUR WORK
ASKING OURS IN MY REGION.
IS THAT ON THIS IS THE FUNDING
IS NOT THERE AND IT IS PROJECT
BY PROJECT WHEN THE FIRE HITS.
RIGHT LIKE WE SAW.
IN MARIN CITY AND YOUR TEMPER ON
WHEN THAT FLOODS.
IN THERE'S A FOCUS AND THEN
OTHER FIRES CONTINUE TO HAPPEN
THROUGHOUT THE DISTRICTS SO.
THAT FROM THE FANS SURE JUST
STOP WITH SAY THAT YOUR
STATEMENT IS -- SO NOTED I'LL
TAKE IT BACK I I WILL SAY THAT
WHEN WE EVALUATE THE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET EVERY EVER
FALLEN INTO THE SPRING AND ALSO --
EVALUATE THE ON GOING BASELINE
WE DO -- COORDINATE INTERNALLY
AND AND TRY TO HAVE A STATEWIDE --
DO YOU AND WOULD ALSO.
I DON'T SPEAK FOR RESOURCE
AGENCY BUT I KNOW AS THE ENTITY
OVER MANY OF THESE AGENCIES TO
COORDINATE WITH THOSE ENTITIES
AS WELL I CAST A GLANCE QUESTION
BECAUSE COMMISSION AND BUSH
PROTECTION COUNCIL.
YEAH I I THINK COORDINATION IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT KEY BOTH AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND WE WILL LOOK
INTO THAT AND SEE IF THERE'S
GUIDANCE WE CAN GIVE I THINK
THERE ARE THINGS THAT
LEGISLATURE CAN DO.
TERMS OF BEING STRATEGIC ABOUT
TARGETING WHEN IT ALLOCATES
MONEY TO A PARTICULAR AGENCY FOR
PARTICULAR ROLE THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME EXAMPLES FOR EXAMPLE WHEN.
LBC IS BEEN GIVEN FUNDING FIRST
VERY SIMILAR THINGS AS THE
CONSERVANCY IS DOING IT SO IT
WAS SO YOU KNOW WE COULD
PROBABLY SEND MORE CLEAR SIGNALS
IF WE WANT TO DELINEATE ROLES --
I THINK THAT COORDINATION AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IS ESSENTIAL AS WELL
AS WE'VE HEARD IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY IT'S A LOT EASIER
BECAUSE IT'S A BATH TUB AND IT'S
PRETTY CLEAR IF YOU DO THIS ON
THE SIDE IT MAY AFFECT THE SIDE.
AND THEY CAN WORK TOGETHER BUT
BUT THERE ARE THOSE IN A RELATED
AFFECTS ALONG THE OUTSIDE COAST
TO IF YOU PUT UP A WALL IN.
ONE YEAH IT WILL AFFECT
POTENTIALLY THE BEACH IN A
NEIGHBORING AREA AND AND IT
PROBABLY IS EASIER FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO VIEW THEIR OWN
ACTIONS MORE IN A VACUUM SYSTEM
MORE THAT REGIONAL COORDINATION
IS PROBABLY.
OVERALL THE STATE CAN REALLY
TAKE -- OUTSIDE OF THE BAY AS
WELL FOR SOME OF THOSE
COORDINATED IMPACTS THE BRANCH
HAS DONE A GOOD JOB WITH THE
CLIMATE ACTION TEAM WHICH
TECHNICALLY IS HOUSED IN THE EPA
BUT FOR THE LAST EIGHT YEARS WAS.
REALLY RUN FROM THE RESOURCE
AGENCY BUT THAT'S A HORIZONTAL --
DISCUSSION BETWEEN THE STATE
AGENCIES.
COINCIDENTALLY THE CHAIR HAS A
BILL ON A DAY A CHIEF ADAPTATION
OFFICER WHICH WOULD BE PARKED IN
OPR WHICH WOULD HELP WITH THE
VERTICAL INTEGRATION OF WE'RE
TALKING WHAT THE DISCUSSIONS
BETWEEN.
THE STATE AND THE REGION'S AND
LOCALITIES SO THAT THAT FLOW OF
INFORMATION AND FUNDS TO COMMEND
CHIEF -- CENTER MONNING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN THE LA --
JUST REFER TO THIS BUT MY
QUESTION.
IN YOU THIS MAY BE IS PROJECT BY
PROJECT COMMUNITY BY COMMUNITY
BUT SOME PEOPLE BUSINESSES AND
RESIDENTIAL AREAS THINK A SEA
WALL.
IS THE SOLUTION. ONE IF YOU HAVE
ANY COM IS THERE ANY.
STATE OF THE ART OR OR MORE --
POLICY ORIENTATION EITHER OF
YOUR AGENCIES ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL ROLE OF SEA WALLS I
THINK SOME PEOPLE THINK THAT'S
THE EASY FIX.
WELL I CAN START OFF THE OF SEA
WALLS DESTROYED BEACHES.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
AND BUT I THINK WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT IT IN THE CONTEXT EVERY.
THERE'S DIFFERENT CONTEXT UP AND
DOWN THE COAST DIFFERENT
SEARCHES CIRCUMSTANCES THERE
CERTAIN URBAN AREAS WHERE
ARMORING IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE
THE ADAPTATION STRATEGY.
AND WE JUST HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO OTHER
ALTERNATIVE YOU'RE NOT GONNA
TEAR OUT YOU KNOW THE CITY OF
LONG BEACH -- DOWNTOWN SAN DIEGO --
AND SO THERE THERE ARE AT SEA
WALLS HAVE THEIR PLACE AS PART
OF AN ADAPTATION STRATEGY IT'S
JUST THAT.
IF YOU'RE GONNA HAVE SEQUELS ONE
OR YOU'VE GOT TO MITIGATE YOU
GOTTA THINK ABOUT WELL WHAT
OTHER A WHAT ONE OF THE AREAS
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO RETREAT.
TO RETAIN OUR BEACHES AND TO YOU
KNOW TO IT TO FEED TO HAVE THAT
SETTLEMENT COMING OFFER BLUFFS
AND FEEDING THOSE BEACHES AND
READERS HIM.
LOOK AND WE HAVE TO BE HONEST TO
SEAL RISE WE'RE JUST GONNA LAYS
EVEN IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE ANY
DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA
LOSE SOME BEACHES BECAUSE OF THE
AT THE AT ALL THE ADVANCING.
SEAL RISE AND ROAD UNIT OF THIS
HAPPENING SO QUICKLY.
BUT THERE ARE THINGS WE CAN DO --
TO PRESERVE OUR BEACHES UP IN AN
ECHO THREE NOURISHMENT AND OTHER --
STRATEGIES.
YEAH IN THE IN THE BARRIO OF WE
ARE A BIT MORE SHELTERED AND SO
THEREFORE -- IT IS POSSIBLE IT
WOULD IMPOSSIBLE THE HARD IN THE
ENTIRE SHORELINE OF THE BABY BUT
WOULD THAT BE A GOOD IDEA IN.
IN TERMS OF THE THE WETLANDS.
PROBABLY NOT AND WE HAVE FOUND
THAT NATURAL SHORELINE.
CAN ACTUALLY HELP PROTECT THE
DEVELOPMENT BEHIND THEM SO
RESTORATION PROJECTS -- CAN
REDUCE FLOODING IN INUNDATION OF
THE DEVELOPED AREAS AND MAYBE IF
YOU HAVE TO BUILD A LEVEE YOU
BUILD IT LOWER.
A PERFECT EXAMPLE IS THE SOUTH
BAY THE SHORELINE -- RESTORATION
OF THE OLD SALT PONDS -- THAT.
ACTUALLY PROTECT DOWNTOWN SAN
JOSE THAT'S SUBSIDED AROUND
TWELVE FEET FROM HISTORIC WATER
ASKED BACK WHEN IT WAS THE
VALLEY OF HEART'S DESIRE -- AND
SO -- IF DO THE RESTORATION
PROJECT WE'RE ACTUALLY HELPING
TO PROTECT DEVELOPMENT AND SO
THAT'S THAT'S THE THE APPROACH
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO TAKE IN
THIS ALSO CAN A ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ISSUES OF GREENHOUSE GAS
MITIGATION BECAUSE THAT'S GREEN
CARBON THAT'S SEQUESTERING
CARBON IN THESE AREAS SO.
SO WE HAVE A FOCUS ON THAT --
BUT IT IS TRUE THAT SOME AREAS --
IF THAT ISN'T JUST GOING TO WORK
AND YOU'RE GOING TO NEED TO HAVE
SHORELINE ARMING SO WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO LOOK AT AT BOTH MODELS.
OKAY THERE'S NO ACTION THIS
COULD BE TAKEN HERE DURING THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
CAP AND TRADE EXPENDITURES --
HEARING WE HELD IT OPEN ON MARCH
TWENTY EIGHTH SO.
THANK YOU WE'LL CLOSE THAT
MATTER AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER.
ELEVEN THIS WILL BE BE DC'S
METRO CENTER.
THE CONTINUING SAGA THIRD TIME'S
A CHARM [inaudible]
PLEASE [inaudible]
YES SO -- THIS IS IS THIS THE
THIRD -- BUDGET CHANGE OPPOSE
ALL FOR OUR AGENCY TO MOVE FROM
WHERE WE ARE NOW IN THE CIVIC
CENTER IN THE STATE BUILDING. TO
THE REGIONAL HEADQUARTERS
BUILDING THAT WAS -- ACQUIRED BY
THE METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION TO BE A REGIONAL
HEADQUARTERS AND NOW -- HAS OF
THE MTC THE ERROR DISTRICT --
THE SOCIALLY SO SEE ASIAN OF BAY
AREA GOVERNMENTS AND ALSO HAS
OTHER -- IT -- AGENCIES WE WORK
WITH INCLUDING THE ESTUARY
PARTNERSHIP AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY TRAIL -- AND SO WE
BELIEVE THAT IT WOULD BE IN OUR
BEST INTERESTS AND OF THE STATE
TO MOVE AND JOIN OUR REGIONAL
PARTNERS -- THE WHICH WE ARE
WORKING WITH CONSTANTLY -- AND
SPEND A LOT OF OUR TIME MOVING
BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN THE
AGENCIES AND SO -- THIS IS THE
FINAL PROPOSAL WERE HOPING THAT
WOULD -- FUND US FROM -- FUND US
TO MOVE TO THE THE THE NEW
HEADQUARTERS AND OUR EXISTING
FACILITIES WOULD BE TAKEN OVER
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
THAT NEEDS TO EXPAND -- AND
WOULD OTHERWISE NEED TO LOOK
OUTSIDE -- FOR OTHER REAL ESTATE
IN SAN FRANCISCO BAY.
FINANCE FINAL FINAL HERE.
LAST REQUEST FOR THIS ISSUE.
I DO YEAH WE WE HAD SOME
CONCERNS IN THIS IN PRIOR YEARS
WHEN IT'S COME BEFORE YOU --
GIVEN THAT THE LOCATION THE
COMMISSION'S IN RIGHT NOW IS
RELATIVELY LOW COST FOR THE
STATE IN THIS WOULD BE HIGHER
COSTS BUT OVER THE ITERATIONS WE
HAVE NOW SEEN -- DOCUMENTATION
THAT DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE DOES
INDEED NEED ADDITIONAL SPACE AND
WILL INDEED MOVE THAT SO THAT
KIND OF HELPS THAT PENCIL OUT
FOR THE STATE.
THE MULTIPLE.
REQUESTS ALSO SOMETIMES RAISE
CONCERNS BUT AT THIS IS
RELATIVELY MODEST SO IF THIS IS
THE SELF CONTAINED AT THAT STOP
[inaudible]
CONTINUING MOVE.
CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THE MATTER OPEN --
AND DEAL WITH IT.
NEXT MONTH.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION.
I WANTED TO HEAR FROM THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION LEARN MORE
ABOUT.
THE 400-580-00800 AND FORTY
THREE ACRES OF LAND THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM.
OWNS [inaudible]
PARTICULARLY. ONE HERE ABOUT THE
FIFTY FIVE ACRES FORCE LAND BUT
THE FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES
OF NON FORCE LAND.
WHERE ARE THEY AND WHAT'S THE
PLAN?
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU MY NAME
IS JENNIFER L CASSIE I AM THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION WITH ME IS
CALLING CONNOR OUR ASSISTANT
EXECUTIVE OFFICER -- FOR THE
COMMISSION SO TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION DIRECTLY ABOUT WHAT ARE
THESE SCHOOL LANDS AND WHAT ARE
THEY BEING PLANNED FOR THE
MAJORITY OF THE SCHOOL LANDS --
ARE LOCATED IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA DESERT -- THIS IS THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THAT FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES -- THAT
YOU REFERENCED MINUS THE FIFTY
FIVE THOUSAND ACRES OF FORESTED
SCHOOL DANCE.
AND FRANKLY -- BASED ON STATE
POLICIES LEGISLATIVE DIRECTIVES --
AND OUR STRATEGIC PLAN WE ARE
FOCUS SEEN THOSE PARCELS IN THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DESERT --
FOR RENEWABLE ENERGY DEVELOPMENT --
AND ASSOCIATED INFRASTRUCTURE
AND OTHER -- TYPES OF PROJECTS
THAT CAN HELP THE STATE MEET ITS
CLIMATE GOALS FROM AN ENERGY
PERSPECTIVE -- AND SO THAT'S
WE'VE -- OR ACTIVE PARTICIPANT
IN THE DESERT RENEWABLE --
ENERGY CONSERVATION PLAN FROM A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO WHERE WE
REALLY STUDIED -- AND WORKED
WITH VARIOUS STATE AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES TO UNDERSTAND OUR
PARCELS BETTER -- AND ALSO
IDENTIFY OPPORTUNITIES FOR LAND
EXCHANGES WERE WE COULD
CONSOLIDATE THOSE DESERT SCHOOL
LANDS FOR EITHER RENEWABLE
ENERGY DEVELOPMENT OR AS
MITIGATION LANDS TO FACILITATE --
RENEWABLE ENERGY DEVELOPMENT
ELSEWHERE -- SO THAT'S BEEN OUR
GOAL FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS AND
WE STILL ACTIVELY WORK TO
IDENTIFY OPPORTUNITIES -- FOR
THAT KIND OF DEVELOPMENT IN THIS
ONE PERMANENT POSITION GOING
FORWARD IS GOING.
TO ASSIST WITH THAT AMP IT UP.
BUT ACTUALLY THE THAT REQUEST
BEFORE YOU TODAY IS REALLY
FOCUSED ON OUR FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND ACRES OF FORESTED
SCHOOL LANDS.
AND WE ARE REQUESTING A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM THE SCHOOL LANDING FUND AND
ONE PERMANENT POSITION WE INTEND
TO HIRE A CONSULTANT TO
INVENTORY ARE FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND ACRES OF FORESTED
SCHOOL LANDS.
AND THE DEDICATED STAFF POSITION
TO MANAGE THIS CONTRACT AND THE
LATER BILL TO FORCE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM FROM THE RESULTING DATA
THE INVENTORY WILL INCLUDE DATA
ON HEALTH SPECIES SIZE AND
DENSITY OF OUR FORESTED LAND.
UNDER OUR JURISDICTION AND THIS
IS REALLY A RESULT OF OUR
PARTICIPATION IN THE FOREST
CLIMATE ACTION TEAM AND THE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN FOREST
CARBON PLAN -- SO SO PART OF
THAT IS IT ON WE'RE NEW.
NORMAL NOW THAT WE WANT TO
MANAGE OUR LAND BEFORE IN THE
OLD BATTLE DAYS WHICH ISSUE SORT
OF SIT THERE AND LET THE TREES
DO WHATEVER THEY DO NOW.
WE NEED TO TH AND WE NEED TO TO
PRESCRIBE BURNSWE NEED TO
MANAGE THAT ARE YOU THINKING.
AS A AS AN ASSET WE WE CAN.
CREATE IF IT'S IN THE WATERSHED
WE CAN CREATE MORE WATER
RETENTION BETTER OF BREAKING THE
IN THE FIRE THAT IS A A
STATEWIDE ASSET THAT'S VALUABLE
FOR ALL OF US WORK.
WE CAN PUT UP CABINS AND HAVE
PEOPLE CO THERE AND AND YOU KNOW
HAVE A HOLIDAY YOU DON'T KNOW
NOW WHERE IT MEAN I I GUESS I
DON'T KNOW WHERE THESE ARE ARE
THE ADJACENT TO PARK SAID THEY
JUST OUT IN THE WE WE I MERRILY
IN THE IN.
NORTHERN EASTERN PART OF
CALIFORNIA -- AND THEY ARE --
ISOLATED PARCELS OF ANYWHERE AS
LARGEST SIX HUNDRED FORTY ACRES
ARE LAST DEPENDING ON THE
HISTORY -- OF THE STATE'S
MANAGEMENT OF THOSE LANDS -- AT
THIS POINT WE DON'T KNOW I MEAN
AT THE GOAL IS ACTUALLY NOT TO
DEVELOP FOUR CABINS AND THAT
SORT OF THING WE REALLY WANT.
TO BE A PRO ACTIVE A MANAGER AND
RESPONSIBLE MANAGER OF OUR OF
OUR FORESTED LANDS AND SO IT'S
REALLY HOW DO WE RESPONSIBLY
MANAGE THAT TO INCREASE AND
ENHANCE THE HEALTH OF THOSE FOR
SAID LANDS -- AND AS WELL AS
LOOK AT OPPORTUNITIES TO SEE HOW
WE CAN -- CONTRIBUTE TO THE
STATE'S CLIMATE POLICIES IN
TERMS OF MANAGING THOSE FOR
CARBON SINKS ARE OTHERS AND WILL
BE WORKING VERY VERY CLOSELY
WITH CAL FIRE -- AND OTHER
AGENCIES THAT REALLY HAVE A LOT
OF EXPERTISE AND A LOT OF OTHER
LANDS THAT THEY MANAGE -- THAT
SURROUND OURS.
HELLO YOU HAVE A COMMENT NO
CONCERNS OKAY THE RECOMMENDATION
IS TO APPROVE HIS BUDGET I'D
LIKE TO OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING AT THIS TIME THIS IS.
ITEM NUMBER. FOR ISSUE NUMBER
TWELVE THANK YOU FOR THE THE
BACKGROUNDER ON THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION [inaudible]
CLOSE.
CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING -- OF
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
THERE'S A MOTION BY CENTER
MINING TO APPROVE AS BUDGET IT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL I CASTING
HI AND THE CHOIR [inaudible]
MORNING.
ALL RIGHT YOU HAVE FIELD HERE
FIVE VOTES IF THAT'S APPROVED.
WE OPEN UP THE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
STERN.
CLOSE THE CONSENT CALENDAR FIVE
ZERO ALL THOSE MATTERS ARE PROOF
MOVING ON TO THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION THIS IS.
THE ANOTHER INCREASE LEASE COSTS
[inaudible]
WELCOME BACK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
CHECKING IS WORTH EXECUTIVE
RECTOR CALIFORNIA COAST
COMMISSION WITH ME TODAY IS --
SUSAN HATCH MY CHIEF DEPUTY.
SO I WILL BE ADDRESSING THE
RELOCATION THE COMMISSION'S
HEADQUARTERS OFFICE AND ALSO OUR
NORTH CENTRAL DISTRICT OFFICE
WHICH IS CO LOCATED THERE IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
OF COURSE THE COMMISSION'S FIRST
CHOICE WAS A STAY IN OUR CURRENT
OFFICE LOCATION AND ALTHOUGH D.
G. S. R. GENERAL SERVICES HAD
INITIAL VERBAL LEASE AGREEMENT
WITH THE BUILDING OWNERS.
AT THE END OF LAST FISCAL YEAR
THEY CHANGE THEIR MINDS DECIDED
NOT TO ENTER INTO NEW LEASE
AGREEMENTS WITH US IN ANOTHER
STATE AGENCY IN THAT BUILDING --
WHICH TO SAY LEASE WAS A
INCREDIBLY UNPLEASANT SURPRISE
FOR US IS WE'VE BEEN IN THAT
BUILDING FOR TWENTY EIGHT YEARS.
SO WE WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
APARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES FIND.
IN NEW OFFICE SPACE FOR THE
AGENCY'S HEADQUARTERS WITHIN THE
SAME GENERAL AREA AS OUR CURRENT
OFFICE LOCATION.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO STAYING IN
THE VICINITY OF OUR CURRENT
OFFICE LOCATION.
BECAUSE IT'S CRITICAL FOR ALL
THE OPERATIONAL CAPACITY OF OUR
OF THE COMMISSION STAFF THAT
LOCATION ALLOWS OUR EMPLOYEES
USE A WIDE VARIETY OF PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. TO GET TO WORK
WE HAVE EMPLOYEES LIVE ALL OVER
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA AND A
100% OF OUR EMPLOYEES USE PUBLIC
TRANSIT OR WALK OR BIKE TO WORK.
AND IT'S CRITICAL TO KEEP THAT
OFFICE LOCATION. TO RETAIN AND
RECRUIT OUR STAFF GOING THE
FUTURE IT ALSO MEETS THE STATE'S
GOALS IN OUR STRATEGIC PLAN
GOALS OF REDUCING OUR GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS THROUGH THE USE OF
TRANSIT AND BIKING AND WALKING.
THE LOCATION IS ALSO A REALLY
REALLY IN SUPPORT AT NO
ESSENTIAL FOR ACCESSIBILITY TO
THE PUBLIC THAT WE SERVE --
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE FACT THAT
ARE NOR CENTRAL.
DISTRICT OFFICES UP COLOCATED
NOT HEADQUARTERS OFFICE AND THAT
OFFICE SERVES.
A SAM A TALE SAN FRANCISCO MORAN
AND SONOMA COUNTIES.
IN ADDITION WE ARE REQUIRED BY
STATUTE TO BE LOCATED IN A
COASTAL COUNTY.
AND ANYWHERE WITHIN THE BAY AREA
COURSE HAS REALLY.
EXPENSIVE -- OFFICE LEASE SPACE
AS YOU ALL KNOW.
SO THE COMMISSIONS -- TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TO THOSE
TWENTIES GOVERNOR BUT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES THE
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS TO COVER MOVING
CONSTRUCTION COST.
IN ADDITION THE NEW OFFICE SPACE
INCLUDE SOME ADDITIONAL --
SQUARE FOOTAGE IT COULD BE
SUBLEASE TO ANOTHER STATE AGENCY.
AND THE GS IS ACTIVELY SEEKING --
SAID.
STATE AGENCY TENANTS TO SUBLEASE
THAT ADDITIONAL SPACE.
AND DTS ESTIMATES OF WE WE MOVED
INTO THE OFFICE.
BY THE BEGINNING OF SEPTEMBER.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND WE'RE
NOT GONNA START PAYING RENT OF
COURSE UNTIL THE BEGINNING OF
THE FISCAL YEAR AND WE'RE HERE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS -- MY
CHIEF DEPUTIES HANDS HAS BEEN
INVOLVED WITH THIS -- INTERNALLY
FOR LAST.
SEVERAL MONTHS NOW THANK YOU.
FINANCE GET THE MESSAGE SENATE
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL OUR YES
AND OUR STAFF HAS MET WITH MANY
STAFF AND AND YOUR IT'S SO NOTED
THIS RIGHT.
HELLO YEAH I WOULDN'T KNOWN AS
PART OF THE CONCERN WITH THIS IS
WE DIDN'T GET THE DETAIL BUT THE
COMMISSION HAS BEEN REALLY
RESPONSIVE AND PROVIDING.
THE DETAIL THAT WOULD HAVE
OTHERWISE BEEN IN A BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL I THINK THE ONE
THING THAT WOULD GIVE US PAUSE
HERE'S AT THIS NEW LOCATION IS
LARGER THAN IS NEEDED BY THE
COMMISSION AND HAS ACCESS SPACE.
BUT THEY'VE INDICATED THAT THEY
DID THEIR DUE DILIGENCE AND IT'S
JUST REALLY HARD IN SAN
FRANCISCO TO FIND OFFICE SPACE
SO IT WILL BE KEY FOR DIGESTIVE
FIND A SUB TENANT TO TED TAKE
OVER THAT ADDITIONAL A NEEDED
SPACE IN ORDER THEM. TO THEM
MAKE THIS WORK FOR THE STATE BUT
THEY HAVE INDICATED THEY HAVE
EVERY INTENTION TO DO SO WELLS
LEAST STATUTORILY THEY DON'T
HAVE TO BE IN SAN FRANCISCO LIKE
THE CDC THAT'S THEY HAVE JUST
HAVE TO BE ON COASTAL. THREE NO
SO WE HAVE THAT LITTLE WIGGLE
ROOM OKAY -- IT'S IN HOLD MATTER
OPEN.
A THIS IS THE ON THE FINAL MILE
FOR MATTER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION I WILL OPEN
THE PUBLIC HEARING.
ANYBODY.
POLICE COST ENTHUSIASTIC COMMENT.
WE WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING --
OUR WORK IS DONE WILL HOLD IT
OPEN SEE YOU GUYS LATER NEXT
MONTH.
LET'S GO TO THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION -- THE BOARD AND
TALK ABOUT PROP.
SIXTY EIGHT THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER.
FOURTEEN MEMBERS IN WE DID DEAL
WITH THIS.
ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF PROP
SIXTY THAT ARE MARCH SEVENTH
HEARING SO THERE'S NO ACTION
REQUIRED.
GREAT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S JOHN
DOLLY AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD.
IN PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT
PROVIDES TO HONOR SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION TO THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD TO FIND A
VARIETY OF ACTIVITIES AND
PROJECTS.
THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF FUNDING
PROVIDED BY PROP SIXTY EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN MILLION
IS IDENTIFIED.
FOR AND WILL BE USED TO SUPPORT
W. SEABEES EXISTING PROGRAMS
WHICH MAY INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE.
OAKLAND CONSERVATION AND
EDUCATION.
BECAUSE SYSTEM RESTORATION ON
AGRICULTURAL LANDS FORCED
CONSERVATION RANGE LAND GRAZING
LANDING GRASSLANDS PROJECT
[inaudible]
RIPARIAN -- CONSERVATION PROGRAM
AS WELL AS REGIONAL CONSERVATION
INVESTMENT STRATEGY HATCHER
COMMITTEE CONSERVATION PLANNING
PROJECTS IN SUPPORT OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
NATURISM OF SYSTEM PROJECTS.
THE REMAINDER OF PROPOSITION
SIXTY EIGHT FUNDING.
FOR OR ONE HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
COMPETITIVE GRANTS TO PLAN.
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT CLIMATE
ADAPTATION RESILIENCY PROJECTS
AND PROVIDE HUNTING FISHING AND
OTHER WILDLIFE DEPENDENT.
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
THESE TYPES OF PROJECTS MAY
INCLUDE PROMOTING THE PROTECTION
OF THREATENED AND ENDANGERED
SPECIES.
AND CONTROL OF NON NATIVE
INVASIVE SPECIES.
VIED WATER FOR FISH AND WILDLIFE
OR IMPROVE AQUATIC AND RIPARIAN
HABITATS.
TECH IN RESTORE OPEN SPACE
WILDLIFE CORRIDORS INTERLINK
AGES TO IMPROVE CONNECTIVITY AND
REDUCE BARRIERS BETWEEN HABITAT
AREAS.
AND PROJECTS TO PROTECT AND
RESTORE HABITAT AND WILDLIFE
CORRIDORS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PACIFIC FLYWAY.
THIS IS NEW IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET THE PACIFIC FLYWAY
FUNDING AND PUNGENT POTENTIAL
PROJECTS WOULD INCLUDE INCREASED
FOOD SUPPLIES FOR MY GRADING.
AND BRING WATER FELL AND OTHER
WATER BIRDS.
PROVIDE OPTIMAL FORAGING NESTING.
AND BROOD HABITAT FOR MIGRATING
AND BRING WATER FELL SHORT BIRDS
AND WATER BIRDS AND PROVIDE
SUMMER WETLANDS CRUCIAL TO
BREEDING WATER BIRDS ANOTHER WAY
WHAT PLAN.
WILDLIFE THE DEPEND ON THE
WETLANDS DURING THE SUMMERTIME.
IN ADDITION THERE'S TWO MORE
AREAS THAT WE PLAN TO FOCUS ON
WITH THIS -- FUNDING ENOUGH TO
CONSTRUCT REPAIR.
AND OR MODIFY OR REMOVE
TRANSPORTATION OR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE TO IMPROVE
WILDLIFE AND FISH FISH PASSAGE.
AND THEN LASTLY IS TO PROTECT
RESTORING HANDS LANDS WITHIN THE
UPPER WATERSHEDS OF THE SIERRA
NEVADA AND CASCADE MOUNTAINS.
WE ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT --
AT LEAST 20% OF OUR FUNDING WILL
GO TOWARDS SEVERELY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
AND UP 25% OF ANY GRANT TO WE
WILL MAKE OVER THE NEXT -- YEAR.
MAYBE USE FOR COMMUNITY ACCESS.
PURPOSES THE MORNING ENGAGEMENT
PROGRAMS TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THE PHYSICAL AND EDUCATIONAL
ACCESS TO WILDLIFE AND CULTURAL
RESOURCES.
WELL I'VE CONSERVATION BOARD
APPROVED -- GENERAL PROPOSITION
SIXTY EIGHT GUIDELINES THAT ARE
NOVEMBER IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN JUST THIS PAST NOVEMBER
AND HAS DEVELOPED A SCHEDULED TO
RELEASE PUBLIC SOLICITATION
NOTICES OVER THE NEXT SIX MONTHS.
A SOLICITATION NOTICE FOR
RESOURCE CONSERVATION THAT
INVESTMENT STRATEGY -- WORK
PROPOSALS HAS BEEN RELEASED IT
WAS A REAL CITY AT THE END OF
JANUARY.
AND WILL BE CONSIDERING OUR
FIRST PROPOSAL UNDER THAT
PROJECT -- PROGRAM AT WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD MEETING IN
MAY.
A SOLICITATION NOTICE ALSO FOR
THE WILDLIFE CORRIDORS AND PHYS
FISH PASSAGE PROGRAM WILL BE
RELEASED TOMORROW.
US OVERLOOK IN -- TO RECEIVE
PROJECTS OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
WEEKS -- FOR THAT PROGRAM AS
WELL.
OTHER SOLICITATIONS UNDER
PROPOSITION.
SIXTY EIGHT AFTER THE LOWER
AMERICAN RIVER CONSERVANCY
PROGRAM.
THE SIERRA NEVADA AND CASCADES --
HAD WATER PROGRAM PUBLIC ACCESS.
AND PACIFIC FLYWAY CORRIDOR
PROJECTS WILL BE RELEASED OVER
THE NEXT TWO MONTHS.
THE B. C. B. AS A SMALL AND
DEDICATED STAFF -- TO IMPLEMENT
THIRTEEN FUNDING PROGRAMS.
AND WE SECURE THE HELP AND
ASSISTANCE OF OUR FEDERAL STATE
AND LOCAL PARTNERS TO ASSIST US
IN THE WORK THAT WE DO.
AS AN EXAMPLE OF ALL PROJECTS
APPROVED BY THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD -- THE
BIOLOGICAL MERITS OF THE ANY
PROPOSAL CONSIDERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OR BY THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD.
IS CONSIDERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE AND OTHERS
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH CAL FIRE IN
THE DEPARTMENT ON FORCE.
RELATED HABITAT PROJECTS AND
ENGAGE DEPARTMENT CONSERVATION
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE AND OTHERS IN OUR
CLIMATE RESILIENCY IN NATURAL IN
WORKING LAND SO SHE DID PROGRAMS.
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT ALSO
REQUIRES THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD TO UPDATE ITS
CURRENT STRATEGIC PLAN.
WE HAVE HIRED A RETIRED AND
MILITANTS -- AND WILL BE
CONTRACTING WITH THE CENTER OF
COLLABORATIVE POLICY. TO ASSIST
US IN COMPLETING A PUBLIC WEB
BASED SURVEY.
I WILL ALSO BE HOLDING TO PUBLIC
WORKSHOPS ONE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND ONE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. TO SOLICIT INPUT AND
SEEK RECOMMENDATIONS IN SUPPORT
OF COMPLETING OUR STRATEGIC PLAN
WORK.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA -- PUBLIC
WORKSHOP HAS BEEN SCHEDULED TO
BE HELD ON MAY NINTH.
DOWN IN AT THE AUDUBON CENTER AT
DEB'S PARK IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES.
AND THEN THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WORKSHOP HAS BEEN SCHEDULED TO
BE HERE HELD HERE IN SACRAMENTO
DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO ON MAY
FIFTEENTH.
OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE A DRAFT PLAN
READY -- OR LEASE RECEIVE
FEEDBACK FROM THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD AND THE
PUBLIC GENERALLY AT OUR MAY
MEETING.
AND THEN HAVE A STRATEGIC PLAN A
FINAL SRATEGIC PLAN FOR
CONSIDERATION BY THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD.
AT OUR AUGUST MEETING.
THERE IS THE BEES MADE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
IMPORTANT WATERSHEDS AND COASTAL
AREAS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR VALUED
FEDERAL STATE.
LOCAL AND NON PROFIT PARTNERS.
AND WITH THAT BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS STRUCTURE.
OKAY -- COMMENTS YEAH JUSTICE%
THIS IS QUITE A BIT OF PROP
SIXTY MANY ANNUAL RECALL FROM
EARLIER HEARING THAT THERE
WASN'T A LOT OF DETAIL PROVIDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SO EVEN
THIS AMOUNT OF DETAIL THAT THE
COMMISSION -- THE BOARD RATHER
HAS PROVIDED IN YOUR AGENDA IS
QUITE HELPFUL -- AND NOTHING
JUMPED OUT AT US AS INCONSISTENT
WITH THE BOND OR RAISING ANY
CONCERNS.
I GUESS MY QUESTION IS I WAS ON
THE HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN DOLLARS
JUST TO CHEER OR THIRTIES.
IN THIRTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
RIGHT BUT HE DOES WE HAVE ALMOST
HALF OF ITS SEVENTY IS SORT OF A
EXCEPT.
ARE IN THE WORK RIGHT WE HAVE
SOME SPECIFIC PROJECTS ARE LINED
OUT -- REQUISITION DEVELOPMENT
FOR REGIONAL CONSERVATION AND
THEN THE SEVENTY MILLION IS THAT
A TIMING THING BECAUSE WE WE DID
THIS AND OUR CHARGE RIGHT RIGHT.
IT IS THE TIMING -- ISSUE THE
SEVENTY MILLION THAT WE RECEIVED
ARE YOU TALK ABOUT WHAT WE SEE
LAST YEAR -- YES THAT WAS IT
ACTUALLY WENT TO SEVERAL
PROGRAMS AS WELL WITH W. SEE THE
AND WE WORKED ON GETTING OUR
GUIDELINES TOGETHER WHICH DID
NOT COME TOGETHER UNTIL NOVEMBER --
SO THAT'S THAT'S REALLY WHAT
IT'S ABOUT.
AND THEN -- THE ON THE CLIMATE
PREPAREDNESS I'M STILL WORKING
THROUGH MY THE REPORT FROM THE
TIMBER FORCED THE FORESTRY FOLKS
I MEAN THEY'RE USING A HOT THIS
IS THE HIGH SIERRA.
THE WATERSHED RESTORATION
THINNING OF FOR US.
THEY'RE LOOKING AT A FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR.
NUMBER SO. SIXTY MILLION IS
RIGHT.
A START.
A START -- CAN YOU.
SHED SOME LIGHT ON HOW YOU THINK
THIS THE SIERRA NEVADA AND THE
CASCADE MOUNTAINS VARIETY OF
WORKED IT'S THEIR JUST START --
HOW MIGHT WE HEAR BACK FROM YOUR
BOARD AFTER THIS WORK IS DONE?
I'M TRYING TO I'M TRYING.
TO WITH A LOT OF ADAPTATION WORK
TO DO A LOT OF FORCE.
WORK TO DO AND WHAT THE QUESTION
ALWAYS COMES OUT TO US BANG FOR
OUR BUCK ARE WE HOW DOES IT HOW
DOES.
HOW DOES THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD WORK TOGETHER
WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR WHO'S
GOT A REPORT OUT AND WITH THE
FORCE PEOPLE AND WHAT THE?
WATERSHED PEOPLE WHOMEVER THEY
MAY BE THAT THAT WORKS SO THAT
WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME PAGE AND
WE SAY THIS IS THE WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE IN THIS NEEDS
TO BE DONE.
ABOVE OR A BILL.
SINCE WE JUST DROPPED.
A BILLION DOLLARS A FIX THAT UP
YOU'D LIKE TO THINK THAT YOU
COULD MANAGE THAT HIGH SIERRA
LAND.
BETTER.
RATE -- LAKE WAS TALKED ABOUT
PREVIOUSLY BY SOME OF THE OTHER
SPEAKERS W. C. B. CHORD IT'S A
LOT WITH OTHER ORGANIZATIONS AND
STATE AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
WE ARE ON THE SIERRA NEVADA
LEADERSHIP FORUM FOR THE FOR THE
ZERO PROJECT THAT CAL FIRE IS
CURRENTLY CONSIDERING -- WE ARE
PARTICIPATING THE SOUTHERN ZERO
LEADERSHIP FORUM NEXT WEEK AND
SO THOSE ARE THOSE ARE GROUPS AN
OPPORTUNITY IS THAT WE ALL GET
ON THE SAME PAGE.
AND WILL BE ABLE TO DO PROJECTS
CONSISTENTLY.
COMPATIBILITY AND ALSO TOGETHER
AND YOU KNOW MAKE OUR FUNDING GO
A LOT FARTHER MET LEVERAGING OUR
FUNDING WITH OTHER FUNDING AS
WELL.
AND THEN I HANDED OUT I HAD THE
SURGEON OURS HIM THAT OUT YOU
KNOW THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
THINGS WE WANT TO DO.
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS TO LET YOU
KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH THIS
FUNDING WHERE THE FOR THE WHERE
THE FUNDING IS GOING THE KINDS
OF PROJECTS THAT WE'RE DOING.
AND THE SUCCESSES THAT WERE
MAKING ALONG THE WAY SO THAT'S
KIND OF WHAT WE'RE HOPING TO DO
MEMBERS QUESTIONS OF DOCTOR
DONNELLY.
OKAY THIS IS [inaudible]
CENTER STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN A
WELCOME DIRECTOR -- QUESTION
ABOUT.
WE WE TALKED TO THE SECRETARY
RESOURCE ABOUT THIS IN A FEW
HEARINGS BACK BUT THIS WOULD
OVERALL PROMISED AROUND PROP
SIXTY EIGHT AND THE EQUITY
DRIVEN INTENTIONS BUT ALSO.
THIS COMMUNITY ACCESS PIECE.
TRYING TO GET A SENSE FROM YOU
WHAT PROGRESS YOU THINK WE'RE
MAKING WE GOT A GOOD SIGNAL FROM
THE SECRETARY.
THAT HE THOUGHT -- WE WERE
GETTING -- GOOD PROJECTS MOVING
BUT NOT IN.
THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN THIS SORT OF
TENSION AROUND.
WHAT?
WHETHER WE CAN DO STAND ALONE OR
WE HAVE TO SORT OF PACKAGE THESE
THINGS TOGETHER IN TERMS OF
ACCESS.
WHEN W VOTED?
ON THIS IN THE LEGISLATURE WE
WENT THROUGH AND SB FIVE IN.
YOU KNOW -- STEP FOR NOT THIS
COMMITTEE VEGAS NATURI SO ONE I
MEAN I I SORT OF FELT LIKE THE
POLICY INTENTION WAS TO FIND A
FRAMEWORK THAT -- ALLOWED NIMBLE
USE OF FUNDS IN THAT WAY BUT DO
YOU THINK THIS IS THE PLACE TO
BE DOING MORE OF THAT HOW DO YOU
VIEW THAT ISSUE IN THE CONTEXT
OF YOUR YOUR BUDGET I THINK AT
LEAST STARTING OUT -- FOR THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD YOU
KNOW YOU KNOW WE'RE ALLOWING UP
25% IN ANY GIVEN GRANTS FOR A
COMMUNITY ACCESS.
AND I THINK THAT'S A START YOU
WILL SEE HOW SUCCESSFUL THAT IS
GOING FORWARD BUT ANOTHER THING
THEY WERE DOING IS THAT WE NEED
TO REACH THOSE AREAS WHERE THAT
KIND OF FUNDING IN THOSE KINDS
OF PROJECTS WOULD BE GENERATED.
AND I THINK I MEAN THAT'S I
DON'T THINK I KNOW THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY WE'RE HOLDING A
PUBLIC WORKSHOP.
DOWN IN THE MIDDLE OF LOS
ANGELES TO ACTUALLY YOU KNOW LET
FOLKS KNOW WHO WCBS WHAT KIND OF
FUNDING WE HAVE HOW CAN WE HELP
THEM IN THE KINDS OF PROJECTS.
NOT ONLY THAT THEY WANT TO DO
WITH THE ACTUALLY NEED TO DO YOU
KNOW -- PER UP FROM A HEALTH
PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW GET PEOPLE
OUTDOORS GET I'M GONNA MOVING
GET HIM.
CAM THINKING ABOUT THIS KIND OF
STUFF AND YOU KNOW YOU NEED WE
IS A STATE AGENCY AND I FEEL AS
A AS A BOARD STAFF WE NEED TO GO
OUT AND REACH THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE OTHERWISE WOULDN'T.
NORMALLY OR TRADITIONALLY HAVE
NOT REACHED AND SO.
YEAH I I COMPLETELY AGREE ME THE
PROMISE OF ALL THIS TO ME IS.
WHAT WE DO IS WE SHOULD OF
WILDNESS IN AND ALL OUR LIVES
THAT'S IT THAT'S THE GREAT?
WEALTH OF THIS STATE RIGHT THAT
YOU'RE AND ACTUALLY FEEL.
WHAT WHAT WILDERNESS IS EVEN IF
YOU LIVE IN CANOGA PARK IN SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY OR IF YOU LIVE
IN YOU KNOW -- AND URBAN
POPULATION BUT YOU HAVE YOU KNOW
BLUE HERON ESTUARY NEARBY OR
WHATEVER MAY BE I MEAN YOU SIR
TO WAKE PEOPLE UP WITH THAT BUT
DO YOU THINK IS THAT 5%
STRUCTURE AROUND YOUR GRANT
MAKING PROCESS IS THAT IN IS
THAT YOUR GUIDELINES AROUND THIS
RIGHT NOW AND IS.
THE WORKSHOPS ARE LOOKING AT
STRUCTURE IN THAT WAY LIKE IS
THAT THE RIGHT.
FRAME WE DON'T KNOW I THINK IT'S
STILL TOO EARLY TO TELL I MEAN
THIS IS A GUIDANCE AT THE
NATURAL RESOURCES OF THE EVEN SO
YOU GAVE US AND YOU KNOW WILL
LOOK TO SEE HOW SUCCESSFUL THAT
5% IS.
IN EXISTING GRANTS INTO WHETHER
OR NOT THERE WILL BE A NEED IN
THE SHORT TERM. TO ACTUALLY DO
STAND ALONE GRANT SOLICITATIONS
FOR THAT MONEY GOOD TO SEE YOU
THINK MAYBE WE CAN SURFACED TO
SOME OF THESE PROJECT IDEAS FOR
WHAT STAND ALONE MIGHT LOOK LIKE
THROUGH THIS WORKSHOP PROCESS OR
SHOULD HAVE BEEN YES I'D HEARD
OF LEASE OR JUST.
RIGHT I THINK WE CAN I THINK
THAT'S THE KIND OF INFORMATION
THAT WE CAN OUTLINE AND
ARTICULATE IN A STRATEGIC PLAN
UPDATE FORGET INSURANCE TO AND
WE'RE DOING BOTH THE SAME TIME
BECAUSE WE KNOW SOME
SOLICITATIONS ARE OUT.
AND YOU'VE GOT THAT 5% THERE BUT
OKAY GOOD SHOULD THE CREATIVITY
AND THAT'S GOOD TIMING I'M DONE
LAUGHING.
THANK YOU.
PERFECT FOR WE THIS IS NO
ACTIONS REQUIRED HERE WE KEPT
THE MATTER OPEN FROM
[inaudible]
MARCH SEVENTH [inaudible]
SO.
WE'LL CLOSE MATTER RATE THANK
YOU.
THIS IS NOW IT'S TIME.
FOR PARKS AND RECREATION -- THIS
IS ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN CONTINUE
ON OUR PROP SIXTY THEME.
THIS IS SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR PROP SIXTY FOUR FOURTEEN
POSITIONS. FOR IMPROVING AND
EXPANDING THE STATE AND LOCAL
PARKS.
QUITE A BIT LOCAL PARKS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DIRECTOR MAN GET RIGHT.
YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I'M LEE SMOG
AND I'M THE DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION -- FIRST BY WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT YOUR
LEADERSHIP PARTICULARLY WITH
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT WITH THE
DISCUSSIONS AROUND SB -- FIVE SO
OUR PIECE OF PROPOSITION --
SIXTY EIGHT WHEN WE'RE OUT
TALKING ABOUT IT WE REALLY
HIGHLIGHT THAT INCLUDE SOME OF
THE STRONGEST LANGUAGE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S EVER PUT FORWARD
INTO THE WORLD.
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF PARK PER
COMMUNITIES AND THE IMPORTANT
ROLE ON THAT WE PLAY AND SO
WE'VE TAKEN THAT VERY SERIOUSLY.
ON THE COMMUNITIES HAVE RECEIVED
VERY POSITIVELY -- IT'S HARD
IT'S ALL THE LARGEST PARK
BONDING CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY SO --
WE'VE NEVER QUITE BEEN AS WELL
POSITIONED AS WE ARE TODAY TO
MAKE SOME IMPROVEMENTS IN THESE
AREAS.
IN SUMMARY ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OF THE PARK BOND --%
WAS DESIGNATED TO GO TOWARDS --
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS -- AND
ROUGHLY NINE HUNDRED MILLION
GOES OUT TO THE THE COMMUNITIES
THAT LOCAL ASSISTANCE.
OUR FIRST FOCUS ON THIS WAS
REALLY TO STAND UP GUIDELINES
AND PRINCIPLES GOVERNING HOW
WE'RE GOING -- TO DESIGNATE
THOSE FUNDS OUT INTO COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- WE HAVE I'VE
ACTUALLY GOT OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR --
OF OF THE GRANTS PROGRAM THAT'S
ACTUALLY BEEN KIND OF THE
FORWARD FACE OF US ENGAGING
HIMSELF WITH THESE COMMUNITIES --
AND WERE OUTLINING THE
GUIDELINES WE'VE BEEN VERY
PLEASED WITH THE INTENDANTS --
OUR FIRST ARE WE ALWAYS FOR IT
FIRST WORRY THAT WE HOLD A
LISTENING SESSION AN ENGAGEMENT
SESSIONS AND COMMUNITIES DON'T
SHOW UP -- SORT VERY PLEASED
THAT THAT HAS NOT BEEN THE CASE
IT'S ALSO GIVEN US A BETTER
SENSE OF KIND OF WHAT THE NEEDS
ARE.
OUT IN THE COMMUNITY AND GETTING
A LOT OF EXCITEMENT OUT THERE SO
FOLKS REALIZE THAT IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM AND THAT
THEY CAN LEAN IN AND THEY'LL
APPLY AT THE APPROPRIATE TIMES.
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL BEFORE USE
SPECIFICALLY FOR OUR TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND TWENTY HAS --
THREE IMPORTANT COMPONENTS ONE
WOULD BE -- THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION THAT IT'S REALLY FOR
PROGRAM DELIVERING -- BUT I'D
REALLY CALL YOUR ATTENTION TO
THERE'S FIFTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION REALLY KIND OF FOCUSING
MORE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
SPECIFICALLY IT STATE PARKS.
AND THEN ALSO ABOUT FIFTY ONE
MILLION IN PROGRAMMING AND THAT
IS THE FUNDING THAT WOULD BE
PUSHED OUT ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO LOCAL COMMIT
COMMUNITIES.
AND AT ON THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE WE'VE HAD PREVIOUS
YEARS THE NUMBERS GIGANTIC IS
THE FIFTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
JUST WHAT THE WORK DO YOU THINK
YOU CAN GET DONE NOW OR IS THIS.
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE THAT.
WE'VE GOT THOSE.
EMPTY FIVE GALLON WATER BUCKETS
THAT'S COLLECTING THE WATER FROM
THE RAIN AND WE REALLY THERE'S
WE CAN'T WAIT ANYMORE TO PUT THE
THE ROOF ON THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- WE'VE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME IN THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
TALKING WITH YOU ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
THINGS TO TACKLE AT FIRST WAS
FRANKLY.
JUST KIND OF GET A BETTER
ASSESSMENT AND PRIORITIZING THE
NEEDS OUT THERE -- WE'VE BEEN
VERY PUBLIC AND SPOKEN WITH YOU
IN THE PST THAT WE HAVE OVER A
ONE BILLION DOLLAR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG AND THAT
INCLUDES EVERYTHING FROM --
WATER STANDS ACQUITTED WATER
SYSTEMS ROOFS -- YOU KNOW ROADS
BRIDGES ALL OF THOSE THINGS THAT
YOU THINK OF FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FOR PARKS.
ARE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE LIST
ALSO IS JUST A LITTLE MORE --
COMPLICATED IN THAT YOU CAN
IMAGINE THAT THESE PROJECTS ARE
OFTEN IN SOME OF THE MOST REMOTE
AREAS IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN VERY NATURALLY --
CULTURALLY SENSITIVE AREAS MAYBE
ALONG THE COAST SO IT REQUIRES
US TO BE REALLY EXTRA EXTRA
THOUGHTFUL AND CAREFUL ON THE
FRONT END OF THE PLANNING SO --
I WOULD HIGHLY THAT THREE
DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU FOLKS --
WELL THIS BUDGET INCLUDES A
TOTAL OF EIGHTY MILLION IN ONE
TIME FUNDING AND THAT WOULD BE
OF AVAILABLE OVER THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS TO TACKLE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
AND THAT BUILDS UPON ROUGHLY
EIGHTY MILLION THAT YOU HAVE
PROVIDED US OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS THOSE PROJECTS ARE
STILL VERY MUCH WORKING TO THE
PIPELINES -- OVER THE LAST
YEAR'S WHAT YOU'VE DONE IS THAT
YOU'VE PROVIDED US ONE TIME
APPROPRIATIONS AND THEN WE HAVE
PROVIDED YOU A LIST OF
PRIORITIZE PROJECTS THAT VERY
TRANSPARENT YOU HAVE A SENSE OF
HOW THOSE FUNDS.
ARE BEING DISTRIBUTED ACROSS THE
STATE PARK SYSTEM AND IT'S OUR
INTENTION TO PROVIDE A SIMILAR
LIST YOU AND WE'RE WORKING ON
THAT WILL BE PROVIDING THAT TO
YOU SOON YEAH BECAUSE PROP.
SIXTY EIGHT THE MAGIC NUMBER IS.
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS SO WE'RE WERE.
THERE'S NO TIME LIKE THE PRESENT
WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH THE
BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF AT BEST
WE WERE GOING TO GET 20% OF THE
WORK DONE AT THE BASS IF WE DID
IT.
ORIGINALLY ALTOGETHER PERHAPS I
SHOULD THE ODDS -- IN RESPONSE
TO YOUR QUESTION THAT I THINK.
YOU KNOW.
WE ALSO HAVE A CAPACITY ISSUE TO
BE ABLE TO PUSH OUT THAT MUCH
MONEY ALL IN ONE YEAR SO WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED THE FULL TWO
HUNDRED MILLION BUT WE'RE JUST
KIND OF STRATEGICALLY TRYING --
TO ONCE WE ACTUALLY GET THE
APPROPRIATION WE HAVE A
SPECIFIED PERIOD OF TIME IN
WHICH TO ACTUALLY ENCUMBER THE
FUNDS.
SO WE'VE WORKED VERY CLOSE TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
IDENTIFY WHAT THAT IS ON THE
OTHER WAY THAT I WOULD SAY TO
YOU THAT YOU HELPED US TACKLE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
AS THAT LAST YEAR -- YOU
APPROVED A PACKAGE OF THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE NEW
POSITIONS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS DEPARTMENT --
ROUGHLY ONE HUNDRED OF THOSE
POSITIONS WERE SPECIFICALLY
TARGETED TO FIXING OUR PARKS AND
MAINTENANCE SO WE ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE HIRING PROCESS FOR
THE THREE HUNDRED SIXTY THREE
POSITION SO.
WE'RE KIND OF TACKLING IT -- TWO
WAYS RIGHT NOT JUST THESE ONE
TIME APPROPRIATIONS TO ACTUALLY
TACKLE THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BACKLOG BUT ALSO BUILDING UP OUR
MAINTENANCE CAPACITY. TO AT A
MINIMUM SLOW THE GROWTH OF THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG AND
JUST REALLY YOU KNOW -- GET ON
TOP OF TACKLING THE LAST AND
WE'VE PROVIDED YOU WOULDN'T IT
EXCELLENT SEASON OF WEATHER SO
THAT YOU COULD YOU KNOW THE
TREES THAT WERE THE LIMBS THAT
CAME DOWN THE THE IMMEDIATE
EMERGENCY REMOVAL AND
MAINTENANCE WORK WHICH IS.
INCREASE THE LA -- DO YOU HAVE A
COMMENT.
AS COMPUTERS AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND AS OUR
OFFICE HAS AN I TESTIFIED BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE ON THE THE LARGER
PROP SIXTY AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROPOSALS THAT YOU
HEARD.
AB PREVIOUSLY I'LL JUST.
REMIND YOU OF THOSE COMMENTS AND
IF IT SPECIFICALLY FOR PARKS AND
SO FOR THESE PROPOSALS WE FOUND
IS THAT JUST OVERALL THE SOME OF
THE DETAIL WAS A LITTLE BIT
LACKEY AND ADD THAT WE YOU KNOW
WE THINK THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
LEGISLATURE YOU'RE GONNA WANT TO
MAKE SURE.
YOU REALLY HAVE SUFFICIENT
DETAIL ON THESE PROPOSALS IN
THAT IT MATCHES WITH YOUR
PRIORITIES.
AND THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN -- RESPONSIVE IN PROVIDING
US ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON
THESE PROPOSALS AS WE'VE ASKED.
AND THE FOR SPECIFICALLY FOR
PARKS THERE'S TWO AREAS WHERE WE
THINK THEY'RE STILL MORE
INFORMATION ON THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO WANT TO SEE BEFORE YOU TAKE
ACTION ON THESE -- AND ONE IS
RELATED TO THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND AS WAS DISCUSSED
BY THE DIRECTOR READY AND WE
HAVE NOT BEEN PROVIDED AND YOUR
YOU AND YOUR STAFF HAVE NOT BEEN
PROVIDED A PRIORITIZED LIST --
THE LIST THAT WAS GIVEN IS YOU
KNOW MANY MANY PAGES LONG AND
ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE PROJECTS AND PRETTY MUCH
EVERYTHING IS IN THERE
ALPHABETICAL ORDER.
I'M AND AND THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS ON THAT LIST THAT ARE
MAYBE NOT THINGS YOU EVEN
TRADITIONALLY THINK OF AS BEING
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND SO WE
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
YOU HAVE A SENSE AND THAT --
PARK STAFF HAS PROVIDED SOME
CATEGORIES OF HOW THEY'RE GONNA
AND PRIORITIZE PROJECTS BUT
REALLY GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE OF
THE SIZE OF THEIR BACKLOG IT'S
REALLY.
YOU REALLY DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE GONNA SPEND THESE FUNDS
ON WITHOUT GETTING A PRIORITIZED
LIST AND SO YOU THINK THAT WILL
BE IMPORTANT.
AND THE AND THEN WITH REGARD TO
SOME OF THE OTHER PROP SIXTY
EIGHT PROPOSALS AND JUST CALLING
ATTENTION AS YOUR STAFF AGENDA
DOES -- AS WELL TO THIRTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR REVENUE
ENHANCEMENT AND REVENUE.
GENERATION OF PROGRAMS AND PROP
SIXTY EIGHT FUNDED FOR PARKS
THESE ARE NEW PROGRAMS AND AND
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THAT THAT I I
AM PROPOSAL WAS MADE BASICALLY A
SPREADSHEET THERE REALLY ISN'T A
LOT OF DETAIL.
WE'VE ASKED FOR SOME ADDITIONAL
DETAIL FROM PARKS AND AND WE WE
WE'VE GOTTEN SOME INFORMATION
BUT IT'S MORE ALONG THE LINES OF
WHAT WHAT WE'RE GOING TO SPEND
THE MONEY ON IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE BOND ACT IN SO.
YOU MAY HAVE SOME QUESTIONS AS
YOUR AGENDA NOTES ON MORE
SPECIFICALLY HOW THE FANS ARE
GOING TO BE ALLOCATED HOW THE
PROGRAMS ARE GOING TO BE
STRUCTURED -- WHY THIS SPECIFIC
FUNDING AMOUNTS ON IN THIS YEAR
I'M FOR THE REVENUE GENERATION
AND PROPOSALS PARKS HAS
INDICATED TO S. I'M SOME
EXAMPLES OF TYPES OF PROJECTS
AND LAKES NEW AND?
CAMPGROUNDS AM OR OTHER PROJECTS
TO INCREASE REVENUES BANG FOR
YOU TO GET A BETTER SENSE OF WHO
EXACTLY YOU KNOW HOW THESE FUNDS
TO BE SPENT HOW THESE NEW
PROGRAMS WILL BE STRUCTURED.
SINCE HE'S A REALLY NEW PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE I THINK THE LAST
ONE IT -- TO THE VARIOUS
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS NOT A
RETURN ON INVESTMENT BUT I AND I
REALIZE IT'S PARK.
HELP US OUT YOU KNOW WE HAVE WE
WERE JUST HAD A BIG DISCUSSION
ABOUT CLIMATE ADAPTATION THERE'S
FOUR HUNDRED FORTY THREE IN
CLAMOR PREPAREDNESS AND HABITAT
RESILIENCY.
AND THEN WE GOT MONEY FOR YOU
KNOW.
INVESTMENTS AN ENVIRONMENTAL
INTO DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND WE GOT TO THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE YES SOMETIMES.
I SEE A LINK BETWEEN THEM
BECAUSE YOU WHEN YOU DO THE
ANALYSIS YOU SAY BECAUSE OF THE
CLAIM MEANS.
CHANGING CLIMATE THIS MAY BE.
ENDANGERED AREA AND WE MADE
RATHER THAN REPEAT FIX AD
REPAIR WE MIGHT WANT TO THINK
ABOUT.
MOVING IT.
UP WATER ARE UP UP UP THE APPEAL
IN A NEW ONE IN THE AGAIN THAT'S
MORE MONEY BUT AT LEAST THAT
ANALYSIS IS COME IN THE SAY.
WE'RE GONNA BAND IN REPAIRING
THE ROOF HERE OR OR MAYBE EVEN
ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE -- TO DO IT --
AS WE TRY.
TO GET THE BIGGEST BANG FOR OUR
BUCK WITH THE MONEY LET'S GO
BACK TO THE REVENUE ENHANCEMENT
THE THIRTY SEVEN MILLION I MADE
A NOTE ABOUT THAT BUT I DIDN'T
FLIP MY PAGE -- DIRECTOR DID YOU
HAVE ANY.
DETAILS TO SHINE ON THAT PROGRAM
THAT GRANT PROGRAM.
I'LL DO THAT MY NAME IS CENTERED
MITCHELL I'M DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT -- THE REVENUE HAS A
PROGRAM -- IS A PER CAPITA TYPE
PROGRAM AND IT IN THE SPIRIT OF
WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH THE PER
CAPITA PROGRAM THAT WAS
ALLOCATED LAST YEAR THE BOOK --
THE THE VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE
DOLLARS -- AND THE ADDITIONAL
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION THAT WE'VE
ASKED FOR FOR THE ROLE PORTION
OF THAT PER CAPITA -- WEIRD.
COMBINING OUR EFFORTS TO
IDENTIFY THE UNIVERSE OF WHO WAS
PASSED IN THIS CASE WHO HAS
PASSED THE TAX REVENUE
ENHANCEMENT MEASURE THAT.
IS SPECIFIC TO OR PARK
ENHANCEMENT I IN ORDER TO DO
THAT WE NEED TO SURVEY THE
ENTIRE STATE WE NEED TO SURVEY
ALL OF THE POTENTIAL -- COUNTIES
CITIES -- JURISDICTIONS THAT DID
THAT WERE IN THE PROCESS OF
DOING THAT -- AS WE SPEAK WE
HAVE SENT OUT A SURVEY TO ALL
THE POTENTIAL -- AGENCIES ARE
PROVIDING RECREATIONAL SERVICES
OR THAT MAY HAVE DONE THAT ONCE
WE GET THOSE BACK WHICH WE'RE
EXPECTING THOSE TO BE RETURNED
TO US BY JUNE.
OF THIS YEAR -- WE WOULD THEN BE
ABLE TO SEE WHAT THE THE
UNIVERSITY IS OF HOW THAT WILL
BE SPENT OUT WOULDN'T YOU KNOW
SOME OF THAT INFORMATION JUST ON
THE NATURAL.
I MEAN YOU HAVE BEEN WE ASK
EVERY LOCAL PARK.
ADMINISTRATOR WHAT THE WHAT
MONEY THEY NEED YEAH THAT'LL BE
A BIG LESSON THAT WILL BE A LOT
OF HEARINGS BUT IN.
INPUT BUT YOU KNOW SOME WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE SOME PARK
FACILITIES THAT ARE IN NATURAL
WATERSHEDS THAT HAVE BEEN
DESTROYED.
IN IN IN OR PRIOR REDUCE AND
THEY HAVE ACCESS FOR THE PUBLIC.
ALL THE PUBLIC ADVANTAGE
DISADVANTAGE PUBLIC AT SCHOOL
WHEN WE GET THE EXTRA BANG FOR
THE CARBON SEQUESTRATION BECAUSE
WE IMPROVE THAT WATERSHED WE GET
MORE.
RETENTION OF WATER WE WE REDUCE
THE FIRED FIRED LEVEL IN VERSE
IS A STANDALONE PARK.
THAT IN MICE DISTRICT LET'S PICK
ON ME AND MY DISTRICT IT'S NICE
PART PEOPLE WANT TO DO IT BUT
IT'S NOT REALLY IN THE CLIMB IT.
I ARENA THAT BECAUSE IT'S NOT A
NATURAL WATERSHED -- AREA I
DON'T ARE YOU ABLE TO JUST MAKE
THAT.
THIS IS ONLY THIRTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS RIGHT IT'S NOT
THAT MUCH.
I WORRIED ABOUT IF IT'S NOT THAT
MUCH MONEY WELL EXCEPT THAT
THEIR OF THEIR ABOUT THE
THOUSAND RECREATION PROVIDERS IN
THE STATE -- RANGING FROM SMALL
DISTRICTS TO CITIES AND
MUNICIPALITIES WE NEED TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT WE INCLUDE ALL OF
THOSE THAT WE UNDERSTAND THE
UNIVERSE OF IT BECAUSE ONCE WE
MAKE THOSE DETERMINATIONS.
AND AND THOSE ALLOCATIONS ARE
ARE PUT OUT THERE.
THERE'S NO SECOND BITE AT THE
APPLE WE MISS SOMEONE SO WE DO
HAVE TO SURVEY EVERYONE IN ORDER
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY THEY
DIDN'T.
ARE THEY HAVE OR HAVE NOT
QUALIFIED BY PASSING A REVENUE
ENHANCEMENT MEASURE.
EQUALLY I GUESS I'M MISSING IT
WE HAVE WE HAVE REVERSING CREEK
RESTORATION I KNOW MY MY CITY.
WHEN I WAS ON THE CITY COUNCIL
TEN YEARS AGO FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
I WAS READING SOMETHING I WAS ON
THE COUNCIL I SAID TO THE PART
PEOPLE I WANT YOU TO APPLY FOR
THAT?
THEY DIDN'T WAIT FOR YOU TO COME
I MEAN THERE WAS A WEBSITE AND
HAD SOMETHING THERE BUT BUT IF
YOU GOT TO GO OUT AND HOLD
EVERYBODY'S HAND THAT'S SUCKING
UP A LOT OF MONEY.
IT DOESN'T GO INTO.
THE FIX IT OR OR OR THE PARK
RIGHT.
MISTER CHAIR MAYBE I CAN KIND OF
HELP -- ECHO -- DEPUTY DIRECTORS
MITCHELL SENTIMENTS -- YOU KNOW.
WE REALLY ARE KIND OF
APPROACHING THIS FROM A LESSONS
LEARNED EFFORT FROM THE PAST
THIS IS NOT OUR FIRST -- PART OF
IN A BOND FUNDS TO GO OUT TO THE
PUBLIC.
WE TREAT THESE FUNDS VERY
DIFFERENTLY THAN WE DO ST
GENERAL FUND TEEN AND WE DON'T
VIEW THESE FUNDS WE WE LOOK AND
TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY THE LANGUAGE
THAT'S UNDER SB.
FIVE AND THE INTENTION BEHIND US --
AND THAT THIS PART OF MONEY
WASN'T NECESSARILY SET ASIDE FOR
US TO DETERMINE WITHIN A YOU
KNOW SACRAMENTO IN OUR
ORGANIZATION.
ON HOW TO DISTRIBUTE THE FUNDS --
WE ALSO WE KNOW WHAT WE KNOW WE
WE DON'T HAVE A SENSE OF ALL OF
THE NEEDS WE ABSOLUTELY JUST
WITHIN CENTER CAN I COULD
PROBABLY EASILY SPEND THIRTY
SEVEN MILLION AND THINKING ABOUT
SOME PLACES THAT WE KNOW OF BUT
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES.
THAT WERE ALSO IS A STATE TRYING
TO OVERCOME IS REACHING ALL
COMMUNITIES SOME COMMUNITIES ARE
JUST A BETTER POSITIONED TO
ACTUALLY APPLY FOR THESE GRANTS
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WAS A
REAL.
DISCUSSION TOPIC AND DEVELOPING
SB -- FIVE AND PROPOSITION SIXTY
EIGHT IS THAT WHEN WE LOOK AT
HOW FUNDS HAD BEEN ISSUED IN THE
PAST HOW DO WE REACH THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT MAYBE NEED A
LITTLE MORE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
OR THE MINIMUM NEED TO BE AWARE
THAT THESE FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE
WE LIVE ON IT BREEDS AND EAT
THIS EVERY DAY SO WE FEEL LIKE
EVERYBODY KNOWS ABOUT THIS BUT
IN FACT.
THEY DON'T AND SO MISTER
MITCHELL COULD PROBABLY TALK A
LITTLE MORE ABOUT THAT MY IT'S
IMPORTANT.
DEFINITELY -- THE THE MEASURE
ALSO CALLS FOR PARK ADVANCEMENT --
REVENUE -- ENHANCED WITH
MEASURES -- SOME CITIES AND
COMMUNITIES -- PAST GENERAL --
INFRASTRUCTURAL MEASURES THAT.
MADE TOUCH ON PARKS BUT ARE NOT
SPECIFIC TO PARKS WE WE HAVE TO
IDENTIFY WHAT ALL OF THOSE
AREN'T AND MAKE CERTAIN THAT
WE'RE WE'RE FOR A FULFILLING
SPIRIT OF WHAT THE LAW SAYS IT
NEEDS TO FULFILL.
AND SOME OF THESE MAY BE SMALL
DISTRICTS THAT THERE THAT ARE --
AGAIN.
I THE CITY MAY PASS A A A A
SMALL TAX IN A COMMUNITY THAT IS
A LONG -- FOR ONGOING
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATION THEY
MAY BE LOOKING AT INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT SO WHAT WE FOUND IS
THAT THE UNIVERSE OF THAT'S OUT
THERE JUST IT IS A UNIVERSE
WHERE THE PER CAPITA PROGRAM IN
GENERAL -- INVOLVES -- THOUSANDS
NOT JUST A FEW HUNDRED OR JUST
AS COUNTIES IT ONCE WE START
GETTING THE UNIVERSE FROM -- THE
SECRETARY STATE ON WHO IS
POTENTIALLY ELIGIBLE AND THEN
NEED TO EVALUATE -- THE
DETERMINE IF THEY ACTUALLY ARE
THE NUMBERS INCREASE INTO THE
THOUSANDS NOT NOT IF THE
UNIVERSE IS A THOUSAND PARK
DISTRICTS ARE PARK THING.
RIGHT EVERYBODY A THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR CHECK IN.
THE THIRTY MILLION THIRTY SEVEN
MILLION IS GONE I MEAN IT'S IT'S
IF WE WANNA JUST HELP THE
KNOWLEDGEABLE NONE A
KNOWLEDGEABLE YOU CAN JUST.
IT'S IT WORKS OUT THE MAP THIS
THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND BUCKS HERE
YOU GO HERE YOU GO SAN FRANCISCO
FANCIES FANCY PARK DISTRICT IN
HERE YOU GO.
FREMONT NOTHING PARK DISTRICT
AND EVERYBODY GETS MY ACT I
GUESS I MEAN WE MAY BE LEVER
LEVERAGE IT BUT WHEN I THINK
ABOUT IT IT'S NOT.
HOW MUCH CAN YOU IMPROVE THE
PARK WITH THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS SOMETHING YOU KNOW SOME
WILL GET DONE?
I WISH I HAD MORE MONEY FOR YOU
IS WHAT SORT OF WHAT MY POINT IS
IS THAT AT THIS LOW LEVEL AND
IT'S A PER CAPITA.
RIGHT TO CHECK JUST GIVE IT TO
THEM BUT I'VE MADE MY POINT
[inaudible]
SENATE MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER PATRICK
AMEND TRACTOR IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU.
SO I THINK ON THE ISSUE OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE -- AND I
WILL NOT GOING -- TO PREVIOUS
CONVERSATIONS THAT THE DIRECTOR
AND I HAVE HAD ON ALL SHE'S A
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BUT I THINK
THAT LOOK THAT.
THE CONCERN THAT I HAVE IS ONE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO ECHO WHERE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE IS
IS BEING ABLE TO SEE WHAT THAT
PRIORITY LIST LOOKS LIKE WHAT
YOUR STRATEGY.
IN.
HOW YOU DECIDE UPON THE LOWEST
HANGING FRUIT -- AND I WOULD
ASSUME IT'S GOING TO BE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC -- AND
DO YOU HAVE A TIME LINE ON WHEN
YOU THINK THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE
ABLE TO COMPLETE THAT LIST.
I'M I FEEL LIKE IT'S RATHER
EMINENT I THINK IT'S UNDER
REVIEW WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION
SO I WOULD I'M HOPING THAT
BEFORE THE NEXT HEARING.
AND WE'RE JUST GOING TO FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS THAT WE HAVE
EVERY OTHER YEAR SO IT'S WE
RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT YOU SEE THAT YOU GET AN
ASSESSMENT.
OF HOW DUTY PRIORITIZE AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO DISCUSS WITH YOUR
METHODOLOGY BUT I THINK YOU'RE
GONNA SEE OF SIMILAR
PRIVATIZATION METHODOLOGY AS
YOU'VE SEEN IN OUR LIST OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS I WOULD LOVE
TO BE A SIT DOWN PRIOR TO THE
HEARING JUST APPEAR TO GO AND BE.
HAPPY TO GREAT I THINK THE OTHER
PIECES AND I UNDERSTAND -- MR
DIFFERENT DOUBLE CHECK TO WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT REGARDS OF
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION THE ONE
CONCERN THAT I WILL THROW OUT --
IN NO IT'S A BIT OF A BROKEN
RECORD.
IT'S WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
BERMAN COMMUNITIES.
ANY LOOK AT RURAL COMMUNITIES.
THEY'RE NOT PASSING PARK RANGERS.
AND WHAT I WORRY ABOUT.
IS THAT THOSE DOLLARS ARE
INCENTIVIZED. TO BE ABLE TO GO
TO COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE PASSED
PARK RANGERS.
BUT WHERE WE NEED TO HELP THE
MOST ARE MORE.
RURAL AND URBAN WHO CANDIDLY
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES SO
THAT'S WHY I REMAIN CONCERNED ON
THIS ONE AREA AND JUST WONDER IF
YOU HAVE A RESPONSE.
CERTAINLY WORK.
THIS PARTICULAR REVENUE ENHANCER
ONE SORT OF REWARD FOR THAT THE
LEGISLATURE GAVE ART FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT DID IN FACT.
UNDERSTAND EXTEND THEMSELVES
THERE'S ALSO ROLL COMPONENTS IN
THERE -- WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT OUR OVERALL --
GUIDELINES THE STATE TO STATE
WY PART PROGRAM AS AN EXAMPLE --
WE DESIGNED AND IN SUCH A WAY
THAT -- THERE'S A NATURAL
ORGANIC PROCESS THAT TAKES PLACE
WHERE -- RURAL COMMUNITIES CAN
COMPETE.
S. ON PAR WITH THE URBAN
COMMUNITIES WHAT YOU MIGHT WANT
TO DO IS LOOK BACK AT OUR
PROPERTY FOR UNDERSTAND WHY PARK
PROGRAM AS AN EXAMPLE AND YOU'LL
SEE THE SPREAD OF DOLLARS WERE
BOTH AND URBAN LOS ANGELES.
AND IN SMALL COMMUNITIES IN THE
IN THE IN THIS -- THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THAT THE I.
NINETY AMOUNTS OF THOSE TO
COMPETE -- REALLY HAS -- HAS --
SHOWN THAT THE PROCESS WE USE --
WORKS -- IN ORDER TO DEVELOP THE
GUIDELINES WE HAVE HAD -- SINCE
SEPTEMBER WE HAD OVER -- FOUR
HUNDRED FOLKS ENGAGED IN THAT
PROCESS WE HAD -- A SERIES OF
WORKSHOPS AND OPEN SESSIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND THEN
COMMA NAY THAT WITH ABOUT
FIFTEEN WORKSHOPS THAT WE TOOK A
FINISHED AND ON MARCH FIRST --
THAT WERE HELD THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WERE OVER FIVE HUNDRED
CAME TO THOSE THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT WE PROVIDE FOR
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND WITH IT I
ON MAKING SURE.
THAT EVERYONE IS ABLE TO COMPETE
AND PUT THEIR BEST FOOT FORWARD
ALONG WITH THE OTHER PIECES OF
TECHNICAL SYSTEMS WE PROVIDE --
I THINK I BELIEVE ADDRESS THAT
PARTICULAR CONCERN NEEDING TO BE --
TO HAVE THE DOLLARS ARE THE
MEASURE THAT IS ALREADY PASSED
OR ALLOCATED CORRECT ONLY FOR
THAT PARTICULAR PROGRAM ONLY THE
REVENUE ENHANCEMENT THE THIRTY
SEVEN MILLION THE THIRTY SEVEN
MILLION BUT FOR THE VAST
MAJORITY TO AND FORTY NINE
MILLION THAT WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
CURRENTLY -- WORKING WITH A
AUGUST FIFTH DEADLINE THEY'LL BE
ABLE TO COMPETE EQUALLY IN THAT
PROCESS AND WE'VE WE CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
THEM AND THEN.
IN IN WHAT WAS JUST FOCUS IN
THREE SEVEN MILLION THE REASON
BEING IS THAT YOU KNOW AGAIN I
THINK THAT WHERE STATE PARKS
WANTS TO BE ABLE TO GO.
AND WHERE IS BAYLOR BRING IN.
IN PARTICULAR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR.
I A N. INSURING THAT -- OUR
PARKS ARE GONNA BE OPEN FOR ALL.
I THINK WITH THE CONCERN
CONTINUES TO BE PARTICULARLY IN
URBAN AREAS IS THAT THEY'RE
UNDER PARKED.
UNDER PARK BECAUSE A LACK OF
RESOURCES.
HI END SAME THING IN RURAL.
AND I GET IT IN REGARDS TO
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION YOU DO NOT
SAY THIS IS FOR MY WORDS.
THAT IT'S A SMALLER ALLOCATION
COMPARED TO THE BIGGER POT.
BUT MY CONCERN IS THAT
ESPECIALLY IN ROLE IN IN -- IN
URBAN COMMUNITIES NOT ALL.
THEY JUST DON'T HAVE -- THE
DOLLARS ON THE TABLE TO BE ABLE
TO COMPETE AND THAT'S WHAT MY
CONCERN WITHIN PER CAPITA THERE
ALSO BE AN ALLOCATION -- FOR THE
COUNTIES THAT OR HAVE FIVE OR IN
THOUSAND OR MORE IN.
BUT BUT POPULATIONS UNDER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND THOSE SMALLER
CITIES WE'LL GET A AN ADDITIONAL
ALLOCATION BASED ON THAT'S WHERE
THE ADDITIONAL DOLLARS.
TO OF FOR IT FOR THE PER CAPITA
ROGRAM THEY WERE ASKING FOR
THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU MISTER TEMPERATURE NAY
INVENTOR NAY SAID TO ITS
IMMINENT ARE YOU THINKING THAT
IT WOULD BE RELEASED IN THE NEXT
WEEK OR TWO WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHT.
YOU KNOW I'VE GOT A CIRCLE BACK
WITH FOLKS BUT IT WOULDN'T
SURPRISE ME IF YOU HAD IT BEFORE
THE NEXT HEARING BUT WILL IF
THAT.
IF THAT IF THAT CHANGES THEN
WE'LL CIRCLE BACK WITH YOU AHEAD
OF TIME [inaudible]
SENATE.
THERE'S CHAIR ARM THANK YOU
MANDRAKE TURN DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR BEING HERE.
I WANT TO I GUESS -- ALL JUMP
OFF WHERE MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
NORTH LEFT -- LESS SO ON THE
READ IN REVENUE ENHANCER
MEASURES MORE ON THIS OR TO
ACCESS PIECE.
SIMILAR QUESTION THAT I ASKED W.
C. B. I DID SEE.
A NOTE THAT THE RELEASE OF A
DRAFT APPLICATION GUIDE IS ON
HOLD AROUND COMMUNITY ACCESS.
FUNDS IN THAT.
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND REC WOOD
WAS NOTIFIED THAT.
THE PROP SIXTY EIGHT SECTION
THAT -- WE'VE PASSED VOTED ON IN
THE VOTERS VOTED ON CAN'T BE
USED FOR PROOF TO FUND PROGRAMS
ACTIVITIES AND TRANSPORTATION.
BUT THEN I GO BACK.
TO THE LEGISLATION ACTUALLY CAST
A VOTE ON IN.
IT'S SPECIFICALLY SAYS COMMUNITY
ACCESS PROJECTS AND NOT NESTED
IN SOME OTHER PROJECT BUT
SPECIFICALLY COMMUNITY ACCESS
PROJECTS.
IN THAT INCLUDE UNLIMITED TO
TRANSPORTATION AND ONE THAT TO
ME ONE OF THE BIG GAPS.
IT'S NOT JUST ON THE CAPITAL
SIDE IN LAND ACQUISITION AND
THOSE THINGS BUT TO GET A RURAL
COMMUNITY GET SOMEONE LOW INCOME.
TO INCREDIBLE RESOURCE WE HAVE.
TO GET THERE IT'S HARD AND IT
AND MAYES BE SOMEWHAT ABOUT
GETTING A LOW COST ACCOMMODATION
BUT IT'S ALSO ABOUT JUST HAVING.
SOME SERVICE PATHWAY A PROGRAM
IS IT ABOUT YOU KNOW CAN KIDS GO
TO CAMP THERE ARE THERE WAYS TO
INTEGRATE COMMUNITIES SO YOU
DON'T JUST SORT OF PLOP THEM.
AT THIS BEAUTIFUL PARK ALONE AND
EXPECT THEM TO FIND THEIR WAY
THERE BUT THAT THAT I GUESS THAT
WAS THE PROMISE I THOUGHT WE
WERE TRYING TO MAKE.
AND I RECOGNIZE ME WE HAVE DEAL
WITH YOUR SAID LOVE TO GET YOUR
ALL FEEDBACK AS WELL BUT IT
SEEMS PRETTY CLEAR CAN YOU GUYS
SHED SOME MORE LIGHT ON THE
CURRENT STATE OF THINKING THERE
EITHER FOR THAT WE CAN START D.
O. F. EVEN IF YOU WANT.
GOOD MORNING -- MICHAEL MCGINNIS
WITH DEPARTMENT FINANCE SO THE
LANGUAGE SURROUNDING THE
COMMUNITY ACCESS PIECE OF
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT CONTAIN
SOME -- LEGAL REQUIREMENTS THAT
REQUIRE -- THAT FUNDING TO BE
SPENT IN IS CONSISTENT WITH G.
OF ONLINE PER THE AND WITH THE
CONCURRENCE OF THE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE.
SO WE'RE STILL WORKING WITH OUR
IN HOUSE COUNSEL TO DETERMINE
HOW EXACTLY THAT WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED.
OUR GOAL IS TO COME UP WITH A
FIRM DIRECTION THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE TO ALL DEPARTMENTS WHO
HAVE -- ALLOCATIONS FROM PROP
SIXTY EIGHT AND HAVE MORE A
UNIFIED ROLL OUT ON HOW THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY BE IMPLEMENTED.
I WOULD JUST SAY I MEAN I I KNOW
THE LANGUAGE YOU'RE YOU'RE
REFERRING TO HERE WHICH IS.
NOT TO THE EXTENT PERMISSIBLE
UNDER THE STATE GENERAL
OBLIGATION BOND LAW RIGHT SO AND
WITH THE CONCURRENCE OF DEAL
WITH.
IT'S BEEN A LONG STANDING ISSUE
ABOUT HOW HOW MUCH.
OF THESE BOND DOLLARS CAN GO TO
SORT OF DOLLARS ASSOCIATED SAY
WITH CAPITAL PROJECTS BUT THAT
ARE NOT.
LIKE ON THEIR VERY OWN JUST
CAPITAL PROJECTS.
I WOULD JUST SAY -- OUR INTENT
IS A LEGISLATURE I FEEL LIKE
IT'S PRETTY EXPLICIT -- SO I'M
JUST HOPING IN THROUGH THAT
PROCESS YOU GUYS CAN TAKE THAT
INTO ACCOUNT TRY TO FIND A PATH
I MEAN I I I THINK THAT'S REALLY.
THAT'S THE SPIRIT OF THE LAW
THAT WE'RE BRINGING YOU IS YEAH
WE WE'VE GOT OF THE CULTURE HERE
AND WE DON'T AND WE DON'T WANT
TO VIOLATE THE BASIC GOOD
GOVERNANCE GENERAL BOND
PRINCIPLES BUT WITH THE
THRESHOLD IT'S BEEN THAT BASED
ON PRESIDENT -- AND WE HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM OUR COUNCIL ANY RISK
THAT'S WHY WE WE PASS THIS IS
WAY SO WE'RE HOPING YOU GUYS CAN
GET CREATIVE AND TRY TO FIND A
WAY TO MAKE THIS WORK BECAUSE
OTHERWISE.
IT'S VERY HARD TO MAKE THAT THAT
SORT OF DEEPER COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT EQUITY PROMISE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE SO DIRECTOR
JEFF COMMISSURE -- SENATOR STERN --
BUT BEYOND JUST KIND OF THIS
THIS SPECIFIC PART OF MONEY I
WOULD SAY -- THAT THERE'S BEEN
THIS REAL RECOGNITION -- THAT
THE KEY ROLE THAT TRANSPORTATION
PLAYS IN IS VERY OR FAX US I
THINK THE STATE HAS TRIED TO
ADDRESS IT IN VARIOUS AREAS -- I
THINK THAT THERE'S BEEN OTHER
DEPARTMENTS OF HAD FUNDING AND
GRANTS PROGRAMS I THINK IN THE
IN THE COASTAL CONSERVANCY SAID
THERE'S BEEN KIND OF AN
EXPRESSION AND UNDERSTANDING --
THAT THIS IS AN AREA THAT WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON WE HAVE BEEN --
WE HAVE SOME PILOT PROJECTS AND
SOME OF OUR PARKS WE ARE WE HAVE
A PORTS PROGRAM AND IT'S A IT'S
A IN REAL TIME USING VIDEO
CONFERENCING TO REACH K. THROUGH
TWELVE CHILDREN.
AND WE'VE ACTUALLY IT'S A IT'S A
PRETTY ROBUST PROGRAM THAT WE'VE
HAD FOR PROBABLY NINE OR TEN
YEARS BUT WHAT ALWAYS
DISAPPOINTEDUS WHEN WE I THINK
COLLECTIVELY WE NEVER FELT GOOD
ABOUT.
IS IT ALLOWS FOR A LIVE
INTERACTION YOU MIGHT HAVE AN
INTERPRETER THERE IN A TIDAL
POOL TALKING ABOUT ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF ROLE THAT STARFISH
PLAY BUT THEN IT DOESN'T GET THE
CHILD ACTUALLY OUT INTO THE PARK
IN THE OUTDOORS.
SO WHAT WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO DO
IS TO ACTUALLY THEN GIVE A PARK
PASS -- BUT EVEN IF YOU GIVE A
PASS TO COME TO THE PARK
TRANSPORTATION ALSO BECOMES A
BARRIER -- WE'VE TRIED TO WORK
WITH THE K. THROUGH TWELVE
SCHOOLS EDUCATION TO SEE IF YOU
KNOW HOW WE CAN KIND OF PARTNER --
BUT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH --
PARTNERS -- ACROSS THE STATE'S
OUR OWN PARTNERS -- OFTENTIMES
FRANKLY I USE SENATOR MAGUIRE'S --
DISTRICT -- THE CINEMA AREA AS A
PRIME EXAMPLE.
THERE IS NO PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION THAT GOES ALONG
THE CALIFORNIA SIGN IN THAT AREA
AND YOU HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE
VERY MUCH A PART OF THAT
COMMUNITY THAT I'VE NEVER SEEN.
THE OCEAN WE WERE -- DOWN IN THE
COMMUNITY EVAN TURNER AND YOU GO
ONE MILE UP THE STREETS AND OUR
INTERPRETERS HAVE CONNECTED WITH --
KIDS IN IN ADULTS THAT HAVE
NEVER GONE TO THE OCEAN SO NOT
EVERYONE HAS SOMEONE IN THEIR
FAMILY OR IN THEIR FRIENDS THAT
THEY THAT THEY GREW UP WITH THAT
KIND OF INTRODUCE THEM TO THESE
PLACES SO -- SO WE ACTUALLY WE
GRANTED A WE HAD -- SOME FUNDS
THAT YOU PROVIDED US LAST YEAR --
TO DO SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE DONE SOME OF THOSE
PROGRAMS BUT WE ALSO ARE WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE NEW
NONPROFIT THAT WAS SET UP
THROUGH SENATE BILL.
ELEVEN ELEVEN AND IT'S CALLED
PARKS CALIFORNIA.
SB ELEVEN ELEVEN ALLOWED OUR
ORGANIZATION THE DEPARTMENT TO
GOING TO A VERY UNIQUE
RELATIONSHIP WITH A NON PROFIT --
IN BY UNIQUE IT MEANS THAT --
THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCE THE
DIRECTOR OF PARKS AND RECREATION
ACTS ARE EX OFFICIO MEMBERS ON
THAT BOARD -- WE ALSO
COLLABORATE AND DETERMINE -- A
PRIORITIZATION SETTING AND MUCH
OF WHAT THEY'RE FOCUSING ON IS
ON THIS VERY ISSUE AN ACCESS --
THE FIRST PROJECT OUT OF THE
GATE THAT THEY'RE FOCUSING IN ON
AS TRANSPORTATION I JUST DID A
CALL WITH THEM YESTERDAY
THINKING ABOUT -- HOW TO GO
ABOUT THAT -- WE ALSO EXPECT
THEM TO DO -- CAPITAL --
FUNDRAISING.
AS WE'RE SITTING HERE TODAY THEY
LITERALLY OUR STAFFING UP THEY
HAVE -- ONE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
AND SO SHE'S OUT RECRUITING --
BUT TRANSPORTATION IS GOING TO
BE A REALLY KEY FOCUS ALSO IN
THE PARKS AND REC COMMISSION
MEETINGS WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT
TRANSPORTATION.
AND THINK ABOUT HOW WE CAN KIND
OF PARTNER WITH COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE.
ANOTHER -- WHEN I WAS ON THE
CALL YESTERDAY I HIGHLIGHTED
THAT THE FRIENDS OF SANTA CRUZ
HAVE A REALLY INNOVATIVE PROGRAM --
AND OUT THERE WE HAVE A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THEM AND THEY
HAVE USED SOME OF THEIR FUNDING
AND SOMETIMES SOME OF OUR STAFF
TO ACTUALLY REACH A LOT OF THESE
K. THROUGH TWELVE COMMUNITIES --
SO I THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT
IS GETTING A LOT OF AND A
SERVICE WE'RE HOPEFUL ABOUT THE
BOND MEASURE BUT I WILL TELL YOU --
WHEN WE DID THE PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT MATT -- SESSIONS WE
WERE WE KNEW THAT THERE WAS KIND
OF YET AND DETERMINATION TO BE
MADE SO WE MADE IT CLEAR WITH
THE PUBLIC THAT THAT WAS STILL
PENDING BUT IT ALSO GAVE US A
SENSE TO STILL IDENTIFY THE
NEEDS OUT THERE.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE ARE
OPTIMISTIC THAT THIS IS NOT THE
PARK BOND MONEY IS NOT THE ONLY
PLACE THAT WE WOULD WITH THAT WE
WOULD EXPECT TO RESOURCES AND WE
NEED TO GET A BETTER HANDLE.
ON WHAT THE NEEDS ARE OUT IN THE
COMMUNITIES.
THE OTHER THING I WOULD SHARE IS
THAT I THINK YOU HEARD THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TALKING
ABOUT THERE'S GOING TO THESE
REAL TIME CONVERSATIONS GOING ON
IN THE FIRST THING THAT WE NEED
TO GET A HANDLE ON IS OKAY WELL
IF IT CAN'T FIND PROGRAMS.
WHAT CAN IT FUND SO FOR HALF
PERHAPS COULD YOU USE SOME OF
THOSE FUNDS TO PURCHASE A BUSES?
SO THOSE TYPES OF THINGS THOSE
TYPES OF CONVERSATIONS ARE BEING
HAN I JUST WANT YOU KNOW I THINK
WE'RE BEING REALLY THOUGHTFUL
ABOUT IT TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE
WORK AND BEST SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA -- IN BE
CONSISTENT WITH BOND FINANCING
LAW BUT THEN ALSO -- THAT THAT
SHOULD BE THE END ALL BE ALL
THAT IF WE'RE REALLY SERIOUS
ABOUT PARKS BEING FOR ALL THAT
TRANSPORTATION IS ABSOLUTELY
SOMETHING THAT AS A STATE WE
AFTER ADDRESS WE SHOULDN'T GIVE
UP ON THEM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
INSIGHT AND EIGHT I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE THE CREATIVITY
AND COBBLING -- YOU KNOW
LEVERAGING PRIVATE NONPROFIT
DOLLARS LOOKING AT THE COSTA
CONSERVANCY SIDE OF THINGS TRY
TO PUT A PACKAGE TOGETHER HERE
THAT'S GOING TO BE BOTH.
THIS PROP SIXTY EIGHT WHAT'S NOT
TO FORCE TODAY WHICH WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THAT WHETHER TTC
GRANTS ARE LOOKING AT ELP HAVE
FOR THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER WAYS
TO GET CREATIVE -- AND I I JUST
I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONTINUE.
THAT OPEN MINDED THINKING AND
AND YOU KNOW IT'S TOUGH WHEN WE
SAY PHYSICAL ACTIVITY PROGRAM
EXPLICITLY.
YOU KNOW WEN PEOPLE ARE VOTING
ON THIS AND YOU KNOW WE GO ROUND
SAY IT WE'VE BEEN DOING A
PROGRAM IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA --
WHERE WE'VE BEEN BOYS AND GIRLS
CLUBS FROM ALL OVER LA HAVE BEEN
HELPING KIDS GET TO THE BEACH
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN THEIR
ENTIRE LIVES AND IT IS SOMETHING
TO SEE SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN LIVING?
TEN FIFTEEN TWENTY MINUTES AWAY --
AND THE WALL THAT EXISTS FOR
THOSE COMMUNITIES AND THEN A
LOOK ON A KID'S FACE IT'S LIKE
THE THE THIS IS WHAT SURFING IS
THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING EL TIME
JUST BECAUSE YOU KNOW.
I GREW UP IN THIS NEIGHBORHOOD
OR LIKE  COME FROM THIS
BACKGROUND I CAN DO THIS TOO I
DON'T I THINK IT'S TRANSCEND AND
TREMENDOUSLY EXCITING SO WE WANT
TO HELP YOU.
PARTNER WITH YOU GUYS ON THAT --
AND I I THINK THERE'S MORE TO BE
DONE -- LAST THING I JUST ASK --
ON THIS SAID DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ISSUE.
OF MEN'S AS YOU'RE WORKING ON
YOUR PROJECT LIST PARTY'S ASIAN.
ARE YOU THINKING I MEAN I I HAVE
TO SHOUT OUT ARE YOUR AMAZING
REGIONAL DIRECTOR CRAIG SAT DOWN
IN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
THE THAT LAST FEW MONTHS WE'VE
BEEN THROUGH.
DOWN THERE I KNOW THIS IS TRUE
ON THE STATE BUT THOSE FIRES
TORE THROUGH A LOT A LOT OF
SACRED.
REALLY SPECIAL PLACES THAT THE
COMMUNITY THRIVES IN OUR SORT OF
THE BACKLOG OF GETTING
RESERVATIONS IS LIKE STALLED OUT.
FOR FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS
FURTHER BECAUSE YOU'RE YOU'RE
STILL.
HURTIN SO ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT
THAT AT ALL IN TERMS YOU
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE TREASURES
IS THAT.
NOT THE THE RIGHT BUCKET
NECESSARILY I THINK THE IT'S
PROBABLY JUST NOT THE RIGHT
BUCKETS SO WE'RE WORKING THROUGH
THE FEMALE EFFORT WITH CALLAWAY
YES -- AND YOU'RE RIGHT I MEAN
WE'VE SUFFERED -- SEVERAL FIRES
ITEM IT WAS A HISTORIC FIRE YEAR
FOR CALIFORNIA SO WE HAD THE CAR
FIRE IN READING -- WE HAD THE
CAMPFIRE THE CAMPFIRE THE IN THE
PORT ROLE THAT STATE PARKS PLAY
DOES REALLY LAST WE HAD LAST --
DAMAGE THEIR TORE LAKE ORVILLE --
STATE RECREATION AREA BUT WE ARE
SERVING MORE -- AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN TERMS OF HOUSING --
DISPLACED INDIVIDUAL SO WE HAVE
ONE OF OUR CAMP LIPS THAT WERE
UNDER CONTRACT WITH FEMA.
AND THEY'RE PUTTING IN FEMA
TRAILERS -- TO HOUSE DISPLACED
INDIVIDUALS WE ALSO -- RE INTO
A AN ARRANGEMENT WITH THE LOCAL
COUNTY -- TO THERE WAS ANOTHER
WAVE OF DISPLACED INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE THAT ARE BEING HOUSE
THERE WE FOUND THAT DURING THE
FIRES FRANKLY WE NOW THE FIRST
THING WE DO IS WE LOOK AT WHAT
PARKS EVEN IF A PARK IS ON A PER
IN A BURNT POTENTIAL BERNIE AREA.
BUT THAT WE HAVE FOUND THAT
PEOPLE TEND TO RUN TO THE PARK --
FOR THE FIRST PLACE OF SHELTER
AND RESPITE SO WE PLAYED A PART
IN ROLE IN THAT.
IN TERMS OF THE WILL THE FIRE WE
HAD MORE -- DISPLACED PARK --
STAFF LIKE INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYEES
HOUSING -- BUT WE HAD MORE PARK
DAMAGE AND SO AS YOU KNOW -- BUT
WE'VE GOT YOU KNOW MUD SLIDES
AND WATER SAID SOME THINGS THAT
WE'VE GOT TO THINK THROUGH.
THE WE'RE WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH CALLAWAY -- SO -- I
WOULDN'T EXPECT TO SEE THOSE
THINGS IN THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BUDGET BUCKET --
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE THOSE THINGS
ON A HIGHER PRIORITY LESTER
TRYING TO GET THOSE THINGS ARE
STORED AND BACK OPEN ACCESSIBLE
CENTER JONES.
SENATOR STERN READ MY NOTES
EARLIER SO THE QUESTION IS
PRETTY MUCH DRIVING ASPECT I DO
WANT TO JUST RAISE.
ON THE ACCESS -- AND THE 5% AND
I MET WITH A GREAT GROUP -- YOU
YOUNG FOLKS -- FROM MY DISTRICT
THAT ARE YOU KNOW ARE DOING
THEIR BEST TO GET IN THE PARKS
AND ONE OF THE EXAMPLES THEY
RAISED IS THAT THEY CAN USE THE
FUNDS TO BUY A VEHICLE BUT THEY
CAN'T USE THE FUNDS TO PUT GAS
IN THE VEHICLE.
SO -- THEN YOU KNOW I'M NOT EVEN
BE WORK SIR FAIRLY WELL AS
CENTER STERN SOUNDS LIKE RECESS
YOU KNOW SOMETHING WE NEED TO
WORK ON I GUESS THE REMAINING
QUESTION BE.
YOUR YOUR WORK ON THIS OF
THERE'S A LEGISLATIVE FIX.
WE CAN PROVIDE -- THROUGH THAT
YOU KNOW THE THE COMPLIES WITH
THE BOND MAJOR THAN MAYBE THAT'S
WHAT WE HAD A LOOK AT I'M
SENATOR I APPRECIATE THOSE --
THOSE COMMENTS IN THOSE THOUGHTS
I THINK THIS ISSUE ACTUALLY IS
MUCH BROADER THAN THE DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS AND RECREATION IT
APPLIES TO THE ENTIRE BONTA
MEASURE AND ALL OF THE
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE RECEIVING
THE ALLOCATION SO -- I DON'T
KNOW IF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WANTS TO ADD ANYTHING TO
THAT BUT I EXPECT THAT THIS WILL
BE A CONTINUING CONVERSATION AS
WE LEARN MORE.
BUT I THINK YOU'VE GOT TO KIND
OF THE FIRST THING WE NEED TO DO
IS MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
REALLY GOOD UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT THE FUNDS CAN BE USED.
FOR WHAT THEY CAN'T BE IS FOR
AND THEN WE NEED TO CHANNEL THAT
BACK OUT TO POTENTIAL APPLICANTS
AROUND THE STATE -- AN AD THAT --
YOUR THE ANALOGY THAT THE CAR
CERTAINLY WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
IT'S THE THE GAS THAT STILL.
THE ONGOING DISCUSSION.
AND THEN THERE WAS MENTION THE
FUEL OF THE MAINTENANCE OF THE
VEHICLE AND THEN ALSO.
YOU KNOW ACCESS TO THE ACTUAL
PARKS -- AND MISSION TO GET IN
AND THAT KIND OF THING WAS NOT
AVAILABLE SO.
OKAY THERE'S NO ACTUALLY NEED TO
BE TAKEN OUR STAFF WILL BE
TALKING WITH YOU ON THESE THIS
MATTER LET'S MOVE ON THE ISSUE
NUMBER.
SIXTEEN THIS IS ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORT STAFFING -- ONE POINT
SEVEN FOUR MILLION IN GENERAL
FUNDS AND ONE POINT SIX THREE
THREE MILLION ON GOING FOR
TWELVE POSITIONS THANK YOU
MISTER THIS IS FOR TWELVE
POSITIONS THESE WOULD BE
ADMINISTRATIVE -- POSITIONS TO
HELP US -- MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
MEETING ALL THE REQUIREMENTS AS
WE TRANSITION OVER TO THE
STATE'S NEW STATEWIDE --
BUDGETING AND ACCOUNTING SYSTEM
FISCALE WE INITIALLY -- STARTED
TO TRANSITION IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVENTEEN I THINK SOME OF
THE INITIAL WORK WHAT I THINK WE
ALWAYS EXPECTED THAT WE THERE
WOULD BE A ONE TIME SPIKE IN
WORKLOAD.
BUT AS WE'VE BEEN IMPLEMENTING --
WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE FISCAL DEPARTMENT ALSO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
IDENTIFY WHICH OF THAT WORKLOAD
WAS GOING TO BE ON GOING IN
NATURE.
WE ARE -- A RATHER IT.
ACCOUNTING WISE WE HAVE --
SPECIALIZED ACCOUNTING WORKLOADS
IF I CAN RUN DOWN A FEW THINGS
IN SOME CASES WE HAD SOME
ACTIVITIES THAT WE DID ANNUALLY
THAT NOW WE'RE HAVING TO DO
MONTHLY.
SO ALL OF THIS IS IN THE SPIRIT
OF HIGHER -- MEETING HIGHER
ACCOUNTING STANDARDS AND ALSO
MORE TRANSPARENCY BUT WE ALSO
ADMINISTER A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
APPROPRIATIONS FOR VARIOUS
CONSERVANCY'S BALDWIN HILLS SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER CONSERVANCY.
AND THE COACHELLA VALLEY --
MOUNTAINS -- WHEN WE FIRST WE
FIRST TACKLE IT IS A ONE TIME
ISSUE WE HIRE TEMPORARY STAFF --
WE ASKED OURADMINISTRATIVE
STAFF TO DO OVERTIME -- THEY
ROSE TO THE OCCASION WE PROBABLY
DID A OVER TEN THOUSAND HOURS OF
OVERTIME -- ACCOUNTING AND
BUDGETING OFFICES AND STATE
AGENCIES TYPICALLY UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
SEASONAL OVERTIME BUT WE FOUND
THAT THIS IS NOT SEASONAL.
SO IN THAT CASE WE NEEDED TO
LOOK FOR SOME ON GOING RESOURCES --
WE EXPECT THAT THIS WILL
INCREASE EFFICIENCY OVER TIME
BUT IT WILL ALSO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY -- BUT I THINK
WE'RE WE'RE FEELING PRETTY GOOD
AN OPTIMA STICK ABOUT IT IT'S
JUST A MATTER OF MAKING SURE
THAT WE GET SOME ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO PROVIDE THE ENHANCE
TRANSPARENCY IN THE OFFICE OF
FLAVOR OF THE EFFICIENCY
INCREASE BECAUSE FISCAL THE
PROMISE OF IT IS.
IT'S GOING NOWHERE YOU'RE ASKING
FOR ONE POINT.
SIX FOREVER AND EVER JUST STAY
TED TO HAVE.
I'LL BUY INTO THE TRANSPARENCY
BUT WE'RE WHEN DO WE REALIZE THE
EFFICIENCY WHAT WHAT AND WHAT
THAT MIGHT THAT LOOK LIKE IN THE
PARKS AND RECREATION.
DOMAIN.
SURE UP THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
MONIES WILL SHOPS ON THE DAVID
DIRECTOR FOR ADMINISTRATION FOR
STATE PARKS.
SO I THINK THE FIRST THING WE
HAVE TO REALIZE OFFICE BECAUSE
IT IS A DIFFERENT ACCOUNTING
SYSTEM AND CAL STARS IT IS MUCH
MORE ROBUST IT PROVIDES.
ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY THAT WAS
NEVER THERE A CAL STARS AND IT
MIMICS MUCH MORE MODERN
ACCOUNTING SYSTEM THEN OUR
LEGACY SYSTEM CAL STARS.
SAYING THAT THERE WILL BE
EFFICIENCIES TO BE GAINED --
THROUGH FISCAL I THINK.
THE BIGGEST IMPACT OF FISCAL
WILL BE -- TRANSITION WAY FROM
DONE WITH CAL STAR INTO MORE OF
A AN AUTOMATED PAPER FLOW OR
AUTOMATED WORKFLOW WITH FISCAL
AN EXAMPLE OF THAT WOULD JUST BE.
PROCESSING INVOICES THROUGH THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE IN
THE PAST WE'VE HAD TO SEND OVER.
REAMS OF PAPER TO SCO THOSE
WOULD BE AUTOMATED IN FUTURE --
I THINK AS THE STATE ACCLIMATE
ITSELF MORE TO THE NEW SYSTEM --
BUSINESS PROCESSES -- EVOLVE.
THOSE THINGS WILL BECOME MORE --
TO APPARENT -- TO THE DEPARTMENT
BUT FOR NOW IT'S A LITTLE.
WE'RE IN A TRANSITIONAL STATE SO
THINGS HAVEN'T BEEN QUITE AS
EFFICIENT AS THEY WILL BE
ULTIMATELY WITH THIS GIRL I
THINK ALSO WHAT I MIGHT ADD IN
TERMS OF FISSION SAYING.
IS THAT I THINK WHEN WHEN -- IN
TERMS OF THE PROJECT IF IT'S A
STATEWIDE PROJECT AND IT ALSO
CHANGES THE INTERACTIONS BETWEEN
OTHER GOVERNMENTAL CONTROL
AGENCIES SO THERE ARE OTHER
EFFICIENCIES THAT WERE NOT
NECESSARILY POSITION TO SPEAK.
TO THAT ARE KIND OF OUTSIDE OF
JUST THE DEPARTMENT.
HELLO I HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD ON
THIS.
WE WE DIDN'T RAISE ANY CONCERNS
AT THIS PROPOSAL AND LOOKING AT
THE OVERTIME HOURS THAT AND THE
ACCOUNTING STAFF HAS BEEN
OCCURRING OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS AS WELL AS THE ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD TO MEET THE HIGHER
ACCOUNTING STANDARDS OF THE
PROPOSAL.
GENERALLY SEEM REASONABLE BUT
GOOD OVERSIGHT QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE LONG TERM NATURE OF WHEN
WHEN THOSE EFFICIENCIES WILL
ACTUALLY MANIFEST OKAY.
I WOULD HAVE A PUBLIC HEARING ON
THIS WHEN I FINISH ALTHOUGH HOLD
UP THE MATTERS MEMBERS WERE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO HOLD THIS
MATTER OPEN.
AND WITH THAT A MOVE ON TO THE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN HERITAGE
CENTER STAFFING THIS IS ISSUE
NUMBER. SEVENTEEN FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THREE POSITIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LAST YEAR
YOU MAY RECALL THAT WE CAME
BEFORE YOU AND TALKED ABOUT -- A
PROPOSAL WHICH THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED FOR A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR NEW
CALIFORNIA INDIAN HERITAGE
CULTURAL CENTRE.
THE INTENTION IS THAT IT WILL
REPLACE THE CURRENT INDIAN
MUSEUM WHICH IS CO LOCATE LOCATE
CO LOCATED WITH OTHER SUPPORT
HERE I SACRAMENTO -- BUT THE
FIRST THING THAT WE NEED TO DO
IS ACQUIRED THE PROPERTY IN WEST
SACRAMENTO THIS WAS A SITE THAT
WAS SELECTED BY A TASK FORCE OF
THAT FROM THE TRIBAL COMMUNITY.
THEY CHOSE THIS LOCATION BECAUSE
IT WAS -- HAD CULTURAL -- AND
SACRED SIGNIFICANCE TO THEM IT
WAS AT THE CONFLUENCE OF THE TWO
RIVERS SO IT WAS THEIR FIRST
PARTY SITE SELECTION SO SINCE WE
WERE LAST BEFORE YOU -- WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE CITY OF
WEST SACRAMENTO TO FINALIZE THAT
SO WE EXPECT THAT LAND TRANSFER
WAS SO WE WERE SUCCESSFUL NOT.
AND WE EXPECT THE LAND TRANSFER
TO OCCUR SOMETIME OVER THE
SUMMER SO PROGRESS IS BEING MADE --
ALSO THAT THE WE ALSO SHARED
WITH YOU AT THAT TIME THAT IT
WAS THE STATE'S INTENTION TO
WORK WITH THE TRIBAL COMMUNITY.
TO SEE IF WE COULD SECURE SOME
PHILANTHROPIC SUPPORT SO THAT
ONE HUNDRED MILLION BECAME A
NUMBER FOUR MARK MARTIN NORTH OF
ONE HUNDRED MILLION -- SO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE CURRENTLY
HAPPENING THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
BEING REQUESTED HERE ARE
RESOURCES THAT WERE IDENTIFIED
IN THE PROPOSAL LAST YEAR BUT
OUR FIRST HOPE WAS TO BE ABLE TO
GO AND SEE IF WE COULD WORK OUT
SOME SORT OF AGREEMENT WITH CITY
OF A SACRAMENTO -- THAT DID NOT
MATERIALIZE SO WE'RE HERE ASKING
FOR THESE RESOURCES I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE PATROL.
I'D AT IT I DON'T THE THE MONEY
FOR PATROLLING THE PROPERTY WE
HAVEN'T EVEN BUILT.
WHAT IT IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BUILD HOW WHY WOULD WE NEED?
A OPPOSITION OR OR MAINTAINING.
ITS.
SACRED LAND I'LL BUT I'LL GET
THAT I GET THAT BUT IT'S BEEN
THERE FOR HUNDREDS OF YEARS JUST
BECAUSE THE PARK DISTRICT
REQUIRES IT WHY ARE WE PAYING
FOR PATROLLING.
AND MAINTAINING WHATEVER THAT
MAY BE I GET THE DEVELOPMENT I
SEE THAT WE HAVE.
THAT WOULD BE CONSTRUCTION THIS
IS MONEY THAT GOES ON FOREVER
AND EVER.
THIS -- AT THIS LOCATION IS
ACTUALLY IN THE MIDDLE OF WEST
SACRAMENTO IN NEIGHBORHOOD IT'S
NOT A VERY REMOTE LOCATION -- SO
KIND OF IN THE SPIRIT OF BEING
GOOD NEIGHBORS THIS PARTICULAR
PARCEL OF LAND IN THE PAST HAS
HAD SOME ISSUES IN TERMS OF
HAVING AN HOMELESS POPULATION
THERE.
SO THE CITY OF LOS SACRAMENTO
HAS DONE A LOT OF WORK TO TRY TO
RESTORE THAT TO A PLACE WHERE
LOCAL INDIVIDUALS CAN USE IT FOR
HIKING AND FISHING.
SO THEIR HOPE IS THAT WHEN IT
TRANSFERS OVER TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IS THAT IT IS STILL LEFT IN A
MANNER THAT SAY FOR PEOPLE TO GO
AND EXPERIENCE THAT -- AND TO
FINISH AND TO WALK AND JUST
ENJOY THAT'S THAT OPEN SPACE SO
THAT WAS PART OF THE COMMITMENT
OF THIS.
WOULDN'T THAT BE PART OF YOU
HAVE A CONSTRUCTION BUDGET THERE
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO BUILD
SOMETHING IT'S NOT JUST.
NOTHING THERE WHEN THAT HAPPENS
THERE'S GOING TO BE NORMAL
FENCING I PRESUME AND AND THINGS
LIKE THAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WE'RE GOOD AT
WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW BEFORE WE
START CONSTRUCTION.
WELL WE'RE STARTING OUR OUR
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT PROCESS OR A
KIND OF WORKING WITH THE TRIBAL
COMMITTEE TO DESIGN THE
COMMUNITY TO DESIGN WHAT EXACTLY
THIS FACILITY IS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE.
AND SO EVEN THOUGH -- THE SHOVEL
IS NOT HITTING DIRT AND
CONSTRUCTION ISN'T HAPPENING
JUST YET WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE PROPERTY DOESN'T LOOK
FORGOTTEN WE ALSO HAVE AN
ADJACENT PROPERTY THAT'S PART OF
THAT'S ALREADY STATE PARKS
PROPERTY THAT WE HAVE A
GARDENING.
ON PROJECT WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY SO THAT'S THE
INTENTION AND SO WE WANTED TO
RANT THAT -- PARTICULAR EFFORT
UP AND I DON'T KNOW IF -- DEPUTY
DIRECTOR BRIAN DO HAS ANYTHING
TO ADD OR MAYBE NOT.
YEAH I WOULD JUST BRING TO A
STATE PARKS AS AD THAT YOU KNOW
BY ACQUIRING THIS PROPERTY WOULD
COME OF POPULAR AND WE HAVE
OBLIGATIONS TO MAINTAIN THE
PROPERTY.
WHEN THIS WAS BROUGHT BEFORE THE
STATE PUBLIC WORKS BOARD LAST
DECEMBER?
WE IDENTIFIED THE ONGOING COSTS
OF MANAGING JUST THE PROPERTY
LOAN.
BECAUSE THE B. C. P. THAT WAS --
OR THE PROPOSAL THAT WAS THAT
WAS FUNDED LAST YEAR THE OTHER
MILLION -- FOR DEVELOPMENT WE
IDENTIFIED THE ONGOING COST FOR
THE FULL BUILD OUT OF OF THE OF
THE CENTER RECOGNIZING THAT THE
THE INITIAL COST WOULD BE A
FRACTION A PORTION OF THAT.
JUST JUST TO MANAGE THE PROPERTY
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC SAFETY AND TO
BE A GOOD LANDOWNER.
HOW A. L. HELP ME?
I'M IT JUST COMPUTERS OF THE
ANALYST'S OFFICE SUITE SO WE
DIDN'T RAISE ANY ISSUES OF THIS
PROPOSAL AND I WILL LET THE
DEPARTMENT I'M.
SPEAK TO AND JUSTIFY THEIR OWN
PROPOSAL BUT JUST WHEN WE LOOKED
AT IT DIDN'T REALLY RAISE
CONCERNS FOR AS THERE HAVE BEEN
EITHER AND PROJECTS WHERE THE
STATE HAS ACQUIRED RIGHT OF WAY
AND IS NOT STARTED CONSTRUCTION
YET AND THE GAME MEET LIKE HIGH
SPEED RAIL I THINK WE'VE.
DONE THIS I'M WORRIED HAD TO PAY
FOR SECURITY COSTS SO ONCE THE
STATE DOES OWN THE LAND IT DOES
BECOME THE STATE'S
RESPONSIBILITY AND SO IT'S NOT
AND REASONABLE THAT.
I'M WE WOULD HAVE SOME TIME
COSTS TO TO MAINTAIN THE
PROPERTY OR TO SECURE THE
PROPERTY.
AND THERE COULD BE HIGHER COSTS
IN THE FUTURE IF THERE'S BLADE
OR LITTERING OR OTHER ISSUES
THAT ARE HAPPENING ON THE
PROPERTY IT POTENTIAL FOR FIRES
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT.
I AM YOU MIGHT WANT TO IT JUST
YOU KNOW ENSURE THAT THE
PROPERTY IS IS MAINTAINED AND
BEING A BEING A GOOD NEIGHBOR IS
THAT AS THEM.
THE DIRECTOR HAS INDICATED SO WE
DIDN'T RAISE ANY FACTS FOR US
FOR THAT REASON DIDN'T SEEM
INCONSISTENT WITH HOW WE HANDLED
OTHER PROPERTIES WERE REQUIRED --
A PERSONAL OUR RIGHT OF WAY AND
AND HAVING STARTED CONSTRUCTION.
FULLY BUILT OUT.
I'M WITH EVERYBODY YOU GOT TO
MUSEUM YOU GOT THE PLAZA YOU GOT
WHATEVER YOU GOT THERE YOU GOT
SOME PATROL GUY GOING ON HE GOT
WHATEVER MAINTENANCE I DON'T
KNOW WHAT WERE MADE IN THE
MAINTAINING.
IF WE'RE GOING.
TO GET THE BULLDOZERS IN THERE
ARE MAKE MUSEUM ON IT I MEAN I I
DON'T NORMALLY.
AT LEAST MY EXPERIENCE IN LIFE
IS THAT I DON'T HAVE THAT IN IF
I DON'T KNOW WHERE THE PLAZA IS
A GOOD TO BE BECAUSE I DON'T
KNOW WHERE YOU'RE.
PUTTING THINGS IN AND HOW IT
COULD BE LAID OUT AND WHAT'S THE
SACRED SITES FROM THE NON SACRED
SITES.
JUST.
LEAVE IT.
BUT LET'S SEE FREE MY THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PROVE HIS
BUDGET.
LET'S OPEN THE PUBLIC HEARING IS
THERE ANYBODY HERE ON THE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN HERITAGE
CENTER STAFFING.
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING
[inaudible]
THE WOMAN.
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE DIRECTOR.
I'LL JUST SAY AS A PART TIME
RESIDENT OF WEST SACRAMENTO.
ALL RIGHT THE CHAIR WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
I'VE EXPRESSED MY ANGST.
SOME OF I AM.
GOOD TO KEEP AN EYE ON THIS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I CASKEY I JONES [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
MONNING I STERN.
ALL RIGHT THAT MADISON HAS FIVE
VOTES TO PROVE.
CALIFORNIA MUSEUM THIS IS A
MILLION DOLLARS I'M GOING. TO
SUPPORT THE MUSEUM'S MISSION AND
ENGAGE AND EDUCATE THE PUBLIC.
THE FOR THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION MERELY SERVES AS A
PASS THROUGH WHERE THIS FUNDS
ARE PREPARADA CENTER PASSED ON
TO THE CALIFORNIA MUSEUM.
ON THE CALIFORNIA MUSEUM IS
LOCATED HERE IN SACRAMENTO THE
INTENTION OF THE CALIFORNIA
MUSEUM WAS TO SHOWCASE.
MUCH OF THE COLLECTIONS AND THE
CONTENTS OF THE STATE ARCHIVES --
AND SHARING THAT WITH THE PUBLIC
ON THE DEPARTMENT PARKS AND
RECREATION WE ALSO PARTNER WITH
THEM BECAUSE WE HAVE -- UNDER
OUR STEWARDSHIP A WAREHOUSE FULL
OF VARIOUS COLLECTIONS SO WE'VE
PARTNERED WITH THEM TO SERVE AS
A MEANS OF PUTTING OUR
COLLECTIONS OUT FOR THE PUBLIC
TO EXPERIENCE THEM.
THIS PARTICULAR -- THE FUNDING
REQUEST WOULD GO TO CELEBRATE
THE ONE HUNDRED YEARS OF THE
WOMEN'S SUFFRAGE SERVER JUST
MOVEMENTS AND THE INTENTION IS
THAT IT WOULD FUND A CENTENNIAL
EXHIBIT WHICH WOULD BE -- UNIT.
THE FOR ABOUT A SIX MONTH PERIOD
AND THAT THERE WOULD THEN BE AN
ON GOING PERMANENT EXHIBIT
SHOWCASING THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH THAT INCLUDE THE PROVISION
THAT THAT EXHIBIT WOULD BE ABLE
TO GO ON THE ROAD AND BE.
SHARED WITH OTHER MUSEUMS
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES ON
THE THE CONTRIBUTION SETTLEMENT
MADE BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT.
MUSEUMS MAKE THEIR MONEY BY
PUTTING TOGETHER THE EXHIBIT AND
TAKING IT ON THE ROAD.
IN A MISTER CHAIR I WOULD HAVE
TO FOLLOW BUT THE CALIFORNIA
MUSEUM AND AND GET BACK TO IT
BECAUSE THE EXPERTISE THAT WE
HAVE AT THE CALIFORNIA MUSEUM IS
KNOWING WHERE ALL THE PIECES ARE
LAID.
PUTTING IT TOGETHER IN THE FANCY
SPAN SHE WAY AND AND ALSO WITH
THE VIDEO WHATEVER PEOPLE WANT
TO DO AND THEN YOU SAY.
SMITHSONIAN YOU GET IT.
NEW MEXICO YOU GET IT NEW YORK
YOU GET IT IN YOU A GOES OUT FOR
SIX MONTHS OR SO SOME MONTHS
THAT WE GET THAT RETURN.
FIRST WE SHARE WHATEVER WHATEVER
THE DELAYS BUT PEOPLE ARE
INTERESTED IN THAT NOT JUST IN
THE UNITED STATES BUT THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD OF WHAT THESE EXHIBITS
ARE THAT THEY LEARN ABOUT.
THAT THAT ROLE SO I KNOW FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MUSEUM I COULD SAY
THAT THEY ARE REALLY LEANING AND
TRYING TO USE MORE MODERN
TECHNOLOGY SO A MINIMUM THROUGH
SOCIAL MEDIA.
DIGITIZING I MEAN THAT'S FOR ALL
OF US THAT OUR STEWARDS OF VAST
COLLECTIONS -- OF IMPORTANT
PIECES AND ARTIFACTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DIGITIZATION
AND MAKING SURE THAT MORE PEOPLE
CAN EXPERIENCE THESE THESE THESE
THINGS AND ALSO INTERACT AND
MAYBE WE CAN COLLECIVELY LEARN
MORE.
ABOUT ANY OF THE ARCTIC CAT
FACTS AND COLLECT MORE --
STORIES I KNOW THAT THAT
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY MUCH BEEN
THAT THEY'VE BEEN INTERESTING AT
INTERESTED IN WE AT THE
DEPARTMENT PARKS AND RECREATION
HAVE PARTNERED WITH THE
SMITHSONIAN MUSEUM -- AND MY
SENSE IS PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
MUSEUM DOES TO THERE'S THIS
TIGHT KNIT COMMUNITY OF OF
MUSEUMS AND COLLECTIONS FOLKS
AND STEWART'S IN THAT AREA.
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF THEIR INTENT
IS TO ACTUALLY KIND OF TAKING IT
ON THE ROAD BUT THEY DEFINITELY
WANT TO CELEBRATE AND SHOWCASE
AN AMPLIFIER PEOPLE IN THE WORLD
OF MUSEUMS PEOPLE PAY. TO HAVE
THE EXHIBIT COME FROM SACRAMENTO.
DISCONNECT THE STATE OR WHEREVER.
THIS IS A HOLDOVER MATTER ALLEY --
YOU HAVE COMMENT.
QUESTIONS ON THIS.
THE THING THAT'S A A MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR OR THIS IS JUST A
ONE TIME ASK OF A MILLION
DOLLARS I KNOWING THIS WOULD BE
ON GOING EACH YEAR NO NO.
AND MY QUESTON [inaudible]
OKAY -- PHONE [inaudible]
URGENCY.
YES THIS IS A REPLACEMENT OF OUR
EMERGENCY FLEET -- SPECIFICALLY
THIS WOULD BE -- WATER.
VERY SPECIALIZED WATER VESSEL
RESCUE EQUIPMENT WE DO OVER A
THOUSAND RESCUES DOWN IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ALONE A YEAR.
ON THESE ARE VERY SPECIALIZED
VESSELS THEY HAVE TO MOTOR SO
THAT THEY CAN TURN AROUND THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY DEGREE TURNS ON
THEY ALSO VERY DEEP HOLES SO
THEY CAN THEY CAN GO INTO
TREACHEROUS WATERS THAT --
PREVENTED FROM CAPSIZING --
THESE VESSELS ARE AS OLD AS I
THINK DIRECT THIRTY YEARS OLD
THEY GO BACK TO THE THE EIGHTIES
IT ALSO REPLACES A FIXED WING
AIRCRAFT IN ANZA BORREGO.
STATE PARK -- WE'RE VERY MUCH
TIED IN TO THE LOCAL OVER PART
OF THE LOCAL SAFETY NETWORK --
THE STATE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES RESPONSE PLAN THIS ALSO
PUT N A NEW FIRE FIGHTING
APPARATUS ESSENTIALLY FIRE
ENGINE -- THERE TO PROTECT
HEARST CASTLE THIS WAS BORN A
LOT OUT OF KIND OF REALLY TAKING
A LOOK AT KIND OF DISASTERS IN
OUR PREPAREDNESS -- TO REALLY
<c.yellow>IND OF LANE AND AND AND BE</c>
RESPONSIVE IN THOSE TIMES.
HI ELLIE -- THIS IS THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION OVER TWO YEARS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR --
THROUGH YOUR LEADERSHIP BUT WILL
OBVIOUSLY BE SUPPORTIVE -- IF
THAT IS YOUR RECOMMENDATION
THERE IS ONE ITEM THAT CAME UP
AS WE KNOW -- JUST OVER THE LAST
COUPLE MONTHS VERY SMALL -- ITEM
THAT I KNOW THERE'S GONNA NEED
TO BE SOME CONTINUE DISCUSSION
ON ANGEL ISLAND THERE IS NO
EMERGENCY RATE ON ANGEL ISLAND A
VERY UNIQUE CASE.
I WITHIN THE STATE PARK SYSTEM
THE ONLY ISLAND WHERE YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE TO FERRY OUT TO
BREAK CITING CONTRACT ON THAT AS
WELL.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT THAT AS THE
AND STATE PARK STRICTER ME BUT
OPINION OR AYE -- BUT WHAT I
WILL SAY IS THAT -- IT WOULD
PROBABLY BE ABOUT A TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR EXPENSE TO BE
OUTFIT.
AN OLD BREAK AN OLD AMBULANCE I
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS A
CAPABILITY OF TRANSPORTING A
PATIENT MAY GET INJURED ON THE
ISLAND. TO A FIRE BOAT THAT'S AN
ITEM THAT WE'RE NEED TO BE A
CONTINUOUS THIS -- JUST CAME UP.
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS
IN A LEAN ISSUE THAT I KNOW WILL
HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ABOUT AS
WELL YOU CAN TEAM CONVERSATION
WITH I STATE PARKS.
MR CHERRY -- I GUESS I WOULD
THINK CENTER MCGUIRE THROUGH HIS
LEADERSHIP HE CONNECTED US WITH
THE LOCAL TIBURON FIRE THOR TEAS.
AND ONCE AGAIN MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE BEING A GOOD NEIGHBOR BUT
WE'RE HAPPY TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION WITH YOU.
PERHAPS AND I'M NOT ME -- THIS
IS NOT MY JOB.
HE YOU HAVE THREE VEHICLES THREE
VESSELS ONE OF THEM'S TWENTY ONE
YEARS OLD.
THERE ARE NO LONGER -- USABLE
SERVICEABLE IS IT.
I DON'T KNOW A LOT ABOUT VESSELS
RIGHT BUT I ASSUME THAT THEY'RE
LIKE CARS LIKE IF SOMEBODY
WANTED TO PUT MONEY INTO IT YOU
COULD.
MAKE IT SERVICEABLE OR ITS GONE
GONE GONE.
THANK CHAIRMAN BRIAN KAREM THE
OPERATIONS G. FOR COASTAL VISION --
THESE VESSELS THAT WERE SPEAKING
OF OUR FIBER LASSEN WOULDN'T
HOLD.
AND SO WE PUT ABOUT AS MUCH
MONEY AS WE CAN'T INTO THESE --
BEFORE THE WOOD IS ACTUALLY
RIDING AND FALLING APART.
AND SO THEY THEY HAVE A LIFESPAN
AND AND WE'VE COME TO ESPECIALLY
THE OLDEST ONE THAT IT'S JUST
NOT GOING TO BE SERVICEABLE.
AND IT IS JUST LIKE A CAR -- THE
LONGER YOU SIT THERE AND AND OWN
IT THE MORE MONEY YOU'RE GOING
TO SINK INTO IT.
I'VE HAD A COUPLE THOSE LET'S
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING THIS
IS -- REPLACEMENT OF EMERGENCY
FLEET THE TWO YEAR -- ASK FOR
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION CLOSE
PUBLIC HEARING.
THERE'S A MOTION BY CENTER
MORNING PLEASE CALL.
THE ROLE FOR ES BUT PROVE
BUDGETED.
CASKEY HI JONES THE CHOIR.
MORNING.
STERN.
OKAY THAT'S MATTER HAS FIVE
VOTES LET'S.
OUR FINAL MATTER TODAY ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY USES.
NUMEROUS CAPITAL OUT LIES.
OUT LINKS AT TOTALING.
NINETEEN POINT -- SIXTEEN
MILLION.
YES THIS IS ON ISSUE TWENTY
THESE ARE VARIOUS COUPLE OUTLAY
PROJECTS -- I THINK THE ONLY
THING I CALLED YOUR ATTENTION IS
FOURTEEN THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THESE ARE ON GOING -- TWO OF
THEM ARE NEW AND WE'RE HAPPY
DISCUSS.
AT YOUR PLEASURE.
I JUST HAD A GENERAL QUESTION ON
WHEN I GO I GET CRAZY OVER
PRELIMINARY PLANS AND WORKING
DRAWINGS.
AND I ASSUME THAT IN THE WORLD
THE PARKS.
IT'S THE SAME PEOPLE WITH THE
SAME ENGINEERS IS THE SAME.
ARCHITECTS THAT THEY KNOW YOU
KNOW I MEAN I DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT A TRAIL TO
RESTORE THE TRAIL BUT SOME OF
THEM.
SOME OF THE PEOPLE THAT DO THIS
WORK.
I WAS THE CLICHE WE DON'T WANT
TO REINVENT THE WHEEL AND I
GUESS I GUESS I'M WONDERING --
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT GOES
INTO THE PRELIMINARY PLANS.
FOR AND LET'S TAKE WITH.
FORT ROSS SEEMS LIKE FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS ON A GLOOMY
PRANCE MEAN I'VE BEEN THE FORT
ROSS THAT'S A LOT.
AND IT'S TAKING.
CAP.
CABINS DOWN AND AND THE
INTERPRETIVE CENTER ALSO THE
STAR SO IT'S OF ARMY BASER THIS
WAS AN ARMY BASE RIGHT.
THURMOND PARTICULAR IN FORT ROSS
I WOULD SAY THAT THAT IS ONE OF
THE MORE COMPLICATED PROJECTS
THAT.
TACKLE TACKLE AND IT'S YOU KNOW
IF I COULD TRANSPORT YOU THERE I
WOULD STAND YOU KIND OF ALONG
THE CALIFORNIA COASTLINE.
THIS IS ONE OF THE MORE REMOTE
PLACES IN CALIFORNIA THAT
PARTICULAR PARK IN THIS AREA
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HAS
VERY LIMITED UTILITIES VERY
MINIMAL CELL SERVICE -- WILL BE
WORKING THROUGH WITH -- VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION THERE'S ALSO
SOME VERY -- VERY SPECIAL OF
CULTURAL ARTIFACTS THERE'S A
WILL BE ALSO WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH -- THE LOCAL CACHE
AYE APAMA TRIBAL CONSULTED
COUNTS CONSULTANTS -- BUT ALSO
THE WEATHER IS SOMEWHAT
CHALLENGING SO -- THERE ARE
CERTAIN TIMES OF THE YEAR THAT
WE CAN DO SOME THINGS -- SO SO I
GUESS RUSSIAN SHOULDN'T HAVE ANY
PROBLEMS WITH IT WHAT'S KIND OF
INTERESTING ABOUT OUR PROJECTS
IS THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THESE
PROJECTS AND YOU LOOK AT KIND OF
THE COMPLICATED NATURE OF THE
FORT ROSS AREA.
AND THEN MAYBE YOU TAKE ONE OF
THESE OTHER PROJECTS -- THAT
MAYBE IS OUT AND HUNGRY VALLEY
RIGHT SO YOU'RE OUT IN THE MORE --
TRY AREA AND THE CHALLENGES
MIGHT BE VERY DIFFERENT TO IT
END -- A DEPUTY DIRECTOR THAT DO
WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO ADD MORE
YEAH -- I COULD SPEAK JUST AND
ALSO JUST GENERALLY ABOUT THE
PLUMBING PLANS VERSUS WORKING
DRAWINGS.
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE BOTH
SPECIFIED IN.
THE BUDGET ACT WHAT'S INCLUDED
MY PLANS FOR CAN TRANSMIT
GENERALLY PLAY PLANS IS ABOUT
HALFWAY THROUGH DESIGN.
IT'S ENOUGH TO IDENTIFY THE
LOCATION SIZE CONFIGURATION
PURPOSE OF VARIOUS BUILDINGS.
IT'S IT'S BEFORE -- AND AND THEN
YOU MOVE IN THE WORKING DRAWINGS
IS THE IS THE IT WAS THE
CONSTRUCTION DOCUMENTS THAT YOU
WOULD HAVE THE CONTRACTOR.
HAS MUCH MORE DETAIL THAT WOULD
THEN BUILD WHATEVER YOUR YOU DID
YOU DESIGN.
BUT GOING BACK TO PLUMBING PLANS
IT INCLUDES MUCH MORE THAN JUST
THE DESIGN BECAUSE BEFORE YOU
DESIGN A ABOUT.
A PROJECT YOU NEED TO KNOW MORE
ABOUT YOUR YOUR YOUR SITE.
WE NEED TO DO -- THAT WE WILL
SEE DUE DILIGENCE UNDERSTAND
MAKE PROPERTY OWNERSHIP.
THESE ARE THE BEST OF MY POINT
IS IS THAT THIS IS YOU GOT YOUR
COLUSA SACRAMENTO RIVER BOAT
LAUNCH I MEAN I WOULD THAT WANT
TO BE SIMPLISTIC HERE BUT A BOAT
LAUNCHES BOTH MUCH.
YOU'VE HAD A BOAT LAUNCH THERE
FOR FORTY YEARS YOU'VE HAD
ENGINEERS AND AND PEOPLE THAT
WORK ON THAT IT'S NOT LIKE.
I'M GOING UP TO COLUSA FOR THE
FIRST TIME AND SAYING ALL WHAT
WE HAVE HERE THEY YOU EAT IT'S
OUR PARK RIGHT IT'S OUR PARK
IT'S REPLACING WHAT'S GOING ON
AND YOU KNOW THERE MUST BE.
THERE'S THE NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE VERSION OF OPPOSE BOTH
WATCH AND THEN THERE'S A TWENTY
NINETEEN VERSION OF A VOTE WATCH
RIGHT MEAN WE HAVE BOTH LAUNCHES
ALL OVER THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
RIGHT I MEAN THAT'S TO GET INTO
I DON'T WANNA BE TOO SIMPLISTIC
BUT THAT'S SORT OF THIS IS WHAT
YOUR BUSINESSES IN THE PARK
BUSINESS YOU'RE DOING BOTH
LAUNCHES ALL OVER LAKE SEN AND
IF IT'S A NEW ONE THAT'S ONE
THING.
IF IT'S A REPLACEMENT.
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I WANTED TO
GET [inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
YES I TO SPEAK OF A SPECIFIC
ABOUT YOUR YOUR EXAMPLE -- THE
PROJECT FOR AT COLUSA IS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BOAT RAMP
THE THE CITY'S BUILDING THE BOAT
RAMP AND THESE ARE THE
FACILITIES THAT SERVE.
THE BOAT RAMP -- NAMELY THE THE
CAMPING FACILITIES AND WE'RE
WE'RE RELOCATING THE THE PARKING
AND THE CAMPAIGN AND THE AND THE
ROADS AND SUCH.
AS WAS PART OF THE DESIGN YOU
YOU YOU HAVE TO DO GEOTECHNICAL
STUDY STUDIES AND YOU UNDERSTAND
YOUR SITE.
AT TO INFORM THE DESIGNERS ON
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO SIGN.
IT IS ALSO SEQUEL -- PERMITTING
ALL THOSE TYPES OF THINGS THAT
ARE INCLUDED IN THAT REALLY FACE
[inaudble]
THE SEC CENTER JONES IS ONE OF
THE STATE -- RECOGNIZED AS A
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO
THE S. V. R. A.'S.
IN THE I'M IN MY CURRENT SERVICE
IN THE ASSEMBLY -- WE WENT
THROUGH SOME STRUGGLES TRYING TO
GET THOSE -- PROPERLY MAINTAINED
AND AND TAKING CARE OF SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT
[inaudible]
TO OKAY.
THEN THE WEATHER QUESTIONS THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO HOLD THIS
MATTER OPEN I WILL NOW.
OPEN THE PUBLIC HEARING ON ALL
THE OPEN MATTERS WITH THE PARKS
RECREATION THIS WILL BE.
GOING BACK TO ISSUE NUMBER
SIXTEEN ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT
STAFF.
THE CALIFORNIA MUSEUM ISSUE
NUMBER.
EIGHTEEN ISSUE NUMBER -- TWENTY
VARIOUS CAPITAL OUTLAYS.
PLEASE COME FORTH.
SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN TWENTY HI HI MY
NAME IS HOLLY MARTINEZ OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION I'M HERE TO SHOW OUR
SUPPORT OF THE PER.
KILLER AND THINK AS SENATOR
STERN FOR HIS COMMENTS ON
COMMUNITY ACCESS AS IT RELATES
TO THAT ISSUE -- AS AS AN
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION AND WE
TRULY BELIEVE THAT.
ALL CALIFORNIANS SHOULD BE ABLE
TO ENJOY OUR STATE PARKS AND WE
KNOW IT'SNOT JUST A MATTER OF
GETTING THEM THERE BUT THAT
THEIR EXPERIENCES ARE MEANINGFUL
AND ENGAGING.
MANY OF THE PROJECTS IN THIS
PROPOSAL WHETHER IT'S THROUGHOUT
CAPITAL OUTLAY AND OTHERS ARE
NOT ONLY HELPING.
TO PREPARE THE STATE PARKS FOR
VISITORS BUT IT'S ALSO THINKING
ABOUT MEANINGFULWAYS TO ENGAGE
THEM FOR EXAMPLE EDUCATIONAL
ACTIVITIES HAPPENING AT FORT
ROSS.
I IS REALLY IMPORTANCE TO NOT
ONLY TELL THE HISTORY OF THE
LAND BUT ALSO TO HAVE STUDENTS
OF TODAY REALLY ENGAGE IN WAYS
THAT WILL HELP THEIR THEIR
EXPERIENCES -- I KNOW JUST TO
GIVE A LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT AND
AS A FOUNDATION WE RECENTLY GAVE
OUT.
A QUARTER OF A MILLION IN GRANTS
AND TOO MANY NOT NONPROFITS AND
PARK PARTNERS TO HELP.
OF PROVIDE COMMITTEE ACCESS TO
THESE AT PARKS IT WAS A DROP IN
THE BUCKET THE NEED IS SO GREAT
OUT THERE -- WHICH IS WHY THAT
CAN BE ACCESSED MONEY IS
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL AND WE KNOW
THE DEPARTMENT BELIEVES THIS AS
WELL.
I SO I'M REALLY LOOKING FORWARD --
TO FURTHER CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
GREATER STRATEGIES ON HOW WE
REALLY MAKE COMMUNITY ACCESS AB
A PRIORITY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS FOR THOSE COMMENTS WILL
CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING WILL BE
BACK NEXT WEEK.
DIFFERENT TOPIC.
TRANSPORTATION THIS WERE NOW
ADJOURN
[inaudible]
AS